react is one of the most popular JavaScript
frameworks in this comprehensive and well
made course. Thomas Weidman falck will teach
you everything you need to know to start using
react. Hello, and welcome. I'm Tomas vevo
to developer from Sweden. And thank you for
enrolling this course. I'm actually a little
bit of extra proud on this one, because I
created a lot of courses during the years
now, but this one is the first ever course
I created because I love react. And I wanted
to create courses. So this is the third iteration
the third version, meaning that I've improved
it a lot and listened to you guys on what
stuff you want in the course. So I think it's
actually really good. There's always room
for improvement, of course, but this one,
I really enjoyed this one. And it was fun
making it also. So hopefully, you'll find
a lot of basic stuff and intermediate stuff,
and maybe some advanced stuff to learn in
this course. And I think we have to get started.
So let's do that. Let's take a look at the
application that we're building in this course.
And it's a nice little move application that
is based on the Movie Database API. So you'll
have to create an account at the Movie Database.
But we'll do that in the next video. So I
thought I could show you the application so
that you have a little feeling about what
we're going to build in this course. And this
one is always going to show the most popular
movie here we have this hero image. So we're
going to create this one. And we also have
some text, and we have a header up here also,
then we can search for movies, or examples,
Star Wars. And we'll see all the movies here.
So that's how the basic functionality of this
application is. And if we click on the movie,
you can see that we get all data from that
movie. So that's nice. We're going to show
the actress and also some information about
the movie itself, we can see the revenue,
the budget, and the running time, for example.
And here, you may think that you can also
click on actors. And yeah, of course, we could
do that. But I have to limit this tutorial
somewhere. So this course is not going to
go there. But it's a great foundation, if
you want to build upon this application. So
you can add in the functionality of showing
information about the different actors and
stuff like that. We also have this little
breadcrumb menu appears, we can go back to
the homepage. And in this version of the course,
this is version three, I'm going to show you
how to create the styles also are going to
be fairly quick when I show the stars because
I still want to have the main focus on react
itself. So that's something that's new in
this version three of this course. And of
course everything is going to be responsive,
we're going to create that one also, as you
can see here, the grid, for example, with
the movies, it changes depending on the viewport
size. So that's nice. So it's a fully working
application. And to be honest, I'm quite proud
of this design, I created the design myself
course I'm both a developer and the designer.
So that's why I love doing design stuff also.
And I think it looks pretty neat. Actually,
I've updated it slightly, since two previous
versions to look a little bit more modern.
But I think it's mostly Yeah, I changed some
colors, for example, on the bottom and stuff
like that. Alright, so that's the application.
In the next video, I'm going to talk about
the Movie Database API, and how you can register
to get your own free API key that I'm going
to use in this course. Okay, so let's talk
about the Movie Database API. That's the API
that we're going to use in this course. And
the Movie Database has a great API for fetching
a lot of movies, TV shows and stuff like that,
we are going to focus on the movies. So that's
what we're going to do here. And you can sign
up for a free account at the Movie Database.
So just go to the movie db.org. And click
Join TMDB. And then you can fill out a username
and password an email and create an account.
And when you have created an account, you
probably get an email where you have to verify
yourself before you can log in. But when you
have created your account, make sure that
you go back to the movie DB and click on login.
And then you enter your username and password
just as a regular site that you log into.
All right, and then you're presented with
this dashboard kind of thing. I think it's
a dashboard. And the only thing you have to
do is go up here to your profile and click
on this round button up here. And then you
have the settings here so she'll settings.
And then at the left menu here, you can see
that you have something that's called API.
So click on API, I guess I probably have to
blur this ones out because I don't want to
show you my own API key. This is the one that
we using API key version three auth. So this
is the one that we're going to use. So make
sure to save this somewhere for now because
we are going to add it to our application
in a little while. So make sure that you have
easy access to this one as we're going to
paste this in into our application in a little
while when we have bootstrapped our application
with something that's called create react
app. And I'm going to talk more about that
in a little while. Before we start creating
our application, I just want to talk a little
bit about react and what it is. So if you
go to the React js.org, you can read more
about react. And this is a great starting
point, if you just started out with react,
they have different documentation, they have
tutorials, and a blog and stuff like that.
And you can read everything that you need
to know to get started with react. So I tried
to make this course kind of beginner friendly.
But react is kind of at least intermediate
in its own nature. So it's hard to make it
really, really beginner friendly. It also
depends a lot on how you learn stuff, I love
to learn stuff in this product oriented way,
where I just build some product and learn
along the way. So I only create courses on
how I want to learn stuff myself, but it's
very individual. So some may think that it's
not beginner friendly at all, and so many
things that it is. That's why I also recommend
to check out react js.org to read about the
very, very basic stuff, at least in react.
So what is react? Yeah, React is a JavaScript
library for building user interfaces, as they
tell you here, I think, actually that this
sentence is a little bit misleading, because
you're using react for so much more than to
just build a user interface. For example,
I build a lot of stuff, I build small games,
I build a Pac Man game, for example. And I
build all the logic in react also. So it's
not only the view layer, so it can be a little
bit misleading here, I think. Just thinking
about that you create the components for the
view. But that's not the case, you can use
react for so much more if you want to do that.
And in this application, we're building everything
in react. So we have all the API calls and
everything it's done from react. So that's
how we're going to use it in this course.
And react uses declarative peridinium. I don't
even know if I pronounced that correctly.
But hopefully, you know what I mean. So react
is declarative. But for example, jQuery is
imperative. And when something is declarative,
you explain, in this case, the user interface,
how it will look, you don't have to tell it
exactly how you want to achieve that look,
you just tell it that we want our UI to look
in a certain way. And then react takes care
of the rest. For example, in jQuery, we have
to grab the DOM elements. And we have to modify
the DOM elements. And we have to create them
row by row, and then attach the element to
the DOM itself. So there can be a lot of code
involved in doing something simple, actually.
But in react, for example, we have as the
Savior, it's component based. So we create
a component, and then we just tell react to
use that component. And it will render out
that to the dome for us. And this will be
more clear as we go along in the course and
create our own components and create the application
itself. So don't worry if you don't understand
everything right now. So it's declarative,
its component base and learn once write anywhere
yet as to tell you here, they don't care about
the rest of the technology stack. So that's
great, you can use a lot of stuff in combination
with react. So what is a react component?
Yeah, we can take a look here, for example,
here they create, this is a class and this
is kind of, I like to call it the old way,
the classes still exist, I don't use them
anymore. And in this course, we're going to
focus on creating functional components. And
I'm going to tell you more about that later.
And in the end of the tutorial, when we're
finished application, I also going to show
you how to convert some of the components,
the stateful components to class components,
just in case, you need to know how to create
class components also, because the reality
is, if you start working for a company or
a client, there may probably be some components
that are still class components. Because there's
a lot of applications made in react that's
made before we had state in functional components.
That's why you had to had a class before to
have stayed in them. And we're going to talk
about that later also. So this is a component
they created with a class and they call it
Hello message. And as you can see here, they
using something that's very much like regular
HTML, they have this tag here with a Hello
message. And this name is a so called prop
the sending in, and we're going to talk more
about props also later, so don't worry about
that. But this is actually not HTML. It's
something that called JSX. And that's something
that we're also going to learn in this course.
So we create the component here, we tell it
to use this component and react will take
care of the rest and create this div with
our text Hello. And in this case, it's going
to be the name that we send in with a prop.
So the name is going to be Taylor. It's going
to type out Hello Taylor. As you can see here.
So this is very, very neat with react, we
can reuse these components in our application.
So that's short on what react is. And as I
told you, we're going to learn a lot more
stuff in the course itself when we create
application. And hopefully, at the end of
the course, you'll have more understanding
of react and how awesome it is. Because I
really love react, I'm really passionate about
using react. And actually, this course is
also something that I'm very passionate about.
Because this is my first ever course I created.
And this is the third version, meaning that
I have listened to people that have enrolled
this course before and changed stuff and added
stuff to make it more optimal and more perfect.
And hopefully, you will enjoy this course.
For this course, I provided you with a sip
file that you should download before you start
the course. And this zip file contains a few
folders here, as you can see, and it may look
maybe a little bit different when I am the
recording of this course, because I haven't
really recorded it yet, but I think it will
look this way. But if it looks a little bit
different, it's okay. Hopefully you can read
the folder names and understand what they
for. So I'm going to provide you with a folder
that's called files to be copied to the project
folder. These are files that we're going to
use for the course. So I have created a file
for us the setups API, so we don't have to
write our own functions for fetching the data.
So I'm going to show you that when we fetch
data from the API, I have a config file and
a helpers file. And I'm going to talk more
about those later also. And then I have a
few images that we also need for the course.
So that's why I have this folder that we're
going to copy over to a project when we have
created it, and the public folder, the index
dot HTML file, I have this here, because I'm
using a Google Font for this one. So I've
already provided that one in the index dot
HTML, so we don't have to do that ourselves.
So that's the one that we have to copy later.
And I'm going to show you that when the time
comes. And you're also going to have two options.
If you don't want to create everything from
scratch, when I set up the application, you
can just ignore that and start from a project
without the styles. And this is if you want
to create the styles also, I structured this
course. So you should be able to fairly easily
just skip the parts where I create the styling
for the components. Some people have, you
don't want to create the CSS and the styling.
So that's why I made it in this way. So this
is the one you should use if you want to create
the styles. Otherwise, you use the one that's
called with styles, that one will provide
you with all the styling, so you don't have
to type in the styles. And you can skip those
videos. So if you want to start from one of
those projects, you navigate inside of that
one, and in your terminal, you type npm install,
and that's going to install all the dependencies
for you. And then every time you start up
the application, you can type in NPM start.
And that's also something that I'm going to
show you, so don't worry about that. Then
you have a folder with the finished app if
you want to check out the result. But please
be aware here, you have to put your own API
key in a file that's hidden here now is called
dot end. inside of that one, you have to paste
in your own API key, otherwise, it won't work.
And that goes for the step solutions. Also,
I have provided you with step solutions that
corresponds to each video. And if you want
to run an example, from a particular step
solution, you also have to paste in your API
key in the dot m file. And I also got to talk
more about the dot m file. But this is the
start of files. So you have to think about
if you want to create the styling in this
course, and you also have to think about now
if you want to set everything up from scratch.
Or if you don't want to do that, you can just
start from one of these folders here, navigate
inside Odin type npm install, or if you're
using yarn, you should be able to use that
one also. And then NPM start or yarn start
to start up the application. Alright, let's
move on in the next video. I'm just shortly
going to talk about the tooling that I'm using
for this course. Just a short, short little
video about what tooling I'm using for this
course, I think you already should know this
tooling and have it installed to be able to
fully take advantage of this course. Otherwise,
it can be a little bit hard. if you for example,
haven't used NPM that I'm going to use to
install dependencies. I suggest that you learn
about that first, because this is a beginner
slash intermediate course in react. It's not
a beginner course in coding, you should know
some JavaScript and especially iOS six syntax,
we're going to use a lot of iOS six syntax
in this course. So it should be a good idea
to shape up your knowledge in JavaScript before
starting to learn. react. But that's only
my opinion. But of course, you should do it
your own way. If you want to learn react before
vanilla JavaScript, it's totally up to you,
I shouldn't tell anyone on how they want to
take on their coding journey. All right, so
I'm using NPM. And that means that I have
to have node installed, we're not using no
de s, per se. But no, Deus includes the NPM
package manager. So that's why we have to
install that one. So if you don't have that
installed, make sure to grab the latest version
and install it. Then I use Visual Studio code
as my ID. So that's what I'm using in this
course. And then I'm going to use create react
app and bootstrap our react application really
fast and easy. So that's what we're going
to do. And I'm actually going to do that in
the next video. So let's get started with
our application. I'm happy to see that you're
going to create this project from scratch.
And we're going to use create react app to
bootstrap our application. So let's get started.
If we look at the homepage for create react
app, you can find it at create dash react
dash app dot Dev. And then they have something
here in the menu that's called get started.
And the only thing that we have to do is remember
this row here mpex, create dash react dash
app. And then you have the name of your application
that you want to create an empty x is something
that's provided with NPM in the latest versions,
so you don't have to globally install create
react app to use it, this will make sure that
we grab the latest version. So I always use
mpex, instead of first globally installing
create react app. So this is really great,
because then I know that I'm using the latest
version, and you don't have to install it
globally. But if you want to do that, you
can of course install create react app globally
first, but this is the command that I'm going
to use. So make sure that you navigate inside
of your terminal. I'm using a terminal that's
called hyper, I get a lot of questions about
that what terminal I'm using, I actually don't
remember the name of the theme, but I style
it a little bit to my likings. So that's sweet.
So hyper is a great terminal. If you want
to have a customized terminal. You also have
a built in Terminal in Visual Studio code,
of course. So let's get started, make sure
that you navigate inside of a folder where
you want to create the reputation. And then
we type in MP x and then create dash, React
dash app. And then we have the name of our
application. And I'm going to name it react
dash or dB. And RM DB stands for react Movie
Database. So that's the best I could come
up with. You can use whatever name you want.
And then we can hit Enter, and then wait for
it. It will install everything for us. So
it will take a little while. All right. Hopefully
that installed correctly for you. And create
react app has now hopefully bootstrap or application,
you could set up this yourself and not use
create react app. But create react app is
actually used in in many production applications.
And it's actually used right now for a client
that I work with. And it's a fairly large
application. So you can do a lot of stuff
with create react app. And it's using Babel
and Webpack in the background to set up direct
environment for you. So that's what you can
do yourself if you don't want to use crate
react app. But I'm not going to show that
in this course, because I think it's a little
bit advanced for a beginner course. And actually,
we're going to be fine with create react app,
that's all that we need. So we also want to
make sure that it works. So make sure that
you navigate inside of the product folder,
I'm going to clear this and then type in a
CD, React dash or MDB, or whatever you named
it. And then we're inside of that folder.
And then we can type NPM start. And it should
start up our environment. This is the finished
one that's here now. So it's going to be replaced
by this application here. So it's working.
And we have successfully bootstrap our application.
And that's sweet. In the next video, we're
going to install a few dependencies that we're
going to use for this project. We are bootstrap
the application. And now we're going to install
some dependencies that we're going to use
for this project. And the first one is going
to be something that's called react router.
And react router is the standard in react
application for handling routes, because this
is a single page application. And we need
something to handle or rolling because we
are going to have different pages. And the
one that we're going to use is called react
router. There is another library that's called
reach router. And I'm actually using that
one in version two of this course. But the
team that created reach router and react router
is the same team. So they're going to kind
of merge them together into react router,
version six. And this one is still in beta
mode, but I've talked to them and I think
that I should have this one in this course,
because it will soon be out. And the API won't
likely change because we're not going to use
the most advanced stuff in this router library.
So we will be fine. And we have some instructions
down here. I'm at github.com, forward slash
react training forward slash react dash router,
forward slash releases. And down below here,
we can see that we have some instructions
on how to install it. So I'm going to bring
up my terminal, do something like this. And
we could of course, just copy this one and
paste it in. But in my courses, I wanted to
learn as much as possible. And it's always
a great idea to not copy paste too much and
type stuff in because that will make you remember
stuff much easier. So that's what we're going
to do now. So I'm going to type in MPM II,
or if you're using yarn, you can, of course
use that instead, I'm going to use NPM for
this whole course. And I'm typing in I instead
of typing out the complete word install, that's
a short term for install. So NPM I, and then
we need to install something that's called
history. Also, that's another library that's
used in combination with react router, and
we can install them in one go. If I type history
here, then I have a blank space. And then
I can type in the other library that I want
install. And in this case, it's going to be
react dash, router, dash dome. And then we
have an add sign. And next, and this will
grab the better version of react router. So
press enter, and wait for it. Hopefully, that
installed for you correctly. So I'm going
to clear my console again. And we're going
to move on to something that's called styled
components, styled components is a super great
library to use in combination with react with
styled components, we can create our CSS in
isolated and scoped components. So that's
really, really great. And we have a lot of
features that we have, for example, in SAS,
we can do nesting and stuff like that. And
we can send him props and change our styling
dynamically. And we're going to talk more
about styled components as we go along in
this course, because we are going to create
the styling. If you choose that path there,
I really think you should if you want to have
some CSS practice, but it's up to you, I provided
you with different alternatives for this course.
So we're going to install style components.
And you can read more about it at style dash
components.com. So go back to the terminal,
and we type in MPM is styled dash components.
And we press enter. Alright, that went smoothly.
So clear the console yet again, and we move
on to the last dependency that we need. And
that is something that's called prop types.
Prop types is a great tool in react, where
you can type check your props that you send
into your components. So as they say, here
is runtime type checking for react props and
similar objects. So that's great. Today, a
lot of people use TypeScript instead, then
you don't need to use prop types. And I actually
use TypeScript a lot myself, I'm starting
to like it actually. But in our case, we're
not using TypeScript. Right. Now, I'm going
to show you that at the end of this course
in a special module that I created, where
we refactor everything to use TypeScript instead.
But for now, we're not using TypeScript. So
that's why we're going to use prop types.
And I'm going to talk more about this later
in the course. And I've placed it title at
the end of the course, because I don't want
too much stuff going on when we learn react.
So that's why, so I'm going to talk about
it at the end of the course. And when you
create a component that has some props, you
should use prop types to do type checking
on your props. But I'm not going to do that
first, I'm going to add it in later in the
course. So we don't get distracted or have
too much stuff going on. All right, to go
back to the terminal, type in NPM. I dropped
dash types, and press enter. So that's it.
That's our dependencies. And of course, I
didn't mention it at the start of this video,
you should of course be in the folder that
we created the application that we bootstrapped
with create react app, it's very important,
you have to navigate inside of that folder.
Otherwise, it won't work because we're installing
the dependencies in that project folder. Alright,
in the next video, we're going to copy some
files from the store to file c file to this
project that we're going to need to make this
work. If we look inside of our project folder,
React dash orientdb, we can see that we have
some different folders and files here. And
for example, if we look in the public folder,
we can see that we have some image files and
the index dot HTML file. And this is the folder
that the dev environment is going to build
for us. So the public folder is the finished
files that we're using for running the application.
So that's everything inside of there. And
the source folder. The src folder is going
to be the folder where we create all our stuff
for application. So you can see we have some
CSS file, we have an app file, an index file
and an index CSS file. We also have a test
file. We're not going to do any tests in this
course. So this one, we're not going to use.
And we have a service worker, we're not going
to use this one either. And we have the set
of tests that we're not going to use. If we
take a look inside of a zip file, the starter
files that you should have downloaded for
this course. And we take a look inside of
the first folder here, one files to be copied
to product folder. Alright, so that's the
files that gonna be copied to the project.
So make sure that you mark them here, copy
them, move back to your folder, your project
folder, and paste them in. And then you're
going to choose to replace the old folders.
This one is in Swedish here. So you probably
don't understand it if you're not from Sweden.
But what it says here is to replace it, so
I'm going to click that button. And then it's
going to ask me if I want to merge the source
folder or if I want to replace it. So if it
asks you to merge it or replace it, always
choose replace. All right, so we successfully
copied the files. And if we take a look inside
of the public folder, here, we're going to
have exactly the same files. The only difference
is that I've added in a Google import of a
font that's called Abel or Apple, I don't
really know, if I pronounce it correctly,
it sounds better to pronounce it, Abel. So
I think that's the correct one. That's the
only thing I've changed here. And that's the
in the index dot HTML file, the other files
remain the same. So that's the public folder.
And if we look inside of the src folder, you
can see that it's lesser files now. And that's
because I removed all the files that has something
to do with tests, or the service worker and
all the CSS files that we don't need, because
we're going to use styled components. And
I also added in some files and a folder, we
have the images folder. And this one, of course
contains the images that we're going to use
for this course. And then I have a file that
called API dot j s. And inside of this file,
there are some functions that are going to
handle the API calls to the Movie Database
API. And in the previous versions, we actually
created this ones ourselves in the course.
But I think that was just a distraction from
react and react syntax. Because this is a
course about learning react. And the thing
is that this is regular JavaScript inside
of this one, it has nothing to do with react
per se. So that's why I created this one for
you instead, and placed them in a file. And
of course, I'm going to talk more about these
functions when we reach that point in the
course. And then I have a config file. And
this config file contains everything that
has to be set up with a Movie Database API.
And I have a helpers file also, and help us
file contains a couple of functions that will
help us to convert some numbers into money,
and also to convert our time. And I'm gonna
talk more about these two files also, later
in this course. So these are the files, hopefully
this one will work. So if we go back to our
terminal, and this one is running now, so
just to be sure, I'm going to break it and
run NPM start just to see that it works. It's
always a great idea to see that stuff works
when you're sharing something. And then I
go to my browser and reload the page. And
you can see I'm at localhost 3000, just as
before. But now this nice little rotating
react logo is removed, and it says start here.
And that is because I removed that one. And
I've modified this file so that we can start
from here now in this application. So if it
says start here, you know that you successfully
copied all the files, hopefully, and it should
work for you. In the next video, we're going
to move on and actually use that API key that
you got when you registered for the Movie
Database API. Okay, we got one more thing
to do. And then we finished with the setup
of our project. And that is that we're going
to create a dot m file and paste in our API
key. So in our application folder at the root,
we're going to create a new file, I'm going
to call it dot E and V dot m, and create react
app has built in support for environmental
variables, the only thing that you have to
do is to name them with react first. So react,
underscore, and that's important, otherwise,
it won't recognize it. And this one is going
to be called AP underscore API underscore
key, all capital letters. And then we have
an equal sign. And then you can paste in your
API key here. And that's everything you have
to do. So just paste it in just after the
equal sign, and you're good to go. And save
the file. This API key is then used in the
source folder in my config.js file. You can
see that our get it to here, process dot n
dot react app API key. And this is all managed
inside of the Create react app. When it starts
up or dev environment and creates all the
files for us and stuff. It will take care
of these various really important to market
with react underscore before the actual name
of the environmental variable and all this
Here is something that I created for you.
So you don't have to care about this. So I
create the different resources from the endpoint
on the Movie Database here. And we're going
to use these resources in the course later.
And then I'm going to talk about more. So
I have different endpoints for the search,
for example, and to get the popular movies.
And this was our for the bonus videos at the
end, where I create the login, and voting
that also provided with the Movie Database
API, you can log in with your account, and
cast a vote on a movie, or on old movies.
If you want to do that. Then we have the image
base URL. This one is also from the movie
database. So these ones are provided from
the API. So just use them according to their
instructions. And we have a backdrop size,
we can set the size of the backdrop and the
poster size on the images, we can set different
sizes here and I mark them here for you if
you want to try to change them and see what
it does. So we don't have to think more about
these as I set them up for you. And there's
also a file, it's called API dot j s. And
inside of this one, I created the actual code
that is going to fetch the data, we can call
these functions later when we fetch the data.
And we don't have to type in all of this ourselves.
And of course, I'm also going to talk more
about these functions later when we fetch
the movies. So this one is for fetching all
the movies, and this one is for fetching one
movie. And then we have this one here that
will fetch the credits. And below here, these
are all for the bonus material also. So you
don't have to care about those in the kind
of main part of the course. So we have three
functions here that is going to fetch data
for us. So that's one thing I changed actually,
in this version of the course before this,
we created these ones ourselves in the course,
but I think it's a little bit advanced for
a beginner course. And I also think that it
takes the focus on react itself, because this
is JavaScript, it's not react specific code.
So that's why and I want this experience,
I want this course to be a fun course also.
So you don't get tired and stop the course
and won't finish it. So that's why I created
these ones for us. Alright, so that's the
config and a py file. And then I have one
more file that's called helpers dot j s. And
this one contains two functions, that's going
to help us to calculate the time and also
convert to money, because the numbers that
we get from the API has to be converted both
the time and the money. So I'm going to use
these ones later in the course also. Alright,
so create the dot m file, create a variable,
React underscore app, underscore API underscore
key capital letters equals and then you paste
in your API key. Otherwise, it won't work
because you can't access the API. one really
important thing to notice here is that this
environmental variable won't be safe, because
it will be visible in the client. So don't
think that this one won't show up in the browser,
of course, you have to look for it. But if
you're good at looking through code, you will
be able to find this API key. So this is not
a safe way to provide an API key if you want
to hide it from the browser. In our case,
it's not that kind of a secret key, that doesn't
matter. And for the sake of the course, it
would be too advanced to create a system that
will hide this for us completely. So notice,
this one won't be safe in the client. Before
we move on, I want to talk about a really
important aspect of react that I think a lot
of people actually forget. And that is when
we create stuff with react, we are also using
something that's called JSX. And it stands
for JavaScript, XML. And if we look here,
I'm at the React js.org page now, and they
show us here how to create the component.
And this is a class component. And as I told
you, before, we are going to create functional
components. So we're not going to create class
components for this application. But they
are using JSX. Here, and this is JSX. You
may think that this is HTML, but it's actually
not it's JSX. And JSX is something that is
really great to use in combination with react,
because we can render out our different components
like this by using HTML ish syntax. I think
a lot of people actually forget it. Because
I don't know exactly the percentage, but I
think at least 99% of the applications use
JSX. In combination with react, some people
don't use it. And that's what I'm going to
talk about here. Because you can create components
without JSX in react. And that is if we scroll
down here, you use something that's called
create element on the React objects react
dot create element, we specify if we want
some props. And then we specify the Child
Elements for this element. And you can see
up here, React dot create element, we have
the component that we want to create, we have
the props, and also we have the children and
this is the spread syntax in JavaScript, he
has six. That's why they use three dots here
to explain this though. This one Here is actually
the same as this, this one here, will transpile
down to react dot create element. But it wouldn't
be practical to use react dot create element
for every component and everything you do
in react, you can see that it's not that readable,
and it will get kind of messy. And I actually
think that react wouldn't be that fun to use
if you use it this way. So I'm just going
to show you how to create an element with
react dot create element also. And in the
next video, I'm going to talk more about JSX.
But now I'm going to show you just a small
example on how you can create an element with
react dot create element. So let's move back
to our terminal and make sure that our dev
environment is running. So NPM start, always
use NPM. Start, when you start up your dev
server, you can see that we have it running
here now. Then I go back to Visual Studio
code. And I'm going to be in the app.js file.
For this one, it's inside the src folder.
And this is kind of the heart of our application,
we have the index.js. That is the start file
for the application. And you can see the there
are import the app component here, these imports
are e6 syntax for import. So we can import
a model. And in this case, the model is a
component. And it's called app. So I import
that one here. And then it's used here and
this one is JSX. So this is the heart of our
application, we have both a library that's
called react. And we have react Dom because
react can be used for other stuff than the
DOM, for example, you can create native apps
with react. But we are going to use the library
react DOM. And this one is all set up with
create react app for us. So you can see that
from the React Dom that we import here, we
call the render method. And we give it the
component that we want to render. And we'll
tell it where we want to render it. So from
the document dot get element by ID, we get
the root element. So if we look inside a republic
and the index dot HTML, you can see that we
have a div here, that's called root. And it's
inside of this div, that we're going to render
out our complete application within close
to public folder node, and go back to the
index.js file. So we're telling react to render
our application to a div that's called route.
And it's also in something that's called react
strict mode. It wasn't that before. But this
is a default. Now with great drag that in
strict mode is actually great. It's going
to do a few more checks if you do some stuff
that it shouldn't be doing when you code your
application. So it's always a good idea to
using the strict mode in react. Alright, so
let's move back to the app.js file. And as
you can see, here, we have this element here,
we have the div that's called AP. And I render
out start here. And that's the one that we
saw before, when we started up the application.
You don't have to type this in if you don't
want, because I want to show you this, this
has nothing to do with application that we're
going to build. So I'm going to create a little
component now. And then I'm going to remove
it and we can continue on creating our application.
I'm going to do it with an arrow function,
I like to use arrow function, they don't do
it here. But you can change this one if you
want to an arrow function const app equals,
and then we create an arrow here instead,
like that, I'm used to using arrow functions.
So I use them for components also. So const,
I'm going to create a component that's called
store, and I have an arrow function. And then
from react, we import react here, you always
have to import react at the top, and another
call create element, I have a parenthesis,
I'm going to create a div. And then we're
not going to have any props because we haven't
talked about props yet. So I set that one
to now, and then I'm going to render out the
screen. This is a little store like that,
and I'm going to remove the sidebar, we can
see the component here. So this is instead
of using JSX. And if we want to render this
one out, instead of returning this one here,
I'm going to return the store. And as this
is the function now, I also have to call it
like this, save it. And then I'm going to
go back to the application. And you can see
this is a little star, so it renders out perfectly.
And this is just a small example. And I want
to just for you to notice that you don't need
to use JSX. And this is actually the React
functionality at its core. So you don't have
to use JSX. But we are going to use JSX because
it's sweet, and it's fun to work with. And
I think actually that it would be a small
l creating applications without JSX at least
I think so. So, I remove everything I created
here and save the file. Again, just make sure
that it works stored here. And it works and
that's great. So that's a little bit about
react dot create element and using react Without
JSX, just a small, small note on that one,
I'm not going to go any deeper into it, because
I don't think it's actually relevant to use
react without JSX. So that's why. Okay, I
talked a little about using react without
JSX. But I actually don't think that's a great
idea. So that's why I also want to talk a
little about JSX before we move on with this
application. So JSX stands for JavaScript,
XML, and it's pretty similar to regular HTML.
So if we take a look here, you can see that
they create an h1 tag here that says hello
word. And this looks just like plain HTML.
But as they say, here, this fun attack syntax
is neither a string nor HTML, I actually don't
think it's a fun attack as to say here, but
alright, you get the ID, why JSX. We can read
here more about why we are using JSX. And
the main thing here thing is that they don't
want to put markup in one file and logic in
another file, they want to have them combined
in one file. And that may sound scary for
some, because a couple of years ago, you shouldn't
ever mix them together. But in react, it works
really great. And as they say, here, rack
components contain both markup and logic.
So JSX is something that is created to look
pretty similar to HTML, there are a few differences.
And I wanted to talk about those here. Because
in this case, we create an h1 element. And
that looks exactly the same. But there are
some stuff that differ from regular HTML.
And for example, you can see you can embed
JavaScript as expressions here. For the source
area in the image tag, for example, you can
use curly brackets, and then you embed your
JavaScript expression. And that's super great
that you can combine them this way. And also,
as you look at tab index, it's camel cased
that differs from HTML. And they say it here
also seems JSX is closer to the JavaScript,
then to HTML, react, Dom uses camel case property
naming convention instead of HTML attribute
names. So remember that, that you have to
use camel case in JSX. And there are some
few differences. For example, when you set
a class on an element, you don't use the class
keyword, you use class name, camel cased.
And they also mentioned it here. And it took
a little bit of time for me to get used to
this one. And no, I actually typing class
name when I type out regular HTML. And also,
it's good to know that JSX is quite safe,
it prevents injection attacks and stuff like
that. So I think you'll learn a lot about
JSX. As we go along in this course, because
we are going to use practical examples in
this course, not the most important part is
to remember that JSX is not HTML. And it's
also used camel casing when you create an
attribute. Before we dive in and create our
components with state and props, and all these
vital things in react, you can sit down, relax,
have a drink, have a beer, have a cup of tea,
or whatever you're drinking. And just listen
to me in this video, where I'm going to talk
a little about props and state in react, the
first thing you can do is to imagine that
this is a room seen from above. And the gray
circle here is a lamp that's not turned on.
And the orange one is a lamp that's turned
on, each of these lamps has a light switch
that is often on. So if I click this one here,
I can turn this light on and the light switch
is going to change to on. And this one I can
turn it off. So both lamps are off, and I
turn this one on, and I turn this one on.
And this is made possible because I can use
state in react. So I have two states for the
lamps. I have one state for the first time
and one for the second lamp that is a Boolean
that is telling if the lamp is on and off.
But if we think about this, we actually have
a state of the room also, because we need
a state also for the light switch to change
from off to on. Because these are kind of
tied together so that you can look at the
state in different perspectives. In this case,
I will look at the state from the room perspective.
So I haven't placed the states in the lamps
or in the light switches, I have placed the
states in the room itself because we have
a room stage and for the room is going to
be if the lamps and the light switches are
on or off. So we have a state for the room
itself. And this is what I talked about in
the for example the React documentation, they
tell you that you can lift up the state to
a parent component if you want to use that
stayed in multiple child components. Because
if we placed the state in the lamp itself,
for example, we could only access that state
in the lamp unto its child components. Of
course, we could place the light switches
as a child to the lamp, but that wouldn't
be the most effective way of doing it. And
it would complicate things if you want to
reuse your code. So what I've done here is
study is that I had this room here and I placed
the components in the room and I'm also going
to have the state in the room so we can use
that state both for the lamps and the light
switches and I'm going to show you how Do
this now, and also talk a little bit more
about state and props. So if we take a look
inside of the code here, this is the application
that I created for you. You can also open
it up from the source files in this course,
I provided it there. So I have the index file,
the standard index file that shows the app
component, and app component is actually going
to be the room. So I could also name this
room because this is actually the room component.
And as you can see here, in the room component,
I'm creating two states. In react when you
create a state with hooks, you use something
that's called the use state hook. Before we
had hooks, we had to use classes to have state
in them. So you couldn't ever create a functional
component that has stayed in them. But now
we have hooks, and that means that we can
have stateful functional components. And that's
sweet. So when we call this use state hook,
we can initialize it with an initial value.
So in this case, I'm giving it false, because
I want this lamp to be turned off initially.
Then I do something that's called ear six
destruction here on destruction of this array
that I get back from the use state hook. So
we can name our state here to whatever we
want. In this case, I name it is lamp one
on and then we have the Center for the state
center is lamp one on. And there's a few things
you should know about state in react. And
the first one is that you should look at the
state as immutable, you should never mutate
the state, then that means that you always
should use the state setter that you get back
to set the state in react. If you're modifying
the state directly, for example, try to change
this one. This means that your component won't
rerender. And that's no good. And it can also
cause a lot of trouble in the future for you
in the application. But if you use the setter
and change the state and don't mutate the
state, your component will rerender and update
the DOM. And this is how stuff works in react,
you update the DOM when your components rerender.
And one more thing with functional components
is that we can add as many states as we want
with the use state hook in the class components,
you can only have one state, so you have to
turn to create an object with different properties
to hold your state. So this is super sweet,
we can divide the states up now depending
on how we want to structure the state. So
in this case, I created two states, I have
one for the lamp one, and I have one for lamp
two. So they are doing the exact same thing.
The only difference here is when I initialize
it, I set this one to true and this will turn
lamp two on. Alright, now I have two functions.
And these ones are going to be called when
we click the light switch. So I have one for
the light switch one and one for the light
switch two, you could have one function instead.
But I want to make it really, really clear
on how stuff works. So that's why I created
two of them. So we have one function for the
switch one and one for the switch two. And
this one will set is lamp one, that's the
setter for the state one for the lamp one.
And what I do here is that I provide it with
an inline function. And when you provide the
state setter with a function, it will get
called with the previous state. So in this
case, I'm going to flip that boolean value.
So when I click the button, the first time
this value is going to get be true instead
because it's false initially. And this one
for a button two is going to be false because
it's true. All right, these are functions
for a light switches. So if we looked at the
JSX, here, what we return to the dome, this
one is a room component. And if I go up here,
you can see that this is the style component
that we're also going to talk a lot about
in this course, I create a style component,
that's a div here. So I set some styling on
that one on the room itself, I make it 500
pixels width and 500 pixels in height, then
I set a border on it, and the margin zero
in order is going to center it on the screen.
So everything is wrapped in this room component,
then I have a component, that's the lamp,
I'm going to talk about that in a second.
And I also have the light switch. So we have
the state in this app component. That's the
room. So this is where I kind of gather all
the states for this little simple application.
And this way, I can use this state in both
the lamp component and the light switch. Because
as you can see here for the lamp component
i created something that's called props, props
is something that you can create and that
will get sent along into your component that
you create props is an object. So you can
create as many properties on that object as
you want. In this case, I created a lamp on
Prop. So this one will be sent into the lamp
component in the prop object. I also created
a prop that's called position. And this is
how I can make the lamp appear on the left
or on the right in the room. And lamp on is
going to be the state for the lamps. So this
one is going to be a Boolean. And that way
this component will know if the lamp is on
and off. And I'm going to show you that in
a second. And I do the same with a light switch.
And for this one I have the callback as I
showed up here. I give this one a prop that
I call callback. It doesn't have to be Call
callback, that's the name that I chose. And
the switch on, I'm going to give it a lamp
state for this one. So you can see that I
use the lamp states for both the lamp and
the light switches. And this is what I talked
about before, if we created the state for
the lamp in the lamp itself, we wouldn't be
able to access this state for the light switch,
then we have to create the light switch as
a child of the lamp. And that's no good, as
you probably can see now, because now we can
place as many lamps and light switches we
want in our room. So it would be much harder
to do it if we place the stain in the lamp
itself. And I also have a position prop for
the light switch. So let's go inside of the
lamp component that I created here. I also
have a wrapper div for this one that's a styled
component. So I wrap everything in that div.
And the interesting thing with style components
is that they also can have props because they
are also valid react components. So we can
use props in our style components to modify
our CSS. And that's one of the super strengths
with style components, I think, because as
you can see here, this is this is something
that's called a template literal. And in this
template literal, we can grab the props that
are sent into this component. So in this case,
I create dollar sign and curly brackets, and
I can use a JavaScript expression. And I have
this inline function here that gets the props.
So if we look at the wrapper component down
here, you can see that I also send in a prop
lamp on and the position. So I'm just sending
along these props that are initially sent
into the lamp component. So I get them in
the lab component, and then I also send them
along to the wrapper component. That's the
style component. And by doing this, I can,
for example, check here, if the props dot
position equals to the left, then I'm going
to set the left value to 20 pixels. Otherwise,
I set it to three or underneath two pixels,
and that will place it to the right in the
room. So this way, I can modify my CSS and
make it very, very dynamic. So that's really
sweet that you also can use props in the style
components. Alright, that's how style component
and props works. So if we look at the lab
component here, I'm sending in these props
here. And what I'm doing here is I'm using
iOS six destructuring. So from the objects
that we get that you usually call it props,
I'm destructuring out these values that are
sending, if I didn't do the destructuring
here, and I just do it like this, you can
see that it wants me here now, then I have
to type in props, dot and props, not because
the props is an object, so I have to grab
those specific properties from the toggle.
But if I destructor it out as I do, here,
I don't have to type that in every time. So
I just structure out the properties here instead.
And there's a few things you should know about
props because they differ from state. And
the main difference is that the props are
passed into the components. And you should
never ever change the props in the component
that gets the props, the props, values are
changed from the parent that is sending in
the props to the component. So if the props
change in the parent, it's also going to rerender,
this component here. So never ever change
the props values in this component, you can
change the state in the component with a state
setter. And that's how you, for example, can
trigger a rerender. When you change the state
in a component. So that's fine, you should
change the state in the component with the
setters. But a prompt should never be ashamed
in a component that receives the props. When
the prop value changes, this component will
rerender and it will have the new value in
the props. So that's how props works. All
right, we can check out the light switch.
Also, I'm doing the same here I am destructuring
out the props here. And I have this bottom
component. That's the star component. And
I modify it with props here also. So I'm doing
the exact same thing here. And you can see
here that are sending the callback, that's
the function that I have in the app component
here. So that's the one I'm sending in with
a callback prop into the light switch. And
then I have my button, and the button has
an onClick handler an onClick handler will
trigger this callback function. And this makes
this component very dynamic because by using
props, you can make your component dynamic.
And you can use it in different situations.
In this case, I can send in whatever callback
function I want to be triggered when I click
on the button. So that means that I can use
this button in different situations. In this
case, I also showing the switch on and off
because I was sending in the prop switch on.
So it probably won't be useful, too much less
than this use case specifically. But if you
want you can use this button for something
else done to trigger a lamp to be turned on
or off, you can turn something else on and
off and have another callback function and
that will work. So that's what you use props
for. Also, you can make your components dynamic
and reusable by giving them some props. And
by using these props inside of the component.
You can adapt your component and change the
logic you can change the JSX and what it should
render and stuff like that. So that is really
useful to us. props for that. Alright, so
that's short on state and props. I hope this
one gave you some insight before we start
creating our own. So let's move on in the
next video, I'm going to talk more about style
components and what they are. There's one
less thing I want to talk about before we
start creating some code for real. And that
is styled components. Because in the next
video, we're going to create a global styles
for our application. And we're going to do
that with styled components. So just a short
talk about style components and why it's so
great. And I think the biggest benefit is
one that you get scoped CSS. And that means
that you can have the same class names for
different components, it doesn't matter because
it's scoped to that component. And number
two is that you can use syntax, kind of like
sass, for example, you can nest stuff, and
you don't need to have polyfills, and stuff
like that, it will create all that automatically
for you. And number three, is that you can
have props inside of it. And props is something
that we're going to talk a lot about in this
course, because it's an essential part in
react. And that means that you can modify
the CSS by sending in different props to your
styles, you don't need to know exactly now
how props work, because we're going to talk
about that later in the course. And also,
you can use just plain regular CSS, and that's
super great also. So that is some benefits
that style components will provide to you
when using it in your application. So we already
install this library. And when you use it,
you have to import something that's called
style, I think they have an example down here,
here, input styled from styled components.
And style is an object that holds different
properties. For example, in this case, they
want to style a bottom. So these properties
corresponds to what they are called in HTML.
So if you want to style a button, if you want
to create a style component, that is a button,
you use style dot button, and then you have
a template literal. So this is something that's
called a tag template literal. And that is
a function that you call with a template literal.
So this is e6 syntax in JavaScript. And it's
super great, because if we move up here, again,
you can see, we have this template literal.
Here, you have the starting backtick. And
you have the end back to here. And inside
of here, we can write our CSS. In this case,
they're using style dot A, because they want
to style an a tag. And then they do some stuff
here, plain regular CSS. But here is something
that's happening. That's not plain CSS. And
this is because we using a template literal
here, we can use JavaScript expressions inside
of this template literal. And when you want
to use an expression inside of a template
literal, you do that with $1 sign, and you
wrap it inside of curly brackets. And then
you can have any JavaScript expression that
you want inside of here, and it will interpolate
it into the string. And in this case, you
can see that they have their props, and they
have an inline arrow function. And from the
props, they grab a prop. That's called primary.
And you can set this CSS conditionally, depending
on this primary prop. And we're going to talk
more about this later, as I told you, so don't
get intimidated. If you don't understand this
syntax right now, hopefully, you will understand
it fully when this course is over. This is
just a short introduction, before we create
the global styling. And we're going to do
that in the next video. It's time to start
coding. And we're going to start by creating
some global styles. The first thing you have
to do is to start up your dev environment.
And you do that by navigating inside of the
folder of your application. And then you type
NPM start, and that will start everything
up for you. And hopefully it looks something
like this, it should say start here. And it's
always a good idea to have your console open.
I'm on Chrome now. So it looks something like
this. And also I can recommend an extension.
That's called react developer tools. And then
you will have access to something that's called
components here. And if we open that up, we
can see our application here. But in this
case, we don't have any components yet. So
it will just show the app component here.
But this is a great tool when you develop
stuff in react. So highly recommended install
react developer tools. Okay, so let's move
back to our application inside of Visual Studio
code, or whatever ID or using an inside src
folder, we're going to create a new file that
I'm going to call that I'm going to call global
style, capital G and capital s.js. So this
is going to hold all the global styles for
our application. And we're going to create
a global styles with style components. So
that's why we have to import a special thing
from the style components. That's called create
global style. So we start by doing that import
curly brackets. Create Lobel style camel case,
that means that there's a capital D and a
capital S. And we ported from style dash components.
And this is how we import the module with
e6 syntax. In this case, it's not what's called
the default export from this library. So that's
why we grabbing it inside of the curly brackets,
we are going to create default exports from
our different components. And then we don't
need to use the curly brackets. But I'm going
to show you that later when we create our
first component. Okay, so we have this create
global style method that we imported. Here,
we are going to use a global styles inside
of our app component later, meaning that we
want to import it here and use it down here
in the JSX. So that also means that we have
to export this styled component from this
file, so export. And this is a const. Also
e6 syntax, it stands for constant. So that's
what we have in JavaScript. Now we have let's
we have const. And we have various, I'm always
using const. Before I know if this one is
going to change, and then I change it to a
left, it's going to change in the application.
But usually const will do, at least when you
do functional programming, as we mostly going
to do in this course. So const means that
this one is not going to change. As with everything,
there are special cases when it can change.
For example, if you create an object with
a const, you can change the properties in
that object, but you can't change the object
itself. Alright, enough about that. This one
is going to be called Global style. And this
is a component, and every component that you
create in react is going to have a capital
letter to begin with. So capital G and capital
S in this case, and it's going to equal and
then we call this method that we imported
up here, create global style. And in this
case, we're not going to have a dot and something
here because this is the global style. So
we're going to have double backticks, creating
our template literal. And then I do like this.
And then we can write our CSS inside of this
template literal. And the rest of your is
going to be regular plain CSS. So first, I
want to set up some CSS variables. To call
on Route, we do that on the route. And when
you create a CSS variable, you do that with
double dash. And then you have your variable
name. So max width, this is camel cased, as
you can see here, are going to set the max
width to 1280 pixels. And then I have another
variable double dash white. And then I set
my white color, another variable double dash
light gray. This one is going to be E double
dash med grade, or medium grade. And this
one is going to be 335 re 535 double dash,
dark gray. And this one is one c one c one
C double dash font super big. That's a funny
name, I forgot that I call it that. All right,
you can call it whatever you want. This one
is going to be 2.5 REM. And the next one is
double dash and font big 1.5 REM double dash
font med or medium 1.2. REM. And the last
one is going to be double dash font small,
one REM. And that's our CSS variables that
we're going to use for this application. Then
I'm going to set the font for the whole application
and also do some resetting here. So I have
an asterisk. Like that, I set the box sizing
to border dash box. And then I set the font
family to able and that's the Google Font
that is important from the index dot HTML
file. And then a how to backup font or sans
serif. Alright, that's the resetting then
on the body. I'm going to set a few things
also. So we're going to set the margin zero,
the padding is going to be zero, like that.
And then as I told you with start components,
you can nest stuff inside of the body, we
can nest the h1 tag like this, and set the
font size to two REM font weight is going
to be 600 and the color and I'm going to grab
this from my variables that I created up here.
And when you grab a variable in CSS, you do
that by typing out various parenthesis and
then the variable name in this case it's going
to be double dash white. So that's the h1
then I'm going to set the age three The font
size is going to be 1.1 or M. And the font
weight is going to be 600 on that one also.
And then one more thing to do here, and that's
the p tag. So font size, one REM for the p
tag, and the color is also going to be white.
So var, double dash white. And then I also
do some auto formatting. And sometimes when
I do this, create global styling, the auto
formatting doesn't work. I don't know why.
So I do it manually instead and save the file.
Always remember to save your files, it's very
easy to forget to save the file, and then
it doesn't work. So this is everything that
we need for our global styles. Now we're going
to move inside of the app.js file. And up
here where we import react, we can mark it
with styles. And then we import global style
from dot forward slash global style. So this
means that we import in this one that we created
here, this constants called Global style,
we can import it because we export it inside
of this file. We don't do a default export,
as I'm going to show you when we create components.
That's why we use curly brackets and import
this as a named import. And we're importing
it from the file that's called Global style.
You don't have to type out.js. It's enough
we just typing out global style, it will figure
the file extension out itself. Right there
we have our global stock component. But how
do we use it in our application, we should
place this at the top level of our application.
And as we're going to have a component that
wraps are complete application. In this case,
it's the div that's called app, it has a class
name of app, we're going to change this out
later when we have the routing setup. But
for now, that's a wrapping div. So inside
of that one, we can use a global style. And
we self close it like this, we don't have
any props to send into this one. And we're
not setting a class name or stuff like that.
So when you use the playing component without
class name, and props in react, you do it
like this. And this is very similar to an
HTML tag. So we save the file, go back to
a browser. And the only thing we can see now
is that the margins and padding have changed
here, it's just right at the edges here now.
And it wasn't that before. So we know that
our global styles are working. And we can
actually just comment this one out, save the
file, go back to a browser. And you can see
that the margin is there now. That way, we
know that it's working. And hopefully we didn't
do any mistake in the CSS itself. So it should
work. Otherwise, we have to adjust that later.
All right, in the next video, we're going
to start creating the header component for
the application. So we're going to create
our first real component in this application.
And it's going to be the header component.
So the first thing we do when we create a
new component is to create a file for that
component. And you can see that we have our
src folder here and we have an images folder.
But we don't have a folder, that's going to
hold our components by usually create a folder,
that's called components. That's what I'm
going to do now. components, all lowercase
letters, and inside of this folder, we're
going to create all of our components. And
the thing is that the structuring of an application
is something that's highly subjective. So
you can have your own opinions on how you
want to structure it. And if you want to structure
it in a different way, you can of course do
that. But please be aware that this course
will have this folder structure. And you have
to think about it. If you change stuff yourself.
If you just want to focus on learning react,
I highly recommend that you use this folder
structure that I created for the course, I
also going to have a folder for each component
because I want to separate out my styles and
have the styles in separate file and have
the component itself in a separate file, I've
created this course you don't have to create
the styles if you want. So that's easier for
me to handle it that way by separating the
mouth. So therefore, I also think it's nice
to have everything related to component in
its own folder. So we're going to create a
new folder inside of the components folder.
That's called header. capital H. So we inside
the header folder, and this is something in
Visual Studio code. It won't show a complete
tree structure here when you just have one
folder. But this will change later. But we're
inside a header folder. And inside a header
folder, I got to create a new file that's
called index.js. And this is also something
that's highly subjective actually, because
I'm going to create my component in the index.js
file. So we're going to have one folder for
each component, and each folder is going to
have an index dot j s file. And this is great
when you import stuff as I'm going to show
you later. But it's not that great if you,
for example, have 10 components open up here,
they all are going to be named index dot j
s. So that's the downside by doing it like
this. But this is a fairly small application.
So I don't think it matters. But I can actually
show this if we have a component that's named
test component, we import it like this. And
from dot forward slash, we have our folder,
that's called test component. Like this, of
course, we don't have this one Oh, this is
just an example. It's exported as a default
export. So we import it like test component
without the curly brackets, we can name it
to whatever we want. But I like to name them
just exactly as they are in the files. And
we import it from the test component folder.
And then if we have a file, that's called
index.js, we don't have to type out anything
more here, it will automatically grab that
index.js file. But if we named this file,
for example, test component, also, we have
to specify it like this. We have to type it
out two times. And I don't like to have to
type it in two times. So that's why I'm using
an index.js file instead, as this is a fairly
small application. So we don't get confused
up here when we have a lot of components open.
So that's my explanation to why I'm using
this structure. And that's also why are named
my files like this. Alright, so delete this
one here, we're also going to create placeholder
components for the styles, because we're going
to use the style components inside of this
component itself. So that's what we're going
to do. And we do that by creating another
file. That's called heather.styles.js. And
this is how I like to name my style component
files. So I have the component name, and then
I have a dot, and then I mark it with styles.
And then I have a.on, the file extension.
Alright, so from the style components, we
import styled, like this import style from
style components, components, it should be
an S. Now, I'm just going to create placeholder
components because I am going to create the
styles in the next video. So if you have choose
to skip the styles, you don't have to do them.
Justice before, you always have to export
these ones, because they are in a separate
file, and we are going to import them in the
index.js file soon. Export const I have a
component that I like to name wrapper, and
it's going to be a style dot div. So this
is a div that I'm going to start. And I just
have the double takes. And I ended there because
this is just a placeholder now, so we could
just copy this one. But as I told you, I want
to repeat stuff and type it in many times
when you learn things. So we export const,
I have another component that is going to
be called content. And it equals from the
start, we have another div double backticks
and then we export const logo, IMD and it
equals a style. And this is an image, it's
the logo that we're going to style, double
backticks and and it and then we export const
TMDB logo. img, be careful with the capital
letters here. This is the Movie Database logo.
So capital TMDB, capital L and capital II.
From the styled, we're going to style another
image like this. So this is the four style
components that we're going to use for this
react component. So save the file, and I'm
going to show you in the next video, how to
create the styles the actual CSS, but move
inside of the index.js, we're going to create
our header component. Now, the first thing
you do when you create a react component is
to import react capital or from react. And
that will make sure that we are using react
in this component. Then I have some images
for the logo. So if we look inside of the
image folder, I have the TMDB logo. This is
an SVD. So we just see some code here. And
then we also have the React movie logo. And
that's also an SVG. So move back to the index
dot j s, we're going to import this ones now.
So import our IMDb logo, you can name it to
whatever you want here, but I chose to name
it RMD v logo, you could just name it logo,
of course if you want to do that, but I want
to separate them out because we're going to
have the TMDB logo also. And we're going to
import it from dot dot forward slash that's
in the header folder that we want to go up
one more folder so dot dot forward slash again.
And then we have our images folder. And then
we grab the React dash movie dash logo dot
SVG. In this case, it's really important that
you also type out the SVG extension, otherwise
it won't work when it's an image. So that's
the rmvb logo. Then we import the TMDB logo
from doc dot forward slash dot dot forward
slash images, forward slash TMDB, underscore
logo dot SVG, like this. And as you can see,
this can be a really long file path here.
And that's no good. In some cases, of course,
you could set up this with create react app,
so you use absolute important step. But I
choose to not do this in this course, as I
want this to be kind of beginner friendly.
And to be honest, we're not going to have
that long file path. So that's why Okay, so
that's our logos. That's our images for the
logos down, we're going to import the styles
that we created inherit old styles dot j,
s, because we export them here, as I told
you, so we want to import them in this component.
So import curly brackets, we have our wrapper,
we have our content. We have our logo, IMD,
we have our TMDB logo, no logo, IMG TMDB logo
IMG. And we're going to import this once from
dot forward slash header dot styles ended
with a semi colon. I'm going to remove this
sidebar here so we can see what we're doing.
That's it, we have everything we need to assemble
this component for now. So we're going to
create a component that's named header. And
we're going to use just functional components
in our application, because now you can have
stayed in your functional components. A couple
of years ago, you had to create a class if
you want to have some state, but now we have
hooked and we can use just functional components.
So I like to create my components with an
arrow function. So cost header equals parenthesis,
and a fat arrow. And that's an arrow function,
you can have regular function if you want
to have that also. And then of course, you
just do it like this instead function header.
You have curly brackets, but I like to have
the arrow function. And that's because you
can make an implicit return like this, if
we just returning JSX, we can add parentheses,
and you don't need to type out return. And
in our case, we're going to have the wrapper.
That's the style component that we created.
And inside of the wrapper, we're going to
have the content. That's also a style component
that we created. And then I'm going to have
the logo IMG. And we can set the source on
this one because this is an image tag that
we styled. So we can use the same attribute
the SRC is going to equal and we have imported
our our IMDb logo, or IMDb logo, like this
was set on OLT. Now we can name it or IMDb
dash logo. And then we can self close it like
this. So that's a logo for this application.
And we have the Movie Database logo TMDB logo,
IMG we have the SRC, it's going to be the
TMDB logo IMG and we set the old TMDB dash
logo, and we self close it, do some auto formatting.
And now you can see. Okay, I just named it
TMDB logo, of course, that style component,
we shouldn't use that. So TMDB logo course.
Now you can see that it complains here, because
we're not exporting this one, it says it's
never used. And that's because we don't export
it. You should always export it. And I like
to do the export here at the bottom. So export
default header. And this is also a sixth syntax
for exporting something. So in this case,
we don't have a named export, we export it
as a default. Some people like to have their
export here, instead, I don't like that. So
that's why I have it at the bottom here. But
you can do however you want. And this is our
header component for now. But we're not actually
using it. If we go back to our application
here, you can see that nothing has happened
because we have created a component, but we're
not actually using it yet. So we have to do
something about that. So let's go back to
our app.js file. And inside of this div here
the wrapping div. This is also something that
you have to know because in react you can
always just return one component, you have
to wrap the components if you have multiple
of them in another component or in something
that's called a fragment that I'm going to
talk about later in this course. So inside
of here, we're going to have Our header component,
but first, we have to import it, of course.
So what I like to do, I like to mark it with
components, like this. And then I import Heather
from dot forward slash components forward
slash Heather. Like this, when you want to
use a component in react, you have to import
it first like this, this is a module that
we import, our component is a module that
we import with EF six syntax like this, right,
and then we can use the component here for
now we don't have any props for this one.
So just as we did with the global style, we
can insert the component here down in the
JSX. And we have our header. So do some auto
formatting and save it. And if we go back
to our browser, you can see that we can't
really see the images now. And that's because
we haven't set the styling for the images
now. So that's what we're going to do in the
next video. Or if you choose to not create
the styles, you probably will see the header
up here. Now if you're using the styles that
you copied over to your product folder, but
in the next video, we're going to create the
styles and that will make the header show
up with the logos we have created or had a
component, but we can't really see anything.
So we have to create the styles for it. Also,
you can see it. Yeah, it looks like crap here.
So we have to give this some styling also.
So we see it have nice little logos and or
header. So inside our file, that's called
header.styles.js. We're going to start by
creating the reference style component, we're
going to set the background on that one background.
And from our variables, we're going to grab
the one that called dark gray, like this.
And then I'm going to give it some padding
zero and 20 pixels. And that will give it
some padding on the sides. We'll save it,
go back to our browser. And now you can see
that we see all gigantic logos here on our
gigantic header. So we have to do something
about this one also. So we have our content
div. This one is going to be displayed as
a flex, because I want to place the logos
on the left and the right. And we can do that
with flex. So first we align items to center.
And this will align them vertically. And then
we justify the content. And we set it to space
between and this will create space between
them and push them to the side one is going
to be pushed to the right and one is going
to be pushed to the left. And I'm also going
to set the max width of this one. And that's
why I also have a container that called content
because the rapper is going to have this background
of dark gray. But I don't want the content
itself to have the full width, the max width
is going to be from our variable dash dash
max with like this. And I'm going to set some
padding at the top and bottom are 20 pixels
and zero on the sides. And I set the margin
to zero, all and this will center the content
div itself, save it go back and see what we've
got so far, you can see that they are pushed
to the size. And that's great. Flexbox is
really neat to do stuff like this, but the
size isn't correct on the logo. So we have
to modify this. So we have our logo IMG. That's
the main logo, and that's the style image,
we set the width to 200 pixels on this one,
save it, go back to the application, you can
see that we have the correct size here. But
we also want to change this size on the logo
when we are on smaller devices. So we create
a media query at media screen and Max dash
with I don't really know if you need to actually
use screen today. I think it's not necessary,
but I'm used to that. So I will do that. I
set the max width to 400 pixels. This means
that when the screen size is lesser than 500
pixels, this one will kick in. So we set the
width 150 pixels on that one, save it go back
to our application and see what we got. So
I can make this smaller. And you can see that
there. The logo gets smaller also. So we know
that the media query is working. And this
is also something that's super great with
styled components, because you can nest the
media queries as I did inside of this component.
I think this is very readable to do it like
this because you know that this specific media
query belongs to this component. All right,
so that's the main logo. Then we just have
the style, the TMDB logo also. I'm going to
set the width 200 pixels on this one. And
then I set a media query on this one also
at media screen and Max with 500 pixels. So
it may see seem redundant to have two of them
here. But actually, as I told you, I think
this is very readable. If you want to change
a media query for just that component, you
can do that inside of the nested media query
here. And I like that a lot. So for this one,
I'm going to set the width to 80 pixels, and
save it, go back to the application. And there
you have it, this is our header. And you can
see that it's working on both of the logos
when we make the viewport smaller. Sweet,
that's the stars for the header. In the next
video, we're going to scaffold out our homepage.
Alright, we're going to start building the
homepage for our nice little application.
And we're going to have all this stuff here,
on our homepage, the homepage is going to
be what's called a container component. And
then we're going to create different components.
For example, for the hero image for the search
bar for the thumbnails for the grid, and for
the Load More button. Let's go back to our
code editor. And inside a components folder,
we create a new file that we call home. dot
j s capital H. And this one, I don't have
a folder for this one, because this is kind
of more container component. So we don't have
any styling in this one, we're going to apply
the styling on the individual components instead.
Alright, so the first thing we always do when
we create a component in react is to import
react, import react from react, then I'm going
to create a little comment here and call it
config because we're going to import some
stuff from the file, let's call config.js.
And inside of this file, I've set everything
up for you that's needed for the Movie Database
API, and I export them here in an object.
So we're going to import a few things from
this file in the home component. So go back
to the home dot j s, and we import curly brackets,
we're going to import the poster underscore
size, all capital letters, we're going to
import the backdrop, underscore size. And
the image underscore base underscore URL.
Remove this sidebar here. We're going to import
them from dotnet, forward slash config, like
this, and be very careful here with the spelling
all capital letters and underscore. Alright,
then later, we're going to import a lot of
components here. So for now, I just mark it
like this, we're also going to import to hook.
So I marked that one also. And we're also
going to import an image. So if we go back
and look here in the images folder, I have
this image that's called no underscore image.
And this one is a fallback image if we don't
get an image back from the Movie Database
API. So we have this funny little smiley balloon
here that will fall back to if we don't have
an image to go back to the home.js. And we
import are going to call it no image. And
when you do an import like this, you can call
it whatever you want. So doesn't need to be
named like this. I'm going to import from
doc dot forward slash images. And I grabbed
the no underscore image dot jpg, very important
to have the file extension when importing
images like this. Alright, then I'm going
to create the component itself. And as I told
you, I like to create it with an arrow function,
you can have a regular function, if you want
to do that. I have a const home, I have a
capital H. All react components always have
a capital first letter. Very important always
name your components with a capital first
letter. So home capital H. And then we don't
have any props for this one. So I just leave
it empty here the parenthesis and then I have
an arrow function. And I have curly brackets
because this one is going to have some logic
inside of it, we have to have a return statement
and make an explicit return. So return for
now we can just return a div that says homepage
like this. Alright, then we can also actually
scaffold out our states that we're going to
have in this component. And for that one,
we're going to need a hook that's called use
state. So make sure to import that one up
here. You type in a coma and then you have
curly brackets. And we import use state from
the React library. And the use state hook
is the hook that you use in functional components
in react to create a state. So when we call
the use state hook, we'll get an array back.
The first value is going to be the state value
itself and the second value is going to be
the setter for the state. And the standard
for grabbing and using these values is to
use the Six syntax for destructuring. So I
create a const, or the structure of the state
and the setter for the state set state. And
you can call it whatever you want here, but
I want to call this state, you could call
it cool like this, but I don't actually think
it's that cool. So I'm gonna stick with state
like this. And then we have an equal sign,
and we call the use state hook. For now, we'll
leave it empty, but it could provide it with
an initial state in here. But we don't do
that for now. So as you can see, here, I'm
calling use state and this one will give us
an array back. So from that array, I destructor
out the state and the setter for the state.
Otherwise, we could do it like this. But you
shouldn't do that. We have a const stayed,
you stayed like this, and this state will
be an array with the first value date value
here. And then we have the setter, or the
state as the second value. And then as we
didn't destructor, this one out here, we just
put it in this constant called state. If we
want to grab the state, we have to type it
in like this, to use the index zero because
that's the first value in the array. And if
we want to set the state, we have to grab
the setter like this with the second value
in the array, that is the index one. So that's
no good. Actually, it's much better to do
it like this, instead, we destructed out and
we can also name them individually by doing
it like this. Alright, so this is the way
to go, this is the way you should do it. So
that's the state we'll that will hold all
the movies, then we're going to have the state
for the loading, the loading and set loading
equals use state and this one, I'm going to
give an initial state, I'm going to set it
to false. And this is also great with the
use state hook, you can have as many of these
ones as you want, you can split the state
up into multiple ones. And you couldn't do
that in the class components in react, because
before we had the use state hook, we needed
to create a class to have state in react.
And then we just had one state and you have
to have a state object with all the stuff
in it. But now we can separate them out into
different states. And that's super great.
So I'm going to create the third one that
are called error and set error. And this one
is going to be used if we receive an error
from the API. So we can have this as a flag,
and we set this one to false also. Right.
So that's the states, we have to do one more
thing, because we have created this component.
And we also have to export it. So export default,
home like this. See if we can get some more
formatting. Now it looks great. Anyways, alright,
save the file. But if we go back to our application,
you can see that we don't see anything yet
it just start here. That's because we have
created a component, but we're not actually
using it. So in the app.js file, up here,
where we import the header, we're going to
import home from dot forward slash components,
and home like that. And then we can use that
component down here. So we remove start here
and use a component and we self close it,
because we're not sending in any props. So
we just type out the name in a tag like this,
save the file, go back to the application.
And you can see that it says homepage. And
that's great. We know that it's working. And
you may wonder why we have all these warnings
here. But they are just warnings because we're
not using these values. Now, they will disappear
later when we use them in the component. So
nothing to worry about there. In the next
video, I'm just going to do a short talk on
the standard hooks, that's indirect library,
and then we move on and actually fetch some
data from the Movie Database API. Okay, before
we move on, I just want to make a brief talk
about the built in hooks that's in the React
library, we can also create our custom hooks.
And we're going to do that in this course
also, but we have some hooks that's built
in that you probably going to use most of
the time when you create react applications.
So I'm on the React js.org. And I'm in this
chapter here that's called hooks. This is
great if you want to know more about hooks,
because honestly hooks can be a little bit
hard to grasp in the beginning. So I highly
recommend that you actually read this chapter
here if you're completely new to hooks. And
if you're new to react, this is a great way
to start doing some reading before you do
any course or create anything with react.
It's always a good idea to have some basic
theoretical knowledge before you start with
something. But of course, it depends on how
you like to learn stuff, so I shouldn't tell
you how to do it. Alright, so they have an
introduction to hooks, they have different
chapters here, we actually going to look at
this one number seven hooks API reference,
and I'm going to talk about the hooks that's
built in the library, sort of separated in
basic hooks and additional hooks. And the
basic hooks are probably the ones that you're
going to use not maybe 99% but perhaps 95%
of the time, and then you're going to create
some own custom hooks and use some special
hooks sometimes. So we already talked a little
about the use state hook. That's the one that
you use for creating state in a functional
component in react. So that one we imported
in the last video, and we initialized it and
set it up in the home component, we're also
going to use the hook that's called use effect.
And use effect is a hook that you can use
for side effects. So in our case, we're going
to grab data from an API, and that's a side
effect. So we're going to use the use effect
hook for grabbing that data. And we're going
to use the state to keep that data in our
application, then you have a hook that's called
use context, we're not going to use that hook
in the main part of this course. But I am
going to use the use context hook in the extra
chapter at the end, where I create a Movie
Database, login in the application and make
it possible for you to cast a vote on the
movies, then I'm going to set up a global
state that holds the login information of
the user by using the use context. So that's
the basic hooks. And then you have some additional
hooks use reducer, that's something that's
very similar to if you, for example, have
used Redux. The use reducer is very similar
to that one. And it can be used instead of
the use state hook if you want more. I don't
know if it's a more complex state. But yeah,
yeah, maybe a more complex state than the
use state, we want to use it in this course.
And the use callback and use memo hooks are
hooks that you can use to memorize stuff.
If you don't want to recreate for example,
a function on each render, they are very handy
if you for example, run into something that's
called an infinity loop with the use effect.
That's very common actually, in react that
you can do that. Because if you set the state
in a use effect that will trigger a rerender.
And if you have a dependency in the use effect,
for example, a function that recreates on
each render, that will trigger that effect
again, and that will set the state again,
and it will trigger the effect again. And
yeah, you get the point here, it will create
an infinity loop, then you can use the use
callback to wrap that function inside the
use callback hook. And that won't recreate
the function on each render. Because by default,
if you create just a regular function, React
will recreate that function on each render.
And use effect. If you specify that one in
one in something that's called a dependency
array that we're going to talk about, then
that use effect will trigger again, because
it will think it's a new function because
that function has been recreated on the next
render. So use callback and use memo or hooks
you can use to memorize stuff in react, but
I think there are a little bit more advanced,
so I won't use them in this course, they use
ref hooked, we actually going to use that
one because I'm going to show you a little
trick in this application. And a neat little
use case to use this one use ref is basically
a hook you can use to create a mutable value
that won't trigger a rerender, you can see
just maybe like you're kind of a regular variable
that won't trigger a rerender. So we can use
this one to create a mutable value. Because
if we have it in a state, it will always trigger
a rerender when we change that value. But
if we change the value with the use ref hook,
it won't trigger a rerender. Use imperative
handle, I've never used this one. So I'd actually
don't know what is for use layout effect,
it's very similar to use effect. They only
differ in when they trigger. So there's no
use case for the use layout effect in this
course. So I won't go into detail. And use
debug value. I haven't used this one either.
These are the built in hooks in react. But
I think the strength about hook is that you
actually can create custom hooks. And we're
going to do that in this course also, that
was a brief introduction to hooks in react.
So in the next video, we're going to fetch
some data from the Movie Database API, we're
going to use the use effect hook and the use
state hook for that. Alright, let the fun
begin, because now we're actually going to
fetch some data from the Movie Database API.
And that's super exciting, because it's always
great when you see the magic happens when
you have that nice little JSON object with
all the data that we fetch from an external
source. I like that I love it. Alright, so
we're going to be in the home.js file for
this one. Now, the later we're going to kind
of break this one out and place it in its
own custom hooked. But for now, we're going
to be in the home component and created inside
of here. So we're already importing US state.
But we're also going to import use effect,
because we're going to use this one for fetching
the data. Then I have this file here, that's
called api.js. And inside of this file, I
created all the functions for fetching data
from the API. And I will also say that this
will probably one of the most advanced videos
in this course and also one of the longest
so you can care a little extra about this
video because it's kind of advanced stuff
in this one. Alright, in this file. api.js,
I have this omit here where I export a couple
of functions. The three first ones are the
ones that we actually need to care about the
other ones is for the bonus material for this
course. So you don't have to care about that
now. So this one is the one that we're going
to use now fetch movies, and this will fetch
a lot of movies, multiple movies, then I have
this fetch movie without the s and this one
will fetch an individual movie. And then I
have fetch credits. And that's the credits
for the movie itself. So these ones are going
to be used for the individual movie page.
And if we take a quick look at this fetch
movies, here, you can see that this one has
two parameters of search term and page. So
we're going to give it the search term and
the page that we want to fetch. And I have
a ternary operator here. And that's ies six
syntax for kind of a shortcut for if an else
so I do a check here, I check if I have a
search term, and then I have a question mark.
And if this one is true, if I have a search
term, it will run this one to the right to
the question mark. And if this one is false,
I have a colon here, it will run this one
to the right of the colon. It's a shorthand
for if and else, then I have to do this because
we have different resources from them point
depending on if we're doing a search, or if
we're grabbing the most popular movies. So
that's why I have this ternary operator here.
If we in the search, we're going to use this
resource from the endpoint here and also attach
the search term. And then we also grab the
correct page. So we add this as a parameter
to the URL. And then I return on the wait.
And I actually waited two times. And that's
because I first await the fetch from endpoint.
And then I await when I actually converted
with JSON, because this one is also async.
So that's why I have to await. And as I have
an await, I have marked this one with an async.
So I'm using the async await syntax for this
one, you could also use the good old them.
But I think that's not as readable. I actually
like this a lot more. So that's why I'm using
the async await syntax for this one. Alright,
and I think that's it for this file. We don't
have to care about this, because we're going
to import this function. So go back to home.js.
And just below here, I'm also going to remove
the sidebar on market with API. And then I
import API from dot dot forward slash API.
And this will give us this object where we
can access those functions are talked about.
Alright, so that's the API, then down in the
actual component here, just above the return
statement, we can create a new function that
we're going to call fetch movies. And as we
fetching from the API, and we're going to
use a wait, we have to mark this with async.
And then it's going to have two parameters
is going to have the page and the search term.
And we can set the default value on the search
term to an empty string like this. And I have
an arrow, and I call the brackets. So we create
this function here is an async function, because
we're going to fetch from the API and await
the data. This one is going to get the page
we can send in what page we want to grab.
And then we can also send in the search term,
we haven't actually created this one yet,
because this one is going to be another state
when we create the search bar. So we're going
to add in more states here later, and also
have a state for the search term. And if we
don't send in a search term, we're going to
fall back to an empty string. So we set this
one as default. So that's the fetch movies
function. We're going to read this in a try
and catch block, try and catch. And we can
get the error in this case, I'm not actually
going to set the error, I'm just going to
have a flag that setting if it's true or false.
But of course, you can have a state where
you can store the message from error Also,
if you want to do that. So in the catch, we're
just going to have set error, and we set it
to true. And here to see how I use this setter
for the state. So we destructor it out here.
And to set a new state for that one, we call
this one and we give it the value. So I call
set error, and I give it the value true and
this will change that state to true inside
of try block will first going to set the error
to false. Because now we grab a new data.
So we have to make sure that this one isn't
set to true because we don't have an error
before we have fetched anything. And we're
going to set the loading to true because now
we're fetching so we set this flag to true.
And this is how we can keep track on when
we actually fetching and we can show the loading
spinner and stuff like that. All right. Then
I create a course that I call movies. And
this course is going to hold all the movies.
So I'm going to wait. And from the API that
we imported up here. We have that function
that I showed you. That's called fetch movies
with an s really important, and then we're
going to give it the search term and the page
So this will hopefully grab the movies for
us. And we can try yourself with console log
movies. But if we go back to our application,
you can see that we don't actually get anything
here because we haven't triggered this function.
And we have to do that in a use effect. So
we have the function now, but we haven't triggered
it, do some more formatting, and go below
the function here. And we call the use effect.
And the use effect is called with an inline
function like this. And then we can do what
we want inside of this use effect. So what
we want now is to trigger this only on Mount
only when we mount this home component on
the initial run of this one. So we can do
this by specifying a comma here, and an empty
array. This is what's called a dependency
array. For the use effect, we can specify
different dependencies on when we want this
use effect to trigger. In our case, we just
wanted for now, the trigger when we start
up the application, and when the home component
mounts, so I specify this as an empty array
for now. And when we specify it as an empty
array, it will just run once. So that's really
neat. In this case, we can just call fetch
movies, we're going to send in one, because
we want to fetch the first page, we can also
mark this one actually with initial render.
So we are specified an empty dependency array,
meaning that it will only run once on the
initial render. And inside the use effect,
we call our fetch movies function. And hopefully,
we will get the console log of all the movies
if we save this one and go back to our browser.
And yes, you can see here we have the movie
object here. So in this object, we have the
page one. And this is all from the Movie Database
API. So it's nothing that we have set up here,
we have a total pages of 500, total results
of 10,000. And we have the actual movies in
a property that's called result. And this
is an array, and we get 20 movies at a time
from the API. So that's sweet, we know that
we grabbing data, and we know that it does
triggers once. And that's super great. So
now when we have the data here, we can actually
set our state because we have our state up
here and we want to put our movies in the
state. So I'm going to call set state. And
for this one, I'm going to provide it with
an inline function is a callback function,
that's going to be called with the previous
state by the state setter, if you provide
a state setter with a function, it's going
to be called with the previous state. And
that's great, because we need a previous state
when we set the state. And I'm going to show
you why in a second. So we have a parameter
that are called prayer, you can call it whatever
you want. In the state, we want to set an
object, so we want to return an object, so
I have a parenthesis and curly brackets. If
we didn't have the parenthesis, it would think
that these curly brackets marks the scope
of the function itself. And that's no good.
We want to return an object and an object
also is marked with the curly brackets. So
we have this parenthesis before and this parenthesis
after, this will make sure that we return
an object. And this parenthesis here is for
the setter, of course, so we have two parentheses
here at the end. So I have this little neat
little plugin. Also in Visual Studio code
where you can see I get these different colors
of the parentheses. So it's really easy to
see the parenthesis, I think it's called rainbow
brackets that plugin. So we're going to set
the state we have the movies inside of this
cost. So I'm going to use the e6 syntax that's
called spread, I use three dots and spread
the movies. And this is because I'm going
to take this object here and spread it out
here. That means that we creating a new object,
it's going to take all the properties from
this movies and spread them out inside of
this object here. When you set the state in
react, you should always provide it with a
new value, you should never mutate the state
in react because if you mutate the state directly,
it won't trigger a rerender. And there can
be a lot of trouble. You should always use
a satellite this to modify the state. And
you should always provide it with a new value
and not mutate the state. Really, really important.
Never mutate the state in react. Okay, so
we have the movies. And then if you remember,
we have this property here that's called results.
So this is holding all the movies. But in
our case, we need to decide on how this new
state should look because if we load more
movies, we want to append the new movies to
the old state to the old movies and not wipe
them out. So we have to do some check here
for that on the results. So we have the results
property, colon, and then I'm going to put
it on a new row. I'm going to check if the
page is greater than one. Then I have a question
mark. This is a ternary operator here again,
are going to return a new array are spread
out from the previous state prep. That's the
one here as I told you, this one is getting
called with the previous state So from the
previous state, I spread out the old result,
three dot prevot dot results with an S at
the end. All right, so that's the old movies
that we already have in the state, then I
have a coma. And I'm going to attach the new
movies from the new movies, dot dot dot movies,
dot results. And this one is going to append
the new movies to this array. So we get an
array with the old movies and the new movies.
And that's great. Then we have a colon because
if we're not loading more, we can wipe out
the old movies and just give it the new movies
that we got in this concept called movies.
So dot dot, dot, movies, dot results, like
this is some auto formatting. And this will
hopefully work. We don't know if it works,
because we haven't created a load more button
yet. So we'll see that later in the course.
And there's one more thing we have to do,
because we setting the loading to true here.
And we have to set it to false when we have
grabbed all the movies. So just below the
try and catch block here at the end of this
function, we're going to set loading to false
like this, save the file, go back to see that
it works. reload it, and yes, it works. And
that's super great. But we call slogging it
out here, we don't know if it works with the
state. So we remove this console log, and
go down here somewhere just above the return
statement, and we can console log out the
state instead, save the file. And we hope
for the best. Go back to the browser. And
yes, you can see we have the state here. And
you may wonder why is it showing this many
times. And that's because if we look in the
home component, we have three different states
here. So it will rerender each time we change
one of these states. And some may say and
go crazy, oh, we have a lot who renders that
crazy, it will make this application so slow.
But yeah, you shouldn't worry about that,
actually, because react will diff those things
and only update things in the DOM that has
changed. So it doesn't matter if it rerender
this many times. And to be honest, React is
fast. So even if you had a lot of rear Enders,
you won't have any performance issue in an
application of this scale, don't worry, it's
completely okay that it renders all these
times because it won't rerender the complete
page, it will only run the stuff that has
changed. All right, that's how you fetch data
from the Movie Database API with a use effect
hook and then you put it in the state with
the use state hook. In the next video, we're
going to take all this logic here and create
our own custom hook and place that data inside
of there. And then we can get rid of this
one in the home component. So it will look
a lot cleaner. Okay, we're grabbing data from
the Movie Database API with the use effect
hook and we place it in the state with the
use state hook, we're going to move all this
logic inside of a custom hook instead, because
that will make this component A lot cleaner.
And it's always great to separate out this
logic, if we want to reuse it somewhere else
in the application. In our case, we don't
need to do that. So we do it just because
we want to clean up this component and to
separate out this logic. So that's why you
create custom hooks. Either you do it because
you want to reuse some logic somewhere in
your application, or you want to clean it
out and have that separated out. So inside
of the src folder, not in the components folder,
this time inside of the src folder, create
a new folder, that's called hooks. And inside
of that folder, create a new file that's called
use home fetch camel casing, dot j s, capital
H, capital F. And why do I name it like this?
Well, React wants you to name all your custom
hooks with use and then your name. That way
react knows that this is a custom hook, you
could skip to use use. But you shouldn't do
that you should always name them with use
before the name, always do it like that. Otherwise,
it can give you trouble in the future. So
inside of this file, I'm going to create a
new function. I'm going to export it also
because we're going to import this one in
our home component and use this custom hooked,
export const use home sets. And I create a
regular arrow function like this. Alright,
so that's our function, then we go back to
our home component inside of the components
folder. And we're going to grab all this logic
here, all the states, the first move is function
and the use effect. We can keep the console
log for now is going to give us an error but
that's okay, we're going to fix that soon.
Go back to the use home fetch custom hooked
paste the logic in here and it complains now
because we haven't imported this ones here.
So we could actually just copy them from the
home component but just as before, I want
us to type in stuff a lot here because we
learning stuff. So we're going to import from
the rack. library, we're going to need the
use state. So import curly brackets, you state
coma use effect. And we're also going to use
the hook that's called use ref laters, we
can import that one also. And we import it
from react. And you can see the red, don't
import react in this one, because we not need
the actual react library, we just need this
stuff from that library. So that's why we
don't have any JSX or anything here. So that's
why we don't need to import react itself,
we also need to import the API. And that one,
we can actually just copy this one from the
home. So go back to the home, cut this one
out here, the import API like this, go back
to the US home fetch hooked and paste it in
here. And this one should be it. All right,
is more of mining. And we only have this function
or we're not actually returning something,
we have to return something in our custom
hook also. So go down to the bottom of the
function. And here we're going to return our
state's for now, we're going to return more
stuff in this one later, when we create more
stuff. But now we return on object. And we
have the state, we have the loading and error
like this. And this is also a sixth syntax,
as we return this object, this one is automatically
going to get the property state because it
has the same name. And all of these ones has
the same name. So we don't have to specify
them explicitly, it will figure this out itself.
All right, there's one more thing I want to
do inside of this one before we finished for
this video. And that is I want to create an
initial state. So up here, I create a const
initial state, it's always a great idea to
have an initial state if you want to reset
stuff. And we want to do that later. So I'm
going to structure the state just as the one
that we got back from the Movie Database API.
So we have the page, it's going to be zero
initially, then we have the results. That's
the property that holds all the movies are
going to provide it with an empty array initially,
where the total underscore pages is going
to be zero. And the total underscore results,
it's going to be zero also. So this is the
initial state. And now we can give this initial
state to the use state here where we create
a state. So provided with the initial state,
and this will make sure that it gets the state.
All right. So that's our custom hook. For
now, we go back to the home component. And
now we have to use this custom hook. I already
created this comment here where we're going
to import it. So we import curly brackets,
use movie fetch, like this, from dot dot forward
slash hooks, and use home fetch. Then inside
our sad little empty home component, we're
going to use this one. And yet again, I'm
going to use ESX destructure syntax to get
those properties from the object that we exported
here. We export an object with all these values
here. So I'm going to destructure them out
here. curly brackets stayed loading an error,
equal sign and our call my custom hook use
movie fit. So this will hopefully work. We
console log in out to state so save this file,
make sure that you also save the hook itself.
And go back to the browser. reload it. Yeah,
I have some arrow here. Use movie fetch is
not exported, didn't I export it? export const?
Yeah, it should be used home fetch, of course,
not use movie fetch. A change this one to
use home fetch. us home fetch homefacts like
this, save the file, go back to the browser.
And you can see that we have our state here.
And that's great. You can see there's a lot
of renders. And a lot of people will say,
oh, crazy. There's too many renders, this
is a performance issue. But it's actually
not. So this is totally fine. But you can
see that it we have our initial state here
first, and it's zero, everything is zeroed
out. And then we get the data here. And we
have all the movies inside here. So that's
sweet. And I promise you it won't be any performance
issue in this application because of these
renders. So this is how you create a custom
hook in react. Always name your custom hooks
with use before you have your name. That's
really important, you should always name them
like this. In the next video, we're going
to start creating the components for the homepage
and we're going to start with the hero image.
In this video, we're going to create this
hero image here in the application. So we're
going to grab a background image and all the
text here from the Movie Database API. Actually,
we have already grabbed them. So we're going
to use that data inside of the hero image
component. So let's go back to our code editor.
And inside the components folder, create a
new folder that we call hero image, capital
H capital I, and inside the hero image folder
and create a new file that we call index dot
j, s, and also file that we call hero image
dot styles. dot j s, just as before, are just
going to scaffold out the style so we can
use them in the component, but I'm going to
create the actual styles in the next video
instead. So if you already have this file
here and choose to not create the styling
for this course, you already have this file
here and don't need to do this. So in the
hero image.styles.js import style from style
components like this, then I'm going to export
a cost that are called rapper is going to
equal from style dot div, I'm going to create
a div I have backticks like this, then I'm
going to export const content equals styled.do,
exactly the same and double backticks. And
I'm going to have one that's called export
const text equals styled dot div double backticks.
And that's it. That's three Olam, save this
file and go inside the index.js file, we import
react from react, then we're going to import
the styles. So I marked it with styles, import,
wrapper, calm content, and text from dot forward
slash hero image styles. Right? Then I create
the component itself const hero image capital
letters h n i equals and this one is actually
going to receive some props. And a probe is
something that you can send into component.
So that component can change dynamically,
depending on the props, a prop should never
be changed inside a component that receives
the props. So they can only change if something
rerun this and they get a new prop. So that's
how that works. And the props is sent into
component on a prop object like this. So we
have the Prop, I have an arrow function. And
for this one, I'm just going to return JSX.
So I can make an implicit return. So I have
parenthesis so I can skip the return statement.
And then I have my wrapper. And this is a
style component, we scaffold it out just recently,
this one can also receive a prop. So when
you send in a prop to a component, you do
it by naming the prop and then you give it
the value. In this case, it's going to be
from the prop that this component get prop.
There's going to be a prop that called image.
So we send out along to this style component,
that's named wrapper. And in the next video,
I'm going to show you how we can set the background
image in this component by sending in the
image URL to the style component that's named
wrapper. So that's what I'm doing here. So
I'm sending this URL along to the style component
on a prop that's called image inside this
wrapper, we're going to have the content.
And inside the content, we're going to have
the text like this. And inside the text, we're
gonna have a regular h1 tag. And in JSX, when
you want to use a JavaScript expression, you
create curly brackets, and then you type in
your expression. In our case, we want to show
the title. And this hero image is going to
receive the title from the prop that's called
title like this, and you end it with a curly
bracket. You can have any JavaScript expression
inside of here that you want. So you can do
some calculations and map through stuff and
things like that, that we're going to do later
also are going to show you that now we have
a p tag. Yet again, I have curly brackets,
I have the text and curly brackets. And that
one is from the prop dot txt. There's more
formatting. And then I export default hero
image. This looks fine, actually. But I want
to show you a little trick here now that you
should use when you create your components,
because now we have to type out prop dot image
prop dot title prop dot text. So instead you
can use e6 syntax up here and destructure
out these props from the prop object. So we
have parenthesis, number of curly brackets,
so we have destruction of this object. And
then we have the image, title and the text
And then we can remove prop here on all of
these. So I think you should get used to always
doing it like this because it will look a
lot more cleaner with the structure mount
up here. So we don't have to type in prop
every time. Alright, save the component. And
just as usual, we can't see anything. Now
if we go back to our application, because
we haven't used the component yet, save it,
go back to home. And up here, where I marked
it with components, we import hero image from
dot forward slash, hero image. And now we
can use this component. So below here, instead
of homepage and this div, we can just return
the hero image like this. But we want to send
along some props to this one also, because
this one needs the title and stuff like that.
And we also need to check that we actually
have any movies in the state. So we can't
actually do it like this, because it will
throw an error if we don't have any movies
in that array. So what we can do here, instead
it we return something here inside of the
parenthesis, because we're going to need multiple
rows to move this one inside of here, instead.
And as I told you before, we can only return
one parent element in JSX. So we have to wrap
this one because we'll have more components
here later. So we can create something that's
called a fragment in react, we could of course,
create a div like this and move this one inside.
But sometimes we don't actually want to create
a div, we just want to return this without
creating a div. And you can do that by creating
a fragment. And this is the shorthand for
fragments, you just create this angle brackets
and an end angle bracket. And this will work.
So inside of here, we also want to check if
we actually have some results in the state.
So just as before, as I did in the hero image
itself, if you can see are in the JSX, where
I have a JavaScript expression, I can do the
same in the home. To go back to the home,
I have a curly bracket, and now I can use
any JavaScript expression that I want. So
I want to check if state results. And the
hero image is going to be the first movie,
it's going to be the most popular movie. So
I grabbed the first element in the array,
I check if that one exists. And then I do
something that's called a short circuit. So
I have double ampersands. And I'm going to
move this column bracket to the end of here,
because I want this one to be nested inside
of this one. So this means that if this one
is true, it will run this code here. If it's
false, it will just fall back. And sometimes
some argue that you shouldn't do it like this,
because it will return the actual value false
here, but JSX won't show it. But if you want,
you could instead do a ternary operator like
this. So if this one is true, we return the
hero image. And then we have colon otherwise
we return null, we can put it on its own roll.
And this will also work. And we want to give
this theory some props. So we have a prop
of image. And that one is going to equal.
And this one I have to construct because the
image URL is constructed by the image base
URL that we that we get here, and also the
backdrop size. So I have backticks in dollar
sign curly brackets, I'm going to grab the
image base URL like this. And this one is
going to be long, so I'm going to remove the
sidebar. So this is a template literal. And
you can interpolate expressions like this
in a string literal. Alright, then I'm going
to add the backdrop size, like this. And then
I'm going to add, you can see I have dollar
sign and curly brackets for all of them here,
dollar sign and curly brackets again, from
the State DOT results, I grab the first element
again. And then we have something that's called
backdrop, underscore path. Be very careful
about the spelling here. So you get that correctly.
It's really, really easy to make a typo here.
And then it won't work. This will get us the
image URL. And these ones are all set up in
this file here. Let's call config. They are
set up as per instructions from the Movie
Database API. You can see the image base URL
is this URL here. So that's the one and then
I set the backdrop size. You can change this
size if you want and try it here. You can
make them smaller, and you can set them to
the original size. I set them to width 1280
in this case. So that's what I'm grabbing
here. And I'm generating the string here by
merging them together in this template literal
here. Right now we have the title. And we
get that one from state auth results. The
first element and we have a property that's
called original underscore title like this.
And then we have the text yet again from state
results. From the first element, you could
also break this out in its own variable if
you don't want to type this in every time.
So there's probably been a lot of things you
can optimize in this application. But as this
is a beginner slash intermediate course, I
don't want to do a lot of stuff like this,
because it will only take time. And it will
be confusing with all the other stuff going
on. So we have a property here, that's called
overview. And these are, of course, all from
the Movie Database API is nothing that I have
created. These are named like this from the
Movie Database API. All right, do some auto
formatting. So you can see here I send in
three props, image, title, and text. And these
are the ones that I destructed out in this
component itself. So when you want to give
a prop two a component, you do it like this,
you named the Prop, and then you give it the
value. And then you can grab those props inside
of this component. So save the file, go back
to the browser, and you can see that we can't
see anything yet. But if I mark it here, you
can see that we have the text. But we don't
actually have set any styling for this one
yet. So that's what we're going to do in the
next video. And then we'll hopefully see this
nice little hero image in our application.
It's time to create the styles for the hero
component. So move back inside of the code
editor, and the file that's called hero image
dot style dot j s that we created in the last
video. So we have all these components here,
and just give it some space here. And we're
going to start with a wrapper, and to the
wrapper, we send in a prop. If you remember
this one here, you can see we have this image
prop here. So just as we do with regular component,
we can send him props to style component.
And this is something that is super great
with style components. Because this way, we
can do some stuff with a CSS. And in our case,
we want to set a background image, the usual
way you did that back in the days was that
you had to create some inline CSS when you
had a dynamic image. And you didn't know from
the beginning where it came from, or what
didn't what his name was, you had to set it
with an inline styling on the element itself
in the HTML. But in this case, we can do it
much, much cleaner and sending a prop to this
component. And we set the image here. And
also we're going to create if you look here
at the finished application. I don't know
if you see it now. But there's a slight little
gradient down here also, because I want this
text to be able to be seen on any different
background. That's why I have a dark little
gradient below this text here. So that's what
we're also going to create. So in the repple
component, we have this div that we styling
here with style components. So we have the
background. And we're going to set a linear
gradient first linear gradient, parenthesis,
and is going to go to bottom RGB a and I use
this because I want to set the alpha value
0000. And these values are auto generated
from somewhere on the internet, I usually
do that when I create gradients, it's so easy
to just go there and type in your gradient
and it will give you the code. So that's why
all these values may seem a little bit odd.
This one is 39%. And the RGBA is going to
be 0000 again, and 41%, rgba, 000 and 0.65.
That's the alpha value. And I see you know
that this one shouldn't even need to have
to have these ones here. I think actually,
I can remove this one here. We don't need
that one. And then we said 100%. And just
after the parenthesis, the end parenthesis,
we have a comma. And then we specify the URL.
And now we can grab that prop that was sent
in here. And you do that as this is a template
literal, just as before we use dollar sign
in curly brackets, and we can grab those props,
you create an inline function and this one
will get called with the props. And from the
props, we grab the image and if you want to
destructure amount, you can do that also here,
then you have a parenthesis and then hold
the object. Then we restructure the image.
And we do it like this. Right. Now we have
a coma from the variable, regret dot Ray.
And hopefully this will work. Do some auto
formatting and save it go back to the browser.
And you can see that we actually had the image
here but we haven't set any other properties.
So that's why it will look like this. So let's
go back here and we're going to set the background
On size 100% and cover, we're going to set
the background position to center the height
is going to be six 600 pixels. position is
going to be relative, because we're going
to absolute position or text. So that's why
we have to set this to relative. And we're
also going to have a slight animation on this
one. So I set an animation that are going
to call animate hero image, and is going to
be for one second. If we look at the finished
here, you can see that it kind of fades up.
So that's the animation that I'm going to
create. And I do that below here. And nested
inside of here. So act keyframes, and the
name is animate hero image. I go from Opacity
is going to be zero to Opacity is going to
be one, save it, go back and see what we've
got. There you have it, there's some little
border up here. I don't know why. Let's see
if it's sort itself out when I create other
styles. But you can see that it it animates
in here quite smoothly. So that's great. Alright,
let's fix the other components. So we have
the content, padding is going to be 20 pixels
on that one, we set a max width, and we grabbed
from our variable max width. And Morgan is
going to be zero in order to save it, let's
check it out, you can see that it's in the
center now. That's great. And that one removed
that nasty little border up there also, that's
sweet. Then we have the text. Let's create
that one also, I set the cell index 200. Just
to place it on top, I set the max with the
700 pixels on this text position is going
to be absolute. from bottom we're going to
set it to 40 pixels and margin right is going
to be 20 pixels. The min height is going to
be 100 pixels. And the color is going to be
from the variables we have the white. All
right, so that's our text. And inside we have
the h1 tag. So for that one, I set the font
size. And for more variables, we have font,
super big camel casing. And then I'm going
to have a media query on this one media screen.
And Max course I have to end this way to see
my colon max with 720 pixels. And I set the
font size to variable dash dash formed big,
so I'm making it slightly smaller. Right,
that's the h1. Then we have the p tag, it's
gonna have a font size. From the variables,
we grab font med. That's the medium size.
And then we have a media query media screen
and you set the max with the 720 pixels. For
that one, the font size is going to be a variable
font small. So this means of course, that
up until 720 pixels, we will use the form
small otherwise it will use the font medium.
And the same goes here, we use the font big
up until 720 pixels otherwise was used the
font super big. All right, then we're going
to have a media query on the text itself.
So media screen and max width 720 pixels.
And we set the max with 200%. And there may
be room for optimization in the CSS because
I haven't put the most focus in the CSS for
this course, as this is a course in react.
But I wanted to show you how to create the
CSS also. So that's why I included it. But
there are room for optimization I'm sure of
that. Go back and see what we got in it. seems
to be working. Let's see what happens. Yeah,
you can see it gets smaller. And that's great.
Now, it's actually starting to get fun because
now we see different stuff happening here,
things are displaying on the screen. And that's
what I like with front end development to
actually see it's put together like this.
Alright, in the next video, we're going to
create the logic for the grid component. So
we have our hero component, and the next component
would be the actual search bar. But I'm going
to save that one for later. So we're going
to create this grid now instead, in this video.
So let's start by creating a logic just as
usual. And in the next video, we create the
styles, go back to the code editor. And inside
the components create a new folder, that's
called grid. And inside the grid, create a
new file that's called index dot j s. And
another file is called grid dot styles dot
j, s and capital G on the grid, of course,
and just as before, we're going to be in the
grid dot styles dot j s first to create the
placeholders for the style components. So
import styled from styled components, then
we export the columns that we call wrapper.
And as you can see here, this is great with
starter components, because I named them the
same, but it doesn't matter, they will be
scoped to that component. So we can have this
exact same name. That's super sweet. So the
styles won't interfere with each other. So
style dot div, double backticks. And then
we export const content, and that equals A
styled dot Dave, also n double backticks,
save it and go inside of the index.js file.
So we import react from react, hopefully you're
starting to learn is now so this will be in
your muscle memory later. Then we have the
styles, we import the wrapper, and the content
from dot forward slash grid styles. Then we
create a component itself const grid equals,
and I'm going to destructure or two props
that we're going to send into this one. So
header and children. I have an arrow function,
and I'm going to do an implicit return. And
you may wonder what children is. And that
is a default prop that we can use in react.
When we nest stuff inside a component, they
will be accessible in the children prop. So
that's great, I'm going to show you how that
works in a second, we're going to have a wrapper.
Then we have an h1 tag. And then I have curly
brackets because I'm going to grab the header
prop and display that here. Then we have the
content. And for that one, I create another
curly bracket, and I grab the children. So
that means that whatever I wrap inside of
this component, when I use it, I can display
it here by displaying the children, then we
need to export default grid like this and
save it. So this is pretty much it for the
grid component. If we go back to the home.js
file, we can import it up here. Import grid
from dot forward slash grid. And then just
below here below the hero image, I'm going
to use the grid here. And this one is going
to get one prop is the header equals popular
movies. So inside the grid, I'm going to map
through all of the movies in the state. So
I have curly brackets and State DOT results.
I map that's also a sixth syntax, we have
a movie. In this inline function, I can make
an implicit return. So I have parenthesis.
And I use a lot of e6 syntax here as you can
see, and hopefully you know a bit about it
before you start this course because it will
be too long of a course if I explain every
little syntax in detail, but I try to explain
some stuff for you. And hopefully, you'll
learn a lot also from it. But the map method
is something you can use instead of a for
loop. So use the map on the array, the results
array, and it will map to each item in the
array. We haven't created a thumbnail yet.
So we're going to create a div. And I think
we have a property that's called title. So
I map through every movie and now I'm just
going to show a div in the grid that shows
us the movie title. Or format it save it go
back to the application. And you can see that
we have all the movies here so displaying
the title, and you can see that it also warns
us now each child in a list should have a
unique key prop That's when we map through
things, we have to market with a key also
otherwise, React will complain. React is using
this internally to diff stuff and to optimize
itself. So we can set a key on this one. And
we're going to give it the movie.id. So this
is a unique ID that we get from the Movie
Database API, it's sometimes return two of
the same movie, and this one will actually
give a warning done. So it's some bug in the
API, I think, because it should only return
one of each movie. So if it gives you a warning,
it's probably that because it has probably
returned more than one of the same movie.
So you could actually add something else,
you could add a random number, also to the
movie ID if you have that problem. So let's
go back to the application. And you can see
that it doesn't complain now. So now it's
happy, we have provided a unique key. And
that's super great. And we have the titles,
but it looks like crap. Now because we haven't
styled it and we haven't created the thumbnails
yet. In the next video, we're going to style
the grid itself, and then we're going to create
the thumbnails. So we have our grid, but we
have to style it also. And that's what we're
going to do in this video. Move back to the
code editor and in the file that's called
grid doc stars dot j s in the grid folder,
we have already created this one here. So
we're just going to fill them up with CSS.
And also I can tell you, if you don't have
that plugin installed in Visual Studio code,
I have a plugin that's called VS code dash
style dash components. So that's the one that's
create this nice syntax highlighting inside
of this style components. So that's a little
tip if you haven't installed that one. Alright,
so let's create the stars for the wrapper.
First, we're going to set the max width from
our variable that's called max width. Then
we set the margin to zero auto, that will
center the div, and we give it some padding
zero and 20 pixels that's padding on the sides.
And then we have the h1 tag, I'm going to
set the color from the variable mid gray on
that one. And then also, I'm going to have
a media query. So at media screen, and Max
dash with 768 pixels. And this one is going
to change the font size from the variable
font big. Alright, save it go back to the
browser. And you can see that we have this
nice Morgan's here, but we haven't actually
created a grid yet. So that's what we're going
to do next. Inside the content component,
we're going to display a grid. Then we set
something that's called grid template columns,
grid dash template dash columns, we're going
to set this one to repeat. And this is a little
trick you can use if you want to create a
responsive grid, so we repeat these columns,
we set it to auto fill a coma, and then we
use the min max 200 pixels, that's the minimum
width that those little thumbnails can have.
And then we set it to one fragment, so we
don't specify an exact pixel width on the
max value. And this is CSS Grid syntax. And
the CSS Grid will probably require a complete
course on its own. So I'm not going to go
there. Grid gap, we're going to set that one
to two REM so that will give it some spacing
between the rows and the columns, save it,
go back to the browser, and you can see that
we have our grid. So now it's showing us five
items on each row. If we do like this, you
can see that it is responsive. And that's
super great. That's a neat trick you can use
if you have a grid like this, just with one
row in CSS Grid, you can make it fully responsive.
So that is really, really cool, actually.
And it works because we set this one to repeat
the columns, and we set it to autofill. And
then we set a min and max value. So we're
telling it when it's 200 pixels wide, it can't
go lower. So then it removes one column instead.
And it's going to do that all the way down
to the mobile devices. All right, that's the
styling for the grid. It was pretty fast.
I think. In the next video, we're going to
start creating the thumbnails. We have the
grid now, but we haven't created the thumbnails
for the movies. So that's what we're going
to do next. Move back inside of the code editor
and inside the components folder, create a
new folder that you call thumb, capital T
inside of that folder, you create a new file
that's called index dot j s. And then you
create another file that's called thumb dot
styles, dot j s, I hope you're beginning to
see the pattern here on how I structure the
components. So first, we're going to start
in the thumb dot style dot j s, just as before.
So we import styled from styled components.
And for this one, we're only gonna have one
component. So export const. Image capitalized.
And this one is going to be styled dot IMG
because we styling the image here. Right,
save it and go back to the index.js file or
the thumb. So first, we import react from
react. Then we mark it with styles an import
image from dot forward slash thumb styles.
We're going to import some more stuff here
later, because these thumbnails are going
to be clickable, we're going to create that
later when we have set up the routing, and
also started to create our movie page. So
for now, we create our thumb component, cost
thumb equals, I'm going to destructure out
an image prop movie ID and clickable, I make
an implicit return on this one, because I'm
only going to return JSX. For this one, I'm
going to have a wrapping div, like this. And
then we're going to use this prop to tell
if it's clickable or not. And then we're going
to have a ternary operator here. But for now,
we're just going to return an image. That's
the image that we created here. The source
is going to be wrong the image prop. Eric
is that an old of movie thumb on that one.
With self, close it. And then down below here,
we export default, some save the file, then
we're going to go back to the home component
and also import this one. So up here, import
some from dot forward slash thumb. Alright,
and below here, where we map through all of
the movies, we're going to use a thumb instead
of this div, remove this one here, and we
use the sum, then we're gonna have a key for
this one also, because we always need to have
a key when we are mapping through components
like this and display them. So the key is
going to be just as before the movie.id we're
going to set it to clickable, that's going
to be true, it's always default to true. So
you don't have to do this, if you want to
set it to true. For now that one isn't working,
because we didn't utilize it in the component
itself. But we're going to fix that later.
Then we have the image prop and we're going
to give it the URL to the image. And for this
one, we're also going to use that fallback
image if we don't have any image for the movie.
So we're gonna have a taller operator here,
movie dot poster underscore path. So we're
checking if we have imposed a path if we don't
have that we're going to display the fallback
image. But if we have this path, we know that
we can grab that image. So we have a question
mark. I'm typing it on another row here, but
it's the regular ternary operator. Then we
have the image base URL. And I'm actually
going to show you the other way now not do
it like this here. But you can do it the old
way with plus, instead, where the poster size,
and then we have the movie dot poster path,
movie dot poster underscore path. Be very
careful with the spelling, it's very easy
to make a little typo here. And that will
break everything. Alright, so that is when
we have a poster path, then we have the colon.
And we're going to display the no image if
we don't have a poster path. So that's the
image, then we're going to send in the movie
ID. And that is because when we click on a
thumbnail, we need to have the movie ID for
that thumbnail. So we know what movie to grab
and display on the individual movie page.
So movie.id and then we're going to close
the thumb component. So be very careful here.
It's a little bit nested. And it's very easy
to type something wrong here. But this should
be right i think i really hope so. I save
it back to the browser. And as you can see
we have the thumbnails but it doesn't look
right. And that's because I haven't styled
them yet. But at least we display something.
So in the next video, we're going to start
the thumbnails some to make it look something
like this instead. Really pretty modern. I
hope Okay, we soon have a grid with nice little
thumbnails, we just have to style the thumb
component itself. Inside the thumbnail styles
dot j s, we already created this one, we're
going to style it inside of the image style
component. So we're going to set the width
to 100%. The max width is going to be 720
pixels, transition, all 0.3 seconds. And that
is because I want some nice transition on
hover. Objects object dash fit is going to
be cover border dash radius is going to be
20 pixels. And the cover here will center
the image and make it fit nicely into the
thumbnail. So that's a really handy little
rule you can use in CSS for stuff like that.
I also got to have an animation on this one
because I want it to fade up, we can actually
look at that in the finished application.
You know, you can see here that these thumbnails
are also fading up just as the hero image.
That's what I wanted animation for. So I call
it animate thumb. 0.5 seconds. So we're going
to create that animation. So add keyframes
and animate them. Right from a set the opacity
to 02. It's going to be opacity one, that's
the animation. And then I also want to set
the hover effect. So colon hover like this.
And I said to pacity to 0.8, there's an auto
formatting and save it back to the application.
And as you can see, it's looking great. So
that's nice, it's working, it's starting to
look like something, we can compare it to
this one here, and it looks exactly the same
without the search bar. So we have a few things
left to do, we have to create the spinner
also when we loading and the search bar and
the bottom for loading more. In the next video,
we're actually going to create the spinner
component. So we have that ready when we want
to show it when we're fetching more. Okay,
we have our hero image on our grid. So we're
going to create the spinner in this video.
Back inside of the code editor and the components
folder, and inside a components folder, create
a new folder that we call spinner. And then
we create a file, let's call index dot j s
and another file. Let's call spinner dot styles,
dot j s, it's been beginning to be a little
bit repetitive here. But as I said so many
times before now is always great to repeat
stuff when you learn it. So even if it's boring,
it's better to repeat it, because then it
will be in your muscle memory later. So that's
why I repeat a lot of stuff also in this course.
And this one is a little bit special actually
because we have the component itself in the
index.js file, but the component is really
just going to be a styled component. So in
this index.js file, we're just going to import
the start component in this file. So we can
create this actually in this video and then
we import it and then it will be finished.
So in the spinner.styles.js file, we import
styled from styled components. We export a
const that we named spinner, and it equals
A styled dot div double backticks and inside
the backticks we write our CSS, we set the
border to five pixels solid. And we have the
variable of light gray. We set the border
dash top to five pixels solid with a variable
dash dash med gray. We set the border dash
radius to 50% because this one is going to
be a circle so that's why the width is going
to be 50 pixels and the height is also going
to be 50 pixels. We have an animation on this
one also. We call it spin 0.8 seconds is going
to be a linear animation and is going to be
infinite. That was at the Morgan 220 pixels.
All right, then we create an animation at
keyframes. Spin we go from 0% Transform. we
rotated Cyril degree, here, I'm using PreSonus
data. So you can use whatever you want. We
didn't do that in the thumb styles I'm using
from two in that one instead. So I like to
change stuff a little bit when I create courses
like this so that you see that you can create
it in many different ways. So here, I'm using
percent instead. And it should say, transform,
not Transform, transform, and rotate zero
degrees, and it will see my colon. And then
we go to 100%. And the transform is going
to be rotate 360 degrees, some auto formatting,
and save it. Then we go back to the index.js
file in the spinner folder. And for this one,
we just import the spinner that we created
a style component. So from dot forward slash
spinner dot styles. And then we export it,
export default spinner. So that's it for this
component, we can actually see if it works
also. So go back to the home page home.js,
we import it first here. Imports spinner from
dot forward slash spinner. Alright, and then
here just below the grid, we can place the
spinner and also a soy, we don't actually
need the use state and use effect here more
so we can delete those ones also save the
file, go back to the browser. And as you can
see, just below here, it's spinning like crazy.
And of course, it's only going to be shown
when we fetch data from the API. But for now,
we're showing it all the time, but we're going
to fix that later. So that's how you create
a really simple spinner with some CSS and
style components in react. In the next video,
we're going to start creating the search bar.
So we created a grid with a thumbs and we
have our hero image and we want to create
our search bar. Next, if we look at the search
bar in the finished application, we can see
that we have this nice little icon here and
I created this myself, first I had an icon
from Font Awesome. But then I thought maybe
we shouldn't import the whole Font Awesome
library just to have one outcome. So that's
why I created an SVG image instead. And then
it says search movie, and then we can type
in something to search for in here. So this
is how it works. So let's go back to our code.
And inside a component folder, create a new
folder, that's called search bar, capital
S, capital B. And inside of that folder, you
probably guessed it, we create a file, let's
call it index dot j s, and a file that's called
search bar dot styles. dot j s. And we do
as we always do, we're going to be in the
search bar dot styles dot j s, and we're going
to scaffold out the style components import
style, from style components, then we export
a const, called wrapper. And he's going to
equal a style of theme. And we have double
backticks. And we export, not triple backticks
double backticks and a semi colon, then we
export the course that called content. It's
going to equal style dot div, double backticks
and a semi colon, save it go back to the index.js
in the search bar folder, we import react
coma, we're also going to import a few other
stuff here, we're going to need to use state
we're going to need to use effect. And we're
also going to need to use ref this one. And
we import it from react. So why do I need
these things? Well, the state we're going
to use to create what's called a control component.
And that means that we're going to have our
input field but it's going to be controlled
by react, the input field is going to be based
on the value in the state. We're going to
use the use effect to trigger when this local
state changes. And then we're going to update
the search term so that it will fetch new
movies from the API. And use ref is going
to be used to show you a little trick that
we can use if we don't want to do something
in the use effect on the initial render. So
then we're going to import the image that's
going to be that little icon I showed you.
So import search icon, camel casing from dot
dot forward slash dot forward slash again,
images and we have something that's called
search dash icon dot SVG. Don't miss the file
extension there. Then we have the styles,
the import, curly brackets, wrapper and content
from dot forward slash sport dot styles. All
right, so that's our imports. And then we
create a component const search bar, capital
S capital V equals, and we're going to destructure
out the prop that's going to be set search
term camel cased by a narrow. Now for this
one, we're going to make an explicit return
because we want to have some logic in it.
So we have a return statement, parenthesis.
Now we have our wrapper. And inside a wrapper,
we're going to have our content like this.
So the first thing we need is the icon and
it's going to be an image. So image SRC is
going to be the search icon. We can set an
author on that one, also search dash icon
with self, close it like this, just a regular
img tag, then we're going to have an input
field. And it's going to be a type text. We're
going to have a placeholder. Let's go going
to be searched movie. And then we're going
to have an on change handler and value. But
for now, I'm just going to surf close this.
And to do some auto formatting and export
this component, export default search bar.
And then we're going to import it in the home
component just to see that we got something
here. So go back to the home, and close all
this, go back to the home. And just below
the hero image, we're going to place that
component But first, we need to import it.
So import search bar from dot forward slash
search bar right down below the hero image
just above the grid, we can place a search
bar, save it go back to the browser. And you
can see that we have our input field here.
But we haven't started yet, of course. So
hopefully it's gonna look something like this,
when we're finished, go back to the code and
the search bar in index.js file, we're going
to make this what's called a controlled component,
a controlled component in react is a component
that react control. So the input value is
going to be based on a state that we create.
And when that state changes, it also changes
the value in the input box. And this is great
because then we know that our state is in
sync with the actual value in the input field.
We create a state of here const, we can call
it state and set state equals use state. And
it's going to be an empty string for stores.
On our input field, it's all formatted them
like this, I want to have them like this,
instead, we're gonna have an on change handler
equals, and for this one, I want to create
an inline function, you could also create
a function up here for that one if you want
to do that instead. But I want to show you
how to do things differently. So in this case,
I created an inline function, we have the
event, or you can just type in E, for example,
you can name it whatever you want, then we
set the state with the event dot turn target
dot value, and this will give us the value
in the input field. And we need to have this
inline function as we are actually invoking
this function here with that value, otherwise,
it won't work. So by having this inline function,
we can provide this one with value. So that's
why you have this inline function. Otherwise,
it will run this function instantly. And that's
no good. So if we, for example, had a function
that we didn't want to send in some arguments
to that we just want to trigger on change,
we can have it like this instead. And that
will work but in this case, we want to send
in the argument or the current value. So that's
why we have this inline function. Alright,
so that's the unchanged and then we set the
value to the state. And there we have successfully
created a control component. We can see if
it works, go back to the browser, type something
in and you can see the value here now is controlled
by react. As soon as we set this value to
some state value here, we are making this
a control component. And every time it changes,
it's going to trigger reset state and it gets
the value here and replace the value from
the text input. In the state, and then the
value is displayed in the textbox itself.
So it's kind of a closed circle here on how
things work. It goes around in this way. Now
we have our input field, but we want something
to happen. Also, we want to set the search
term that we're going to create in our hook
that we created before. So we actually going
to create a new state inside of use home fetch.
So up here in the US home fetch hook, we're
going to create a cost, call it search term
capital T, and set search term, then it's
going to equal use state. And we'll set it
as an empty string initially, then we also
need to export this one. So export it down
here. And we only need a setter for this one.
So we can export the set search term like
this, save the file, go back to the home.js.
And up here, where we where we use or use
home fetch hooked, we can destructure out
the set search search term, the set search
term arrived. And this one is going to be
the prop for our search bar. So I'm going
to call this prop set search term also. You
can call it whatever you want. And then I
give it to set search term. So this way, we
pass this along down to our component to the
search bar, so that we can use it in the search
bar. So when this one triggers when we set
the search term is going to trigger here.
So actually changing the state in our hook
here. That's exactly what we want, because
then we can use it in our hook when we fetch
stuff. But in this case, we want to have a
slight delay when the user types something
in before it tries to fetch the data, we can
look here in the finished application, you
can see when I type something in here, that
I have a slight delay, otherwise, it wouldn't
be a good user experience if it just instantly
started to fetch data. So that's why I do
it this way instead, otherwise, we could have
used this state to actually fetch the data.
But in our case, we want a slight delay. And
then we set the search term that we're going
to use for fetching. So that's why I have
dual states for this one. So let's create
a use effect in the search bar use effect.
We have an inline arrow function just as before.
And we have the dependency array. And we're
going to fill it out in a second. I'm going
to show you how to create a timeout in react
now and how we can use it in a use effect.
So first we create a timer. We use the set
timeout that's built in JavaScript, we have
an inline function for that one. And then
we're going to call the set search term. That's
the one that we created. And we're going to
give it the state like this. And I'm going
to set it to half a second, that's 400 milliseconds.
So this one will trigger after 500 milliseconds.
If you want some other value, you can of course
type that in instead. And you can see here
now that it instantly complains, because we
haven't specified this as a dependency. So
we specify and set search term as a dependency.
And it also complains, because it needs the
state, that's also dependency to this use
effect. So this linting rules are actually
really good. It tells us stuff so that it
is so that we actually do this correctly.
And we should always specify the dependencies
and handle it inside of the use effect if
we need to. Alright, but there's one more
important thing we have to do with the timer.
And that is declared a timer on each render,
because otherwise, it will just create a lot
of timers. And that's no good. And there's
a handy little thing with the use effect that
we can use for this. Because if we return
a function in the use effect, so every time
before a new render, it will trigger this
function. So we can clear our timeout inside
of that function. And this will take care
of that we clean up this timer. So we don't
have a lot of timers that just ticks in the
background. And you can imagine you have a
lot of stuff that you want to do maybe to
clean up stuff. So you can always do that
in a return function with the use effect.
This one doesn't trigger until this render
has finished and is going to render again.
So that is sweet. We can say this one. And
we can actually go back to the use on fetch.
And up here. We can console log the search
term, so we can see that something is happening.
So go back to the application again. Yeah,
I have a typo somewhere. Maybe I didn't save
the home. Save go back to the browser. Yeah,
no, it's worse. You can see it's really important
to save your files because it will break otherwise,
be sure to save all the files. So if I type
in test, and you can see here after 500 millisecond
it will trigger. So that's sweet. We know
that that is working and we Use this to fetch
data from the API. But there are one more
thing I want to do. And I promised you to
show you a little trick with the use ref.
And that is because the use effect always
trigger on the initial render, and we don't
want to trigger a fetch. When this component
mounts, we only want it to trigger when the
user has typed something in. So that's why
I'm going to create a cost that's called initial
up here. And I'm going to use ref. And I set
it to true. So when we call the use ref hook,
this one will create a mutable value for us
that you can compare to something similar
as a mutable variable. So we have this initial
const, and the actual value is going to be
in the initial dot current, that property
will hold the value true right now. So I set
is the true and inside the use effect, I'm
going to check if initial dot current, that's
going to be the true value right now, if it
is true, in it, it should say initial, like
this, right? Then I instantly going to set
the initial dot current to false. And you
can see here, I can mutate this variable directly,
I don't have to have a setter for this one,
because this one won't trigger a rerender.
That's the biggest difference from a state
that when you use ref, it won't trigger a
rerender. And then if this one is true, we
know that this is the initial render, and
then I'll just return, we don't do anything
more inside of the use effect. And we set
it to false. So next time, this one triggers,
this one is going to be false. And it's going
to run our logic. So this is how you can create
a neat little code snippet here, to skip the
initial render in the use effect, save the
file, just make sure that it works. Yeah,
and it seems to be working. We've learned
how to create a control component in react,
and the component controls the input field
with the state. So the input field always
has the same value as the state and that's
the control component or state is synced with
the input field. And then we created a timer
that will trigger each half a second and call
this set search term to set the stay there.
And the state is going to be the value from
the input field. And we also pass this one
along from the US home fetch. So that's how
you pass data down to your components. That's
what props are for, you can pass data down
to your component, and we can use it in that
component. And that means that we also have
this value in our use home fetch hook to use
the fetch data later, that can remove this
console log for now, save the file, and this
will be it actually for the search bar. In
the next video, we're going to style the search
bar. And then we're going to create the logic
for fetching the data. were created our search
input field, but it doesn't look good. So
we have to style it also. And that's what
we're going to do now. So in our search bar
dot styles file, we're going to create the
wrapper first. And I'm going to display it
as a flex. I'm going to align items center.
Now not aligned a line I set the height 200
pixels. The background is going to be from
the variables, we have the dark gray. And
I'm going to give it some padding on the sides,
zero and 20 pixels, do some more formatting,
save it go back to the browser. And you can
see that we have the search bar here. And
now we have to style kind of the inner part
of the search bar. And we do that in the content.
Inside the content, I'm going to set the position
to relative because we want to place the icon
with an absolute position. The max width is
going to be from the variables we have our
max width, the width is going to be 100%.
The height is going to be 55 pixels, the background
is going to be from the variables met gray.
And Morgan is going to be zero in order. And
the border dash radius is going to be four
pixels and the color from the variables we
have our white. Save it go back and see what
we've got so far. So we have this inner part
now of the of the search bar to add the style
icon and the search bar input field itself.
So inside the content, we're going to nest
some stuff here we have our icon that's the
IMG I set the position to absolute. And this
is why I use relative appear, otherwise it
won't work. So it needs to be relative to
the actual content div is going to be left
15 pixels. So 14 pixels, and will is going
to be 30 pixels, save it go back. And now
it seems to align correctly and it also has
the correct size. Great. Then we have the
input field itself. So down below the IMG
type in input, we set the font size to 20
pixels in this one position is going to be
absolute left is zero, margin is eight pixels.
And zero padding is going to be 000 and 60
pixels. border is zero, the width is going
to be 95%. The background is going to be transparent.
The height is going to be 40 pixels. And the
color is from the variables and is going to
be white. So go back to the browser. And you
can see that it works now but we have this
nasty little outline, you shouldn't remove
the outlines, actually, but in this case,
I think it's fair to do it because it doesn't
look good. So I'm going to remove them. So
inside the input, I'm going to nest focus.
And I'm going to remove the outline, I set
it to none. And hopefully that will remove
it. Yeah, you can see it removed. Now. One
thing you can do also, if you want is to style
this for mobile devices, maybe make it a little
bit less insight in font size, and stuff like
that, if you want to really fine tune it here,
but it seems to be working now. All right,
and that's it for the search bar. That's the
style for the search bar. In the next video,
we're actually going to hook this up to the
API and fetch some data. We've created our
search functionality on our search bar, but
we can't really search for anything. Yep.
So if we type something in, we just get this
console log here. So we're going to implement
the actual functionality where we fetch the
search data from the API. Let's go back inside
of the code editor. And we're going to be
in the use home fetch hooked. And down here,
where we say initial render, we're going to
change this one to initial and search like
this, because we're going to use this use
effect both for the initial render and the
search. And it's actually pretty easy, because
now we just have this empty dependency array,
meaning that we only trigger this use effect
once on Mount. But we also want to trigger
this one each time to use the search for something.
And up here we have our search term. And in
this one, we're going to store what the user
typed in in the search bar. And that means
that we want to trigger the use effect when
the search term changes down here in the dependency
array, we specify a search term, meaning that
this use effect will trigger each time the
search term changes, and it will also trigger
one time on Mount. So we can actually use
this one for the initial setting also. Because
when we search for something, we always want
to fetch the first page just as we do on the
initial amount. So that's fine, we're fetching
the page one. But we also want to provide
the search term. And that's also fine for
the initial fetching, because the search term
is going to be an empty string. So we know
that we're fetching the most popular movies,
because we're not specifying any search term.
There's one more thing though, that we have
to do, and that is to wipe out the old state
before we make a new search, because we want
to wipe it out and then make a search, show
the loading spinner and then show the new
movies that we grabbed from the search. So
we can set state to the initial state here,
and that will wipe out the state. And that's
really all there is to it. So we say this
file, go back to our application, we try to
search for something. And you can see that
it works. Now this one changes because this
one will always grab the first element in
the array of movies. And that's fine. Actually,
you can have it like this if you want, but
I want to remove this hero image when we're
in a search. We can do that also to go back
to our code. And then inside of the home.js.
Down below here where we show the hero image.
We can also specify that we don't want to
show this one if we have a search term, so
not search term, double ampersand so now we're
checking that we don't have a search term
and also that we actually have a first element
in the array. or movies. But you can see that
you won't see her now. And that's because
we haven't exported this one from our hooked.
So go back to the hooked. And down below here,
we can export this one also search term like
this, save the hook, go back to the home notice,
and up here where we destructure out everything
from the hood, we can also destructure out
the search term like this, save the file,
go back to our application, we tried to search
again. And now you can see that it disappears.
This is exactly what I want. If you want to
keep the hero image, you don't have to do
this. And then it reappears when we don't
have anything in the search bar. All right,
there's one small thing that I also want to
do, and that is in the home.js. And if we
look down below here, where we have the grid,
I'm going to create a ternary operator now
because now it says popular movies, even when
we're in a search. So this one, I'm going
to create a curly bracket and also curly bracket
here at the end, and then I check if I have
a search term, I have a question mark. And
if we have a search term, I create a string
I wanted to say, search result. And if we're
not in a search, it's gonna say popular movies.
So if we have a search term, it's gonna return
what's the right to the question mark, and
that search result. Otherwise, it's going
to return popular movies, save the file, go
back to the application. This time, I'm going
to search for Indiana Jones. And now you can
see that the header on the grid changes. So
that's great. It says search results. And
I remove this and it says popular movies.
So that's our search, we have implemented
all the logic for the search bar. And in the
next video, we're going to start trading the
Load More button. Okay, let's start creating
a button that will go at the bottom here.
And the spinner will not show all the time,
it will only show when we loading stuff back
in the code. And inside the components create
a new folder that's called baronne capital
V. And you guessed it, we create a new file,
let's call index dot j s. And we create another
file that's called Baran dot styles dot j
s. And we're going to be in that file and
import styled bomb style components. And for
this one, we only going to have one style
component. So we export const. And it's going
to be a wrapper equals a style dot button
in this case, and double backticks Auto format
it and save it and then we go back to the
index.js file. And we're going to create a
bottom. So we import react from react. Then
we have our styles, we import the wrapper
that we created wrapper from dot forward slash
buttons and dot styles. Right, now we have
our component const bottom. Then I just structure
two props. One is called text and one is called
callback. And I create an error and I make
an implicit return on this one. I'm going
to add the rapper is going to be type button.
And it's going to have an onClick handler.
And it's going to be the callback that was
sent in as a prop. And then I'm going to display
the text inside of the bottom. So this is
a button that we created as a start component
and call it wrapper. And it's going to trigger
a callback function when the user clicks on
the button, and then we show the text we can
send in what text we want to this button.
If we want to reuse it, then we export default,
bottom, save it, then we go back inside of
the home component. And at the top, we're
going to import bottom from dot forward slash
bottom. And then at the end over JSX, we're
going to show the bottom. And we have to think
about this because we don't want to show the
bottom if we read the last page of movies.
So we have to take that one into consideration.
So just below the spinner here, I'm going
to use the curly bracket and create a JavaScript
expression, we're going to check from the
State DOT page. If that one is less than State
DOT total underscore pages, we know that we're
still not on the last page. And I have a double
ampersand make a short circuit here. I also
want to check so that we're not loading anything.
So if not loading, and then I have another
pair of ampersands. And I have a parenthesis,
put it on a new road just to make it a little
bit more readable. And then I'm going to show
my bottom. So the text is going to be load
more. And for now I'm not giving it the callback.
This is it for now. So this statement will
check if the page we're currently on is less
than the total pages. And then we know that
we still want to show the Load More button.
And it will also check that we're not loading
anything because when we loading something,
we want to show the spinner instead. And we
have the spinner here. So we can actually
create another statement here, the creator
curly bracket, and type in loading and double
ampersand, and we end it with another curly
bracket like this. So this will show the spinner
if the loading is set to true. And if it's
set to false, it will not display the spinner,
but then it will display the button instead.
If we go back to the application, we can see
the button down below here in the corner.
But it doesn't look right, we have decided
also to look like this here. And that's what
we're going to do in the next video. We have
our ugly little button here down at the corner,
so it's time to style it, go back to the code,
and inside of button dot styles dot j s file
and we have the wrapper here, we're going
to give it some nice little style here, we
start by displaying it as blocked display
block, we set the background. For more variables,
we have the dark gray, we set the width to
25%. The min width is going to be 200 pixels,
the height is going to be 60 pixels. The border
dash radius is going to be 30 pixels. And
the color is from the variables dash dash
white, the border is going to reset to zero,
the font size is going to be from the variables
font big Morgan is going to be 20 pixels and
auto transition is going to be all 0.3 seconds.
I'm lazy here I can set it just the property
data wants to have a transition, but I said
it all outline is going to be none. And the
cursor is going to be pointer, then I want
a little hover effect all sorts of over a
set of pacity to 0.8. That's why I had this
transition here. Also, I just want to check
also, the font sizes here. Font big. Maybe
we can use this one instead on the styles
for the search bar because I think I have.
Yeah, I have the font size, or 20 pixels,
we can use the variable instead variable on
big and see how it looks. Yeah, I think that
looks nice. Actually, we can use that one
instead. But let's check out the button. Yeah,
you can see that it works. It looks great.
Now, we only have to create a logic footer
button now when so that we actually can load
more movies. So that's what we're going to
do in the next video. This is actually the
last video for the homepage. So we're going
to create the fetching logic for loading more
movies. And we're going to start in the US
home fetch hook that we have in our hooks
folder. And we're going to start by creating
a new state. So this is going to work in a
way that we have a state with a kind of a
flag that was set to true or false. And we
set that one to true when we click on a button.
And then we're going to trigger reuse effect.
Because as I said before, I think this is
great practice with the use effect hook and
also the state hooks. So you could do this
in other ways also. But this is a quite neat
way of doing it we have this state that was
set to true or false. And when it changes,
we trigger that use effect. And then we can
trigger to load more movies, we first create
the state const is loading more camel casing
as always. And then we have the setters set
is loading more, it's going to equal and we
call the use state hook we set it to false
initially. And this one is going to be triggered
from the button itself. So we have to export
it down here also. So after the set search
term, we can export set is loading more. So
there you have it, I removed the sidebar,
so we can see the complete row here. Now we're
exporting six of those. So that's our state.
So we can go back to the home.js file. And
here we have our button but we first need
to destructure out the set is loading more
set is loading more. There's some auto formatting,
and it will clean it up for us a little bit.
So we just structure that one also. And that
means that we can use it in this component.
And one thing that we also didn't do is to
actually check if we have an error so we can
do that before the return statement here.
If error We can return a div that says something
went wrong. Like that. And that will make
sure that if we get too narrow, we won't display
everything here, we will display this error
message instead of. So you can create a more
sophisticated stuff here, if you want to do
that. In our case, I think it's enough for
this course. Alright, so let's move on to
this set is loading more. So we have our button
down below here. And we already created a
callback prop. So we give it the callback
prop curly brackets, and this one is going
to have an inline arrow function. Because
I want to call this one with an argument set
is loading more. Yeah, I'm going to remove
the sidebar set is loading more, and we're
going to set it to true like this. So this
will change this state when we click the bottom.
And if we check out the application, we won't
actually be able to see anything. Now, you
can see that it renders when we click the
bottom because it costs logs this out, so
we know that it's working. And one great thing
to know that is that if I click a few more
times here, you can see that it don't rerender
anymore. And that is because we're giving
it the same value. So react won't update the
state if it gets the same value. So it's good
to know that with react, if you give it the
same state value, it won't rerender it. So
react is kind of smart, it already knows that
it has the same value. So it won't do anything,
a quick little pro tip in react. Alright,
so we know that the button is working. So
we move back to the use home fetch hook. And
we're going to create another use effect down
here. below the search use effect, I'm going
to mark it with load more. So just as before
I create another use effect, an inline arrow
function, and we have the dependency array.
And we want this to trigger when the is load
more is changing. So it's load loading more
like this. And the thing is that we only want
this use effect to trigger when we actually
is loading more. So if not, is loading more
if this one is false, we're just going to
return we don't want to do anything else in
this use effect. This one should only do something
when we load more movies. And what we want
to do now is to call or fetch movies function
again. In this time, we want to give it a
State DOT page, plus one because we want to
load the next page. And we also give it a
search term if we're in a search. And now
you can see that it was associated because
it wants a few other dependencies, it tells
us that we need to specify the search term
and the State DOT page. That's what we're
going to do the search term and the State
DOT page. And now it will be happy at us.
And that is because these ones are outside
of the use effect. So we should always specify
dependencies in the dependency array. And
we should handle them inside of the use effect
hook. If there's something we don't want to
do when something change, we should account
for that inside of this use effect. So we
fetching movies, and then we set is loading
more to false. Do some more formatting and
save it. And hopefully this should work. So
we have the use effect of triggers. When we
change the is loading more Boolean. If we're
not loading more, we will just return we don't
do anything else in this effect. Otherwise,
we call the fetch movies function. And we
give it the next page that we want to fetch.
And we also give it a search term. And then
we set it slowly more to force again so that
we go back to what it was before. And then
we can do it all over again, if we want to
click the Load More button again, save it
and go back to the browser and see if this
works. We click the load more. And as you
can see, it works. And I love when stuff just
works. And you can see that our loading spinner
is showing showing up also. It's fast, so
we can't hardly see it, but it's there. So
it's working. And we can also see in the console,
here we are at page 11. And we have 220 results
now. So that's great. We know that load more
is working. We can also try it out so that
it works when we search for something. And
it does. So that's sweet. I'm happy with this.
Hope you like it too. You can see also those
those images, some of them has some strange
proportions. So if you want you can tweak
the CSS to take that into account also. In
the next video, we're going to start creating
our routes for application. We're going to
start creating the routing for our application.
And before we do that, I just want to talk
shortly about react router. Especially the
version six that we're using. It's not officially
released when I record this tutorial. So hopefully
it released now, when you watch this tutorial,
because it is, as they say, here, it's around
the corner. And I actually talked to this
guy, Michael Jackson here on Twitter. And
he said that I should use this version in
my course, because it's that stable now, and
it's not going to change that much. And we're
not going to use all the advanced functionality
in the router itself. So that's why we installed
the next version of react router when we install
the dependencies for this application. And
there are a few changes in it if you compare
it to version five. And I actually don't want
to talk about version five, because that will
soon be deprecated. So just wanted to mention
why I chose to use the version six of the
React router, because this is the future version.
And it has the API that is going to be used
for a long time, hopefully, in the future.
So that's why I use it. In this tutorial,
I want to make sure that this tutorial uses
the latest stuff, so that you know that you're
up to date on the things that you learn. So
that's why so just a few words, words here
you can compare, for example, they brag here
with a react router, version five, that the
bundle size is 20.4 kilobytes minified. And
the version six is only going to be 8.5 kilobytes
minified. So if you care a lot about size
on your packages, this one is drastically
smaller than the version five. And then they
also show you some stuff here on how you use
the router. But that's what I'm going to show
you in the next video. But if you want to
read more about this one here, you can go
to react training.com forward slash blog forward
slash react dash router dash version six dash
pri, forward slash. And then you can read
more about it or just google react router
version six, and you will probably find a
lot of information about it if you want to
read more about it. So let's get started.
We're going to create the routing in the next
video. We're finished the home page and we
have our application here. And we have this
nice little grid with all the movies, but
we can't actually click on them to view a
movie. And we can't click on the logo up here.
So we have to fix that. And we're going to
do that by creating some routes for our application.
So the first thing we're going to do is if
we go back to the code, we're going to create
two more components inside a components folder,
we're going to create a new file that called
not found dot j s, and also not a file that's
called movie dot j s, capital M on movie and
capital and capital F are not found. So we're
just going to scaffold This one's out. So
we have something to route to. If we're in
the movie.js file, we import react from react,
then I create a component are called movie
that is going to be an arrow function. And
I'm just going to return a div that says movie.
And now export default movie, do some more
formatting and save it always save your files.
Alright, then I copy this one. And I go inside
of the notfound file that we just created.
I paste it in and I change this one, I'm going
to share them in one go not found like this
and save it. And there you have it we have
two components to play with. And this one,
the movie dot j s is going to be the individual
movie component for showing the movie. So
we're going to be working a lot in this component
later. This one is going to be a series I'm
not going to create a fancy and not found
component. So you can do some stuff on your
own in this one if you want to do that. So
we scaffold out two components. And then we
can move inside the app.js file that you find
in the src folder not in the components folder.
So app.js. And the first thing we have to
do is to actually import all the components
we need from the router library from react
router. We can mark it here with routing.
If we want to do that. Then we import we have
curly brackets, we're going to import something
that's called browser router, capital D capital
R. And this name is a little bit long. So
if you want to rename this module, you can
do that by typing s and router. So we import
it as router. I think I'm going to remove
this sidebar also. Alright, so that's the
first one we import browser router, but we
import it as router so we can use it with
the name router instead. Then we import another
component that's called routes. And then we
import another component that's called route
very similar names here. So be careful when
you import these ones. And we import them
from something that's called react dash router.
So be very careful here. We're not importing
it from just react dash router. We Pulling
it from react router DOM. So this one is using
react router in the background. But this one
is specifically created for using in the dome.
Alright, so that's all the inputs that we're
going to do. So let's create our components
down below here. And I'm actually going to
change this one to an implicit return. So
I delete the return and the curly bracket.
And I want to create an arrow function instead
const f equals because it's only with arrow
functions, you can do an implicit return and
I remove the curly bracket there, do some
auto formatting, to me, it looks a little
bit cleaner. And this div is going to be replaced
this wrapper div that has a class name of
app going to be replaced with a router to
so we wrap our complete application with the
router. So it's really important where you
want to put the routes, you should wrap it
with the router. And that is the browser router
that we imported here, but we renamed it to
router. So that's why I use it as router here.
Then the header is going to be shown on both
the home page and the individual movie page.
So the header is going to be left out of the
routes. So I'll leave that one here. And then
I use the route component. And inside of the
routes component, we can create our routes.
And the first route, we're going to use the
component that's called route. So we have
three different components here from the router
library router, we're going to wrap our complete
application in this case, and then we have
routes, that's going to wrap a route because
you can route in different components if you
want to do that. So let's say that you have
a component deep down in your app tree, and
then you want to create some routes for just
that component, you can wrap them in this
route component, and then you create the routes.
So you don't need to have them here in the
top of your application. And then you use
the route component to actually create your
route. And this route component has a prop
that's called path. So we can specify the
path where we want to show a specific component.
And in this case, it's a forward slash because
it's the homepage. And then we have another
prop that's called element is going to equal
and here we can give it a component. And we
want to give it the home component like this.
And then we also have to self close the route
component. That means that we can remove this
home component here. So that's the first wrote,
if we want, we can save this to see that it
still works, go back to the application, reload
it, and you can see that it works. So that's
nice, then we're going to create another route.
So we use the route component again, we set
the path, and this one is going to be forward
slash. And then we're going to do something
special here because when we're going to fetch
an individual movie, we need the movie ID
and we can send a long route params for that.
And we create a route params for the route
by specifying a colon, and then we name it.
So movie ID. So this means when we create
a link on the thumbnails that we're going
to do soon, we can send along the ID for the
movie. And that ID, we can grab that in our
movie component and grab data from the API.
And you can name this to whatever you want.
Because this is a rod puram that you decide
what you want it to be named. So I want it
to be named movie ID. And then we specify
the element on this one. And we give it the
movie component. And we also close the route
component. We haven't actually import the
movie components, we can do that. Import movie
from dot forward slash, components. Movie.
And then we can also import not found from
dot forward slash components and not found.
There you have it. So that's the route for
the individual movie, we save it. And we can't
actually click on the thumbnail now because
we haven't created that one. But what we can
do is go up here, create a forward slash,
and then we type in some ID. And you can see
that it types out movie here now. And that
is because it's showing the movie component
so we know that it's working. That's sweet.
And then if we remove this one, we'll show
the homepage instead. Alright, we're going
to create one last route. And that is for
our not found component. So we create a route
with a path of forward slash and an asterisk.
And this will make sure that we show the not
found component on any other route that don't
exist. And we set the element to the not found
component. And we also surf close this route,
save it go back to the application. We know
that it works if we specify an id like this,
it shows the movie component But what happens
if we create Another route here like this,
yeah, then I chose to not found. And that's
super sweet because then we have a fallback
component if the user tries to go somewhere
else in our application. So that's the route
set up in our app.js file. Then if we move
inside of our header component, and the index.js
file, we're going to create a link on the
logo. Up here, we have to import curly brackets,
and the component is called link from react
dash router dash DOM. And this is actually
quite simple. It works the similar way as
the a tag does in HTML. So we have a link
component we specified to and in this case,
it's going to lead to the home page, so we
have a forward slash. And inside the link
component, we just put our logo like this.
So we wrap it inside of the link component.
And this will make sure that we can link to
the homepage, so go back to the browser. For
now, we specify an ID. So we're in the movie
component, and then we click on this logo.
And we go back to the home page. So really
easy to make links with react router. You
can also make them programmatically. But we're
not going to do that in this course, because
it's kind of a little bit more advanced. And
we don't really need it in this application.
But we have to add a link to the thumbnail
also. So that we know that we can click on
a thumbnail, and that will lead to a specific
movie. So inside the thumb component, the
index.js file will do the same thing up here
we import curly brackets link from react dash
router dash dome. And we have this prop here
that's called clickable because we are going
to use this thumbnail for the movie poster
on each individual page also. And that means
that we won't be able to click that one. So
we have to have this Boolean to check if we
should be able to click the thumbnail or not.
And the way I solve this is to create a ternary
operators. So here just below the div we check
if clickable is true. It's enough to type
in clickable, then we have the question mark.
And I have parenthesis. And I'm going to use
my link component and it's going to link to
and in this case, we want to use the movie
ID because as I talked about before, we are
going to send along this ID in the route.
And we can grab it later in the movie ID params
that we create here. So we have backticks.
I create a template literal here. So I have
forward slash, then I have dollar sign curly
brackets, and I'm going to give it the movie
ID and this will give it a link with a forward
slash and the movie ID close the link component.
And then we have our image. And in this case,
I'm going to copy this one and paste it in.
So this is if the thumbnail should be clickable,
then in the ternary operator Be very careful
here it should be after this parenthesis,
I create a colon and then I create a new pair
of parenthesis. And I move this image inside
of that one. And I also have to end the ternary
operator with a curly bracket. And then I
do some auto formatting. So what did I do
here? Well, I create a ternary operator checking
if the clickable is true or not, I show the
link component with the image wrapped inside
it. And that means that we'll be able to click
on this thumbnail. Otherwise, that's what's
right to the colon here, I just show the image
as it is or don't wrap it in a link component.
So the user won't be able to click it. Save
the file, go back to the application. And
hopefully we should be able to click our thumbnails,
you can see that we have this nice little
hand here. That means that we've created a
link. So if we click this one, you can also
see that we have the movie ID up here. And
that's the one that we're going to grab in
the puram in our movie component. So it's
working great. And this is actually it for
the routing, there's no more routing we need
to do in this application. And in the next
video, we're going to start creating the movie
page. Okay, we're just going to do a little
bit of scaffolding in our movie component
before we move on. So up here we're already
importing react, we're going to import some
stuff from the config also. So import, we're
going to need the image, underscore base,
underscore URL capital letters and the poster
underscore size. And we're going to import
it from dot dot forward slash config. Then
we're going to have our components we're going
to create new ones for this one. But two of
them we already created. We're going to import
the grid from dot forward slash win. Then
we're also going to need a spinner so import
spinner Apart from dot forward slash spinner,
and then we're going to create the other ones
later, we're going to create a hook for this
one. And we also need an image. And that's
the fallback image just as before. So import,
no image, from dot dot forward slash images,
and no underscore image dot jpg. And as always
be very careful to actually add the extension
here, when it's an image. All right, and then
we have our movie component, this one is actually
not going to have an implicit return, we create
curly brackets, because we're going to have
some logic in this one. So we create a return
statement, parenthesis. And then we're going
to create a react fragment, like this. And
inside for now, we can just have a div that
says, movie, do some auto formatting, and
save it. And I think this should be it, go
back to the browser. Try something else here.
Or we could actually just have clicked on
one of these. Yeah, and it shows movies. That's
great. We know that it works. And then we
can move on. And we're going to start by fetching
the data from the API so that we have something
to work with. All right, we're going to create
our second custom hook. Now, I'm not going
to create it first in the movie component,
and then move it to a custom hook. Because
now we know how we can create a custom hook.
So that's why I'm doing it instantly in that
one instead. So in the hooks folder, let's
create a new file that's called use movie,
fetch capital M, capital F, and dot j s. And
as I told you before, it's important to name
your hooks with use before the name. This
is the actual finance. So it doesn't matter
here. But it's important that you name your
actual hook with use before. So for this hook,
we're going to import curly brackets, we're
going to need use state and use effect from
react. Just as before, we don't really need
a main react library for this one, because
we're not doing any JSX and stuff like that.
So that's why we're not importing it, we're
going to import the API object from dot dot
forward slash API. And that will give us access
to all these nice functions that are created
for us. Then we create the actual hooked,
so export const, use movie fetch, equals and
this one is actually going to have a parameter,
because it's going to be the movie ID. And
I'll talk more about that in a second. So
that's the arrow function. And up here, I
create three states, the state and setter
for that state. I call the use state hooked.
And I'm going to give it an empty object as
default value. Now I create a loading state
and set loading. You state I'm going to set
this one to true initially, because this component
is going to start by fetching the data for
a movie, so we can set that one to true. And
then we're going to have the error and a set
error just as before, and this one was set
to false. So you state and give it an initial
value of false, right. So that's the state
we're going to need for this one. And then
we're just going to need one use effect. For
this one, because we only fetching data one
time, and that is when the component mounts,
and then we're not going to fetch anything
more, because then we have all the data from
the movie that we need to have the inline
arrow function. And we have the dependency
rate. And this one is going to change if the
movie ID changes, it actually not going to
change now, because we just do it initially,
as I told you, but as I also told you, we
need to specify all the dependencies for our
use effect. So that's fine, in this case,
to have it there, it only going to fetch it
one time. And then as a use effect can't have
an async function here, we create another
function that async fetch data equals async.
And in this case, I placed it inside of the
use effect, and I'm going to show you why
in a second also. So we have an async arrow
function. And then we can do our fetching
logic inside of this one, and it's going to
be quite similar to the other one that we
did. So we have a try block. And we're going
to catch the error if there is one. And if
there is an error with set error to true like
this. Then in our try block, the first thing
we do is this That loading to true. And we
also set error to false. Yes, that's we did
before. And then we can fetch our data. But
I have a typo here. It just say, error. Yeah,
I guess I misspelled it up here. Yeah. There
you have it, right. Yeah, this one too. Ah,
something like that. Right. So first, we're
going to grab the movie data from one resource
from them point. And then we also have to
grab the credits that we get from another
resource from them point. So we have const,
movie equals a weight. And from the API, I
created a function that called fetch movie
without an S at the end. There we go, going
to give it the movie ID. Right. So that's
the movie, then we also want to fetch the
credits. So we create a cost to that when
that we named credits, we await again from
the API dot fetch credits. And we also give
it a movie ID. So hopefully, we got all the
data that we need here in those costs. But
we want to do some stuff here. And that is,
we only want to show the director solely because
if we look at the finished application, and
we go back, and we click Whoa, yeah, there
you have it encountered two children with
the same Keith. And this is what happens sometimes
with this API. And I really don't know why.
So if you get this warning, you can create
your own unique key somehow, by maybe have
a random number and the movie ID, I don't
know, you can do it in many different ways.
But for now, it doesn't really matter. So
we have the movie here. And as you can see,
here, we are showing the directors, we need
to get the directors somehow from the API.
Because from the API and the credits, we get
something back, that's called crew. And the
crew contains more than the directors. So
we have to filter out the directors to just
get the directors name. So I mark it with
get directors only. And then I create the
new cast, I call it directors equals and from
the credits, that's the one up here, we have
the crew properties. And I'm going to filter
this one filter is a built in method in JavaScript,
we have a member a crew member. So I'm going
to check if the member dot job, this is also
a property that we get back from the Movie
Database API, are going to check if that one
is equal to director with a capital D. And
that will filter out all the directors and
put them in this const. Or format it. And
then we have all the data that we need, so
that we can set our state, so we call sub
state, that's the setter for our state. In
this case, we don't need to use a previous
value. So I'm just returning an object here,
I spread out the movie. That's the data that
we got back here. So we spread out everything
from that one. And then we have a property
that's called actors. And I'm going to give
it the credits dot cast. So from the credits,
we have the cast, and we also got the directors
from the crew. So the actors is a property
that I create myself that I want to have in
my state. And I'm going to have all the cast
inside of the actors property. And the last
one is going to be the directors, there can
be more than one director. So that's why it's
called directors with an S. And as this is
iOS six syntax, we just need to type out this
it will create it like this automatically.
Alright. Then we're going to set loading the
false like this. Auto format it and this should
be for this use effect. Actually, I think
for now, we need to return something from
our hook also. return an object with the state
loading and error. Save it go back to the
movie.js file. We can see if it works. So
down here I marked it with hook. I'm going
to import use movie fetch Rome dot dot forward
slash hooks and use movie fetch. And then
we can try out our hooked and see if we get
some data back. So at the top of our component,
we can destructure out the properties that
we exported from the hooked I also want to
show you how you can rename something when
you're distracted. So we have the state that
we destructed, and we have a colon, and I
want to call it movie instead. So that's how
you rename it. And then we destructor out
loading and error. Then we call or use movie
fetch choked. And we also want to give it
the movie ID. But we haven't really got the
movie ID. So how do we get it? Yeah, and this
is from the route that we have up here, as
I told you about before, we have the ID up
here in the routes, we can get that one from
the router. So we have to import something
up here. So we import curly brackets, it's
a hook that's called use params. From react
dash router, dash dome. So with this hook,
we can grab that params that we have in the
URL. So we'll do that before we destructure
out the state and everything here from our
use movie fetch hook to make sure that we
have the ID to send into that hook, the const,
and then we destructure out the movie ID equals
and we call the use params. That's everything
you have to do. And this one is named movie
ID because we named it that in the app.js
file. We call it movie ID. If we call it something
else here, we have to distract it with that
name. But this will give us that ID that we
have up in the road here in our application.
So hopefully this will work when we tried
to console log out the movie, and this is
actually the state but I renamed it to movie.
So that's why I can console log it out as
movie. Save it. So we try it out, click a
movie and nothing shows up. And I think I
know why we go inside the use movie fetch
hook, we also need to actually invoke this
function here. So we do that at the bottom
of our use effect hook. Fetch movie. Did I
name it fetch data, we can rename it to fetch
movie instead, like this. And make sure to
invoke it at the bottom of the hook. Save
it go back to the application. And now you
can see that we have the data here. So we
have all the actors. And we also have the
directors that were filtered out here. So
that's great. All the data that we need is
here. I want to show you one more thing here.
And that is if we were to remove this, that
movie function outside of the use effect like
this, it tells us here that we need to specify
the fetch movie, and that's okay, because
it's outside the use effect. Now, we do that.
And then it gives us another warning here.
And this is because this function two will
get recreated on each render. And this use
effect will think that it's a new function
that gets on each render, and it will create
an infinity loop. So that's no good. So if
we want to have it placed outside of the use
effect, we need to wrap it in something that's
called a use fallback hook, we can import
that one up here. And then we wrap this one
in the use callback hook like this. And then
at the end of it, we need to have a dependency
array. In this case, it's empty. And then
it gives us another warning. And then it says
that it needs to specify the movie ID because
the movie ID is something that's outside of
this one here. We also need to specify this
one, we specified a movie Id like this. And
now it won't complain. And this one will not
get recreated unless the movie ID changes.
So this will stop the Infinity loop. And we
can see that it won't go into an infinity
loop here. If you want to do it like this,
instead, you can do that. In this case, we
don't need to call this function from anywhere
outside of the use effect. So I'm just going
to revert it back and not use the use callback
hook. So I'm going to have it inside of my
use effect instead. Like we had it before.
Save it make sure that it works again, and
it does. So that's how you use the use callback
hook to stop infinity loops in react. But
in this case, we won't need it. So it's better
to have this function directly in the use
effect hook instead. Alright, let's move on
and create some nice components for our movie
page. Alright, we're going to create this
nice little breadcrumb navigation up here
on each individual movie. So go back inside
of the code editor inside the components folder,
create a new folder that's called Brad Trump.
capital B, capital C and you create another
file inside of that one. Let's call index.js.
And you create a file, let's call the breadcrumbed
dot styles, dot j s a bit repetitive now,
but it's good because that means that we probably
be learning something here. So inside the
breadcrumb dot styles file, we're going to
scaffold out to style components. But first
we import styled from styled components, then
we export the class, that's called wrapper.
And is equals a style.do, double backticks.
And then we export const, that's called content.
It equals A styled dot div, all formatted
and save it. Go back inside of the index.js
file in the breadcrumb folder, first, we import
react from react, we're going to import the
link from react dash router dash DOM. Because
we want to be able to link back to the home
page, then we have our styles, import wrapper,
and content from dot forward slash breadcrumb
dot styles, then we create our component cost
breadcrumbed. equals, then we're going to
destructure to prop is called movie title.
And we create an arrow function and we can
make an implicit returns we have parenthesis
we're going to have the rapper num, we have
the content. Now we're going to use the link
from the React router DOM is going to link
to and where do we think it's going to link?
probably guessed it, it's going to be forward
slash because we want to link to the home
page. This is the first element in the breadcrumb
menu. So we're going to have a regular span
here. And it's going to say home. So that's
the first one, then after the link, we create
another span. And we're going to have a pipe
like this, I think it's option seven on Mac.
Yeah, option seven. Or you can have whatever
you want inside of there. But I'd like to
have that as a divider. And then we have the
last span and that's it's going to be the
movie title. Do some more formatting. And
then we need to export default this one also.
Next export default breadcrumb, right. So
this is going to be a two level breadcrumb,
we only have the home button to click on to
go back to the home page. And then we show
the movie title, save the file and then go
back to the movie.js file. Up here where we
have the component imports, we import breadcrumbed
from dot forward slash breadcrumb. Right.
Now we can use it down here in our JSX. One
thing we can do first is that we can return
something here, if we loading. So if loading
return, we're going to return the spinner
if we're loading something, which we are going
to do initially. And if we have an error,
return a div that says something went wrong,
or something else if you want that. So this
will make sure that we show the loading spinner
initially when we load in all the data for
the movie. And if we have an error, we want
to show that JSX down here, I don't know why
it's a spinner, you know, and deleted. Alright,
so instead of the movie here, I'm going to
remove this one, and I'm going to use my breadcrumb
and it has a prop that's called movie title.
For that one, I'm going to give it a movie
dot original underscore title. And I close
the component like that, save it and go back
to the browser and click a movie and you can
see that we have our bread crumb here. It
looks like crap but we're going to style it
in the next video so don't worry. And it seems
to be working here with a title and everything
and we can click the home button to get back
to the home page. That's not so in the next
video. We're going to give it some styling.
Alright time to give this little breadcrumbs,
some styles and we do that inside of the breadcrumb
dot styles file. We have components inside
of that one, we have the wrapper and the content.
So let's start by styling the wrapper, I'm
going to display it as a flex align items
is going to be center and justify content
is also going to be center. I set the width
100% The height is going to be 70 pixels.
And the background is going to be from the
variable that's called matte gray. And the
color is going to be also from a variable
but that's the white one. Save it go back
and see what we've got so far. You can see
that we have it here but it looks not good
now, so we have to fix this also. And that's
the one here does the content. So the content
was set at one also to flex display flex.
The width is going to be 100%. The max width
on this one is going to be from the variable
max width and the padding is going to be zero
and 20 pixels. Then we have the span element
inside our breadcrumbs, we're going to style
up one also span we set the font size. What
do we have in the global style here in the
root? For me, I think it's the font medium.
So variable dash dash, font med
And the color is going to be for the variable
is going to be white. The padding dash, right
is going to be 10 pixels. And then we're also
going to have a media query for this one.
So add media screen and Max dash with is going
to be 762 pixels. And I'm just going to change
the font size here font size. And I think
yeah, I forgot all of them now. Yeah, font
small. That will do, I think. So from the
variable, font small. Alright, save it and
go back to our application. And there you
have it, and it should change in font size.
Yeah. So it's working, and the link is working.
Great. There's some padding there. I have
it there also, okay. Yeah, it doesn't matter,
you can adjust that one if you want to do
that. Alright, so that's the styles for the
breadcrumbs. So let's move on and create our
movie info component. We're going to create
the movie info component. So we looked at
an individual movie, or we can look at anyone.
It's this component here, it's kind of a hero
component. So I think this will be the largest
individual component in this application.
So we're going to do a little bit of JSX.
And also, it's going to be a little bit of
styling for this one. So we better get started
with this move back to your code editor. And
inside a components folder, create a new folder
that we call movie info, capital M capital
I. And then we'll create a new file index
dot j, s, and then another file inside of
that folder, that's called movie info, dot
styles dot j s. And we scaffold out the style.
So import, styled from styled components.
And for this one, we're actually also going
to import some other stuff here, because we
need the image base URL and the backdrop size
from the config. And I'm going to talk about
that when we style this component, but we
import them now. So import, capital letters,
image, underscore, base, underscore URL, and
also the back drop underscore size. And we
grab them from dot dot forward slash dot dot
forward slash config, right. And we scaffold
out three components here. So export const,
rapper, equals style, Dave, double backticks,
export const. content, hopefully beginning
to see my pattern on styling. In this one,
I usually have a wrapper and the content.
This one is also going to be styled div. And
then we're going to have a third one. That's
going to be called export const text. And
it's also going to equal the style of div
that will backticks. Like so save the file,
go back to the index.js file in the movie
info folder. Now we can start building this
massive component. Now it's not really that
massive, I think it's about 50 rows or something.
All right, import react from react, and then
we're going to have a component, so we're
actually going to use the thumb component
for this one. So import thumb from dot dot
forward slash, thumb. Alright, so that's the
component that we need. We also need something
from the config. So import the image underscore
base underscore URL, and also the poster.
underscore size. From dot dot forward slash
dot dot forward slash double dot dot forward
slash config. Then we have an image. And it's
going to be the fallback image as we always
use, so import no image from dot dot forward
slash dot dot forward slash, again, images.
No underscore image dot jpg. All right. And
then we have our styles. The import curly
brackets, wrapper, content, and text from
dot forward slash, move info dot styles. Right,
that's our imports. Then we're going to create
the component itself. So we have a const.
Movie. info equals anger is a structure of
a prop. That's called movie we're going to
give it the movie data as a prop, an arrow
function and we can make an implicit return
on this one. First, I actually going to export
default its export default movie info, like
so, then inside of here, we're first gonna
have a wrapper. And this one is actually going
to take in a prop. That's going to be the
backdrop image. So we have a prop that called
backdrop. And from the movie, we have a property
that's called backdropped. underscore path.
And we close the component and inside the
wrapper, we have our content, like so then
we're going to use a thumb component again.
And this is actually great, because you can
see here how you can reuse components in react.
And this is kind of the fundamentals of working
with components, you can reuse them in your
application. So you should always code with
that in mind, if you want to reuse it somewhere,
you should make the components flexible. So
you don't need to create similar components,
it's better to use one component that you
can modify with props instead. So we have
our thumb. And on that one, if you remember,
we have an image prop. So we're going to give
it the image. And this one, just as before,
I'm going to check if it's as a movie poster
path, I use a ternary operator for this one,
I have a question mark. And also note, I created
curly brackets here, because this is a JavaScript
expression. And as I like to do it with template
literals, I'm going to have double backticks.
And I have $1 sign and then I'm going to grab
the image base URL, then I have another dollar
sign and curly brackets, I'm going to grab
the poster size. And then lastly, I'm going
to have a new dollar sign and curly brackets.
And I'm going to grab the movie dot poster
underscore path. So that is if we have a poster
pass. Otherwise, we have a colon and we show
the no image that we imported. That's the
image prop. Then we have the clickable prop.
And in this case, we're going to give it false
because we don't want this one to be clickable,
we set an OLT of movies thumb. And then we
can close this component, do some more formatting,
save it and we can actually go back to our
move it up JS component and import this one
here where we import the components, import
movie info, from dot forward slash, movie
info. And then below here below the breadcrumb
or we can use a move in for component like
this, we give it a drop of movie. And it's
going to be the complete movie stayed. If
you want, you can specify it even more in
detail if you don't want to give it the complete
state but I think for simplicity's sake, I
give it the complete state here to work with,
say the file go back to our browser. And you
can see that we have our image here. And we
can click it and that's great. So yes, yes,
it works with some other stuff here. Yeah,
it does. That's great. Move back inside of
the index.js file in the movie info folder.
So we created our thumb and just below the
thumb, we're going to have our text. So we
use the text style component. And inside of
that one, we're going to have an h1 tag. And
I'm going to grab the movie dot title for
that one. Then we have an age three tag. And
it's going to say plot or something else if
you want that. Next we have a p tag. And we're
going to grab the movie dot overview. And
that's the short text about the movie. And
inside of here, I actually going to create
some regular classes with class name, because
I want to show you that also, you could create
stock components. Also, if you want to do
that for these that I'm going to create now.
But I'm going to create a regular div with
a class name or rating dash directors, I'm
going to have both the rating and the directors
in this one. And inside of this one, I'm going
to nest another div. And inside that div,
I'm going to nest an H three tag that's going
to say rating, like that. And then I have
another div with a class name. That's going
to be that's going to be score. And then I'm
going to grab from the movie dot vote underscore
average. And that will give us the score from
the API. Let's do rating. Then below this
wrapping div are going to create another wrapping
div and this one going to have a class name
of director and inside of that one are going
to have another age retag and it's going to
say director and I'm going to do a little
trickier because if there's more than one
director, we won't To say directors, so I
create curly brackets. And inside here I oops,
don't know why did like that, okay. And inside
the curly brackets, I can have a JavaScript
expression. And I can check if movie dot directors
dot length. If that one is greater than one,
I'm going to add in an S, like this. Otherwise,
I just return an empty string. If there's
only one, it will say director, otherwise
it will say directors. then below that header,
we create another pair of curly brackets,
because now we have to loop through the directors
and display them in our dome. So from our
movie, we have this property that's called
directors, we're going to map over that one.
And we have a director, we can make an implicit
return in this arrow function. So we have
a p tag with a key, it's always important
to include a key as you know, otherwise, React
will complain react uses the key internally
to diff stuff, so it knows what to change
in the DOM. Okay, so the key is going to be
from from the director, we're going to grab
something that's called credit underscore
ID. And this will be unique, right, and inside
the p tag, we have another pair of curly brackets,
and I'm going to grab the director, dot name,
auto formatted. So that's the directors and
this should hopefully be it. So we can save
it, go back to the application and see what
we got, we probably won't see anything because
this text is white, I guess. Or if we check
here below, we can see that we are the last
it is in white now. So you can see it, the
rating is 5.1. And we have a directory also.
So we know that it's working, we just have
to give it some styling to make it look nice.
And that's exactly what we're going to do
in the next video. We have finished a logic
for a movie and four components. So it's time
to style this one. Go back inside of the code
editor. And inside the movie info dot styles
dot j s, we start off with a wrapper. For
this one, we set the background and this one
is going to be based on a prop that we're
selling. That is called backdrop. So I'm going
to create a ternary operator here because
if we don't have a backdrop, then we're going
to set the background to be just black. And
if you remember when we grab a prop in a style
component, we can do that with $1 sign and
curly brackets. Because this is a template
literal. So that's how you create a JavaScript
expression. And then I'm going to destructure
out from the props. So I have a parenthesis
and curly brackets again. So I'm going to
destructor out the backdrop like this. And
then I create an inline arrow function. And
then I'm going to create a ternary operator
here to check if the backdrop exists. So backdrop,
then I have a question mark. And then I do
another template literal. Inside of here,
we have the URL. And I have a regular single
quote, I don't actually know if we need this
one. But I'm gonna leave it in just to be
sure. And then dollar sign curly brackets.
And I grabbed the image base URL. And then
I have again, dollar sign and curly brackets,
and I grabbed the backdrop size, and I have
a third dollar sign and curly brackets. And
I'm going to grab the backdrop, that's the
one that we send into this component. So that
is if we have a backdrop otherwise, to the
right of the colon. I'm going to show a black
color. And then we have a semi colon to MDS
with just after the last curly bracket. This
can be a little bit nested here and hard to
read actually see if it does something if
I yeah, it's all formatted on one row. Okay,
yeah, that's fine. I'm going to remove this
sidebar. So you can see this is maybe easier
to read. So I check if the backdrop is true.
And then to the right to the question mark
are going to parse in the image base URL and
the backdrop size, and then we'll have the
backdrop that we're sending to this star component.
If this exists, we're going to show that one
as a background. Otherwise, we set the background
to be black. Right, then we're going to set
the background dash size. It's going to be
cover and then we have the background dash
position. That one is going to be center.
And I'm going to set a little bit of padding
on this one. So 40 pixels and 20 pixels. And
I have an animation also because I want this
one to fade off just as the other ones. animate
movie info, camel casing, and one second and
then I create The keyframes so add keyframes
like this, and then we go from. Or if you
want to use 0%, instead, we set the opacity
to zero, and then two, or 100%. If you use
that instead, Opacity is going to be one,
save it and see what we got. Okay? I must
have some typos somewhere because we we don't
see the background. Yeah, and that's because
I need to have this single quote here also,
at the end, save it and go back. And there
you have the backdrop. That's sweet, I can
actually try also to remove those and see
if it works without them. Yeah, and it seems
to be working. So we don't actually need to
have those single quotes. Alright, sweet.
Okay, that's the wrapper move down. And then
we're going to style the content itself, we
set the display to flex, the max dash with
is going to be from a variable max with. Then
we set the margin to zero and all the background,
I'm going to set a transparent black on this
one. So RGB or RGBA, I don't think you need
a actually 000 and 0.7. That will make it
a little bit transparent. Then we have a border
radius of 20 pixels. And we have a media query
on this one also. So at media screen, and
max width is going to be 768 pixels on this
one. And then we're going to display it as
a block and set the max height to none. And
that's it for the content, save it, go back
to the application. And you can see that we
have the content here. But we need to do some
more styling here on the text to get it to
look exactly as we want. So we have our text
style component here. And for this one, we
set the width to 100%. I set the padding to
20 pixels, and 40 pixels. Set the color from
the variables white. And overflow is going
to be hidden on this one. Then I'm going to
grab a class. That's called rating dash director.
So that's the one that I created inside of
here. rating dash directors, you can grab
them just as a regular class in the star component.
So that's why you don't need to create a separate
star component for each and every element.
If you don't want to do that some elements
are really small. And maybe it's not justified
to have its own style component. So we're
going to display it as a flex and justify
content is going to be flex dash start. Then
we have the sport class. This one is also
going to display it as a flex align dash items
is going to be center and justify content
is going to be center so these three will
center stuff for us. And you could also create
a separate class if you don't want to type
them in all the time. The width is going to
be 35 pixels. The height is also going to
be 35 pixels background is going to be white.
So FFF and the color is going to be black.
And you could also of course create variables
for these ones. If you want to do that and
place them in the global style where we have
the other CSS variables. The font dash width
is going to be 800 border dash radius is going
to be 25 pixels. Or you can actually set it
to 50% if you want that is instead because
this is a circle and the Morgan is going to
be zero. That's the score. And then we have
our director. So dot director the Morgan is
going to be 0004 pixels on that one. And inside
of that one we have a p tag and we set the
margin to zero on that. And below we have
the last one that's the h1 tag. And that one
is going to media screen and Max dash with
760 pixels. And we set the font dash size,
the variable, dash dash font big. Right? Save
it go back to the application. Yeah. So there's
something here that doesn't look right. And
I think I know what it is. Yeah, this one
is called directors. And probably, I misspelled
this one yet rating directors, we should have
an S zeroes on that class, make sure that
you add an s and save it. Go back to the application.
And now it should look right. Yeah, it does,
we can see if it looks great on another movie,
also, and it does. Sweet. So that's the movie
info component. In the next video, we're going
to check out this little movie info bar that's
below here we can see the running time to
budget and the revenue. Let's create the movie
infobar. And that's the one here with running
time, budget and revenue. We're going to start
as always by creating the component first
and then we create the styles in the next
video. So we start off in the components folder
by creating a new folder that we call movie
infobar, capital M, capital I capital D. And
inside of that folder, we're going to create
a new file that's called index dot j s. And
then we're going to create another file that's
called boring stuff. No, I'm just kidding.
Of course not. But it's getting a little bit
repetitive here, it's going to be called movie
in full bore.styles.js. Of course, we start
off by scaffolding out those components, import
styled, ROM styled components. And we export
constant, we have our wrapper, style dot div,
double backticks. And then we're going to
have our content export cones content equals
stand, dot div, and double backticks. Save
the file and go back to the index.js file,
we import react from react. And then we're
going to use some helper functions that are
provided for us, they will take a look in
the helpers.js file, you can see that I have
one function for calculating time, and one
for converting the money. So this one for
example, the Convert money, JavaScript has
something built in that we can use for converting
into a currency. And this one I said is one
for converting it into US dollars, you can
change this one if you want to have another
currency. And this one is going to give us
the time in hours and minutes. So these are
the ones that we're going to import in the
component. So move back to the index.js file.
And I mark it with helpers. Import calc, time,
camel casing and convert money also camel
casing wrong. dot dot forward slash and dot
dot forward slash again, help us right, then
we have our styles. So we import curly brackets
and wrapper and content. From dot forward
slash movie and FUBAR stars, all right. And
then we can create our component. So we have
our concept of movie info bar equals, this
one is going to get some props. So I destructure
the time, the budget and the revenue. And
I have an arrow function and I make an implicit
return. And I think I'm also going to export
default, before we start creating our JSX.
So export default movie info bar. All right,
we start off with our wrapper. Now we have
our content. And the first div we're going
to have is a deal if we have a class name
or column on that one. So we have a p tag,
a running time colon, then I have a curly
bracket, and we invoke the function that's
called calc time that we import it. And we
give it the value of time, and we end it with
a curly bracket. So that would give us the
correct time. And actually, the other two
days are going to look almost exactly the
same. So I'm going to copy this one and paste
them in two more times. The class name is
going to be column also on this ones, but
this one we can change it to budget. And instead
of chart time, we're going to invoke convert
money instead and we're going to give it budget.
Now the last one is going to be revenue. And
we also invoke convert money and give it the
revenue. Right? Save it. And this is our movie
in football, we just need to make sure that
we use it in the movie component. So move
back to the movie.js imported up here, import
movie info bar from dot forward slash, movie
info bar. And then below just below the movie
info. We use that component movie info bar.
And we also have to give it some props time
is going to equal movie dot runtime budget
is going to equal movie budget. And the revenue
is going to be the movie dot revenue. And
then we close the component like this, do
some more formatting, and we get him on each
row. So that's much nicer. We can see it here
now. So we have these props here. Now. This
should be it for a movie and FUBAR. If we
save this one, go back to the browser. And
nothing shows. And that's because we haven't
styled it yet. I thought we should see something
at least. But I guess it's because the Yeah,
the text is white now. So that's why so you
can see down here that we have the running
time we had the budget. But the budget is
actually Ciro that's no good. Or is it zeroed
out on that particular movie? Yeah, it was,
it didn't have any budget. Right. So in the
next video, we're going to start it. Alright,
we're going to create the styles for the movie.
And for Boris, make sure that you insert a
movie in FUBAR dot stars file. And we start
as always with wrapper, we display it as flex,
align the items. To center, I'm going to set
a min height on this one 200 pixels. And the
background is going to be from the variables
and I'm going to grab the dark gray. I set
the padding to zero and 20 pixels. Save it
go back and see what we got so far. Yeah,
we can see it down here. So go back to the
code, then we're going to start the content,
we display it as a flex. I set the max win
over variable from the variable max width.
I set the width to 100%. And the Morgan is
going to be CRN auto. Then, we have that class
that's called column. So dot column. That's
the one if you remember that we have here
the class name column. And I also got to display
that one as a flex flex box is a really handy
tool in CSS a line items is going to be Sunder
and justify content is going to be Sunder
assess the background, from our variable are
going to grab med grade, a set of border dash
radius to 20 pixels, the margin is going to
be zero 20 pixels, and the flex is going to
be set to one. Then I'm going to style the
first child we have we have three of them.
So I want to start the first shot a little
bit differently. I want to set the Morgan
dash left to zero. And I also want to start
the last child with colon last dash child
I set the Morgan dash right to zero. Right.
Now we just have a media query left at the
bottom here at media screen and Max dash with
several 168 pixels are displayed as a block
below that pixel size. And the column dot
column is going to have a margin of 20 pixels
and zero, right? This should be it, save it
back to the application. If it works, yeah,
there you have it. It works on mobile devices
also. That's super great. That's the movie
infobar. And now we just have the grid with
the actors left to do and then we've finished
the basic stuff with this application. Alright,
let's create the last component for our application.
And that's going to be the actor. Inside a
components folder, create a new folder that
the name actor. And then you create a new
file inside of that folder that we're going
to call index dot j s. And we created another
file that's called actor dot styles, dot j
s. And inside the actor dot styles dot j s,
we import styled Rome style components. And
then we export the cost that we call wrapper
equals style dot div, double backticks. And
then we're going to have another one, export
const is going to be called image capital
I, of course, equals style dot IMG, we're
going to style this image tag, save it, go
back to the index.js file, and we can create
our actual component. So import react from
react. Then we have our styles. And we import
the wrapper and the image, ROM dot forward
slash actor styles. Then we create the component
const actor equals parenthesis and another
a destructor. Out inside of the curly brackets,
the name, the character and the image URL.
We have an arrow function, we make an implicit
return we have the wrapper, then we're going
to display our image, we have the source or
image URL ot is going to equal actor dash
thumb. And then we close it. Now we have an
H three tag, that's going to display the names
of curly brackets and name that's the prop
name. And then we have a p tag and we have
curly brackets and we're going to grab the
character that's going to be the name of the
character. Right, then we just need to export
default actor and or component is good to
go. So go back to the movie.js file imported
up here, import actor from dot forward slash
actor, right, and then move down to our JSX.
I'm just below the movie info bar. We're going
to show these actors and we're going to show
them inside of our grid. So we first display
a grid. The header for this one is going to
be actors. If you remember, we have this prop
that's called header where we can set the
title of our grid. And inside a grid, we're
going to map through all the actors. So we
have curly brackets, and from the movie dot
actors, we're going to map through each actor.
So we have an actor and an inline arrow function,
parenthesis, we make an implicit return. Then
we display an actor, it needs to have a key,
as always, when we met through stuff in our
JSX in react, so the key is going to be from
the actor dot credit underscore ID. That's
the key. Then we have a prop that's called
name. So we're going to give it the actor
dot name. And a scroll up a little bit here.
And then we have a prop that's called character.
And for that one, we give it the actor dot
character. Like so now we have an image URL.
And it's going to equal and this one is also
going to be that ternary operator that we
use before because we want to display a fallback
image if we don't have that one. So we check
if we have an actor dot profile underscore
path. And then we have a question mark and
we're going to return our nice little URL.
So I have double backticks dollar sign and
I have curly brackets and I grab the image
base URL and then directly after that I have
another dollar sign curly brackets and I grabbed
my poster size. And then I have a third dollar
sign and curly brackets. And I'm gonna grab
actor dot profile underscore path. Be very
careful with the spelling here. It's very
easy to get a typo when you do stuff like
this. Now we have our colon and if we don't
have a profile path, we give it a no image.
And then below here we need to close that
component also do some auto formatting. So
this should be my friend We have hopefully
finished the base of the application. And
then I'm going to teach you some other stuff
that's useful in react. So this should be
it, I hope, save it and go back to the browser,
you can see that we have the accuracy, but
it doesn't look good, because we haven't styled
them yet. But at least it's working. And these
are in white, there, you can see the character
they play in the movie. So we're going to
style them in the next video. And then we
have this nice actors grid. Alright, let's
give those actors some styling. So inside
our code in the actor.styles.js file, we have
two style components. So let's start with
wrapper as usual. I'm going to set the color
from our variables, we have white, I set the
background. And also from our variables, we
have the dark gray, I set the border dash
radius to 20 pixels, padding is going to be
five pixels, and the text align is going to
be Sunder then I'm going to have an age three
tag nested here, I set the Morgan to 10 pixels
000. on that one, and then we have the p tag
is going to have a margin of five pixels and
zero. All right, so that's everything for
the wrapper, then we have the image, just
a few lines of code left, we display it as
a block, the width is going to be 100%. The
height is going to be 200 pixels. And albeit
dash fifth is going to be cover and the border
radius is going to be 15 pixels. And this
should be it, save it go back to the application.
And hopefully you have a nice grid. Yeah,
almost. There's something wrong here with
a background. Yeah, and that's because I have
a typo, it should say border radius, like
that Not radius. Save it go back. And there
you have it. Let's make sure that it works
on all devices. And it does. Sweet, sweet,
sweet. And that concludes the basic stuff
for this application. In the next video, we're
going to talk about prop types and how you
can type check the props that you send in
to your components. I'm going to talk about
something that's called prop types. And prop
types is something you can use on your components
in react to type check the props that you
send into your component. So you have this
special property on your components you create.
That's called prop types. I'm on the official
react page. Now, reg deus.org. And just as
to say here, React has some built in type
checking abilities. I'm going to show you
how to convert this application into TypeScript
later in the chapter. So if you don't use
TypeScript, you should use prop types instead.
That way, you can at least type check your
props that you send in it. So they tell you
here to run type checking on the props for
a component, you can assign a special prop
types property. And I'll give you an example
here. So they import the prop types that's
from the library that we installed earlier
prop types up here. Then they have the component
name, and then assign and then assigned to
this property that's called prop types. So
this one has a lowercase letter to start with.
And this one has an uppercase letter. So this
one is the actual property on the component
itself. And this one is the one that you import
from the library that's called prop types.
So it can be a little bit confusing, but we're
going to practice this in our components.
So hopefully, you'll get a grasp of it quite
quickly, you have this special property on
your component that's called prop types. And
that is an object. And here you can specify
your props. And from the prop types that we
import up here, you have different types you
can check against. So this one will get a
warning if the prop isn't a string that this
component receives. And if we scroll down
here, they show you everything you can do
here. And we are actually just going to do
those simple checks if it's a string, a number
or a Boolean. But you can also check against
an object, for example, you can set all the
properties in an object, and then you use
something that's called shape. And then you
specify your orbit shape inside of that one.
So you can do some more advanced prototype
validation here, instead of just check that
it's an object. You can check all the properties
on the object by using the dot shape. So I
highly suggest that you read this one on rxjs.org.
If you want to know more about prop types.
I think a lot of people now are starting to
use TypeScript with react. And with TypeScript.
We don't have to do this. We have it for free
in TypeScript. So prop types is only If you
don't use TypeScript, and that's why I won't
go into super detail about it either, because
I think TypeScript is actually great to use
in combination with react. But you should
know at least that you can do some deeper
prop type validation by using some of these
syntaxes. Here, you can also check an object
with with warnings on extra properties. And
you can do an exact check here, if you want
to do that. And you can also check if you
send in an array that should have only numbers,
you can check that also. So that you make
sure that the array doesn't contain strings,
for example. Or then you can do the same with
an object here. So there's some really useful
stuff inside of here that you can learn if
you want to get more advanced into prop types.
But we are going to use the most simple use
cases. And we're going to check for strings,
numbers, and Boolean and also for functions,
I think. So in the next video, we're going
to learn about the most simple forms on how
we can use prop types on your components.
Okay, let's start doing some prop type validation.
So we're going to do that with the prop types
library that we installed in the beginning
of this course. So let's begin at the top
here with the actor in the components folder,
and then we're going to move away down and
go through all our components. So in the actor,
make sure that the import prop types, capital
P, capital T, from Prop, dash types, right.
And then just below the component at the bottom
here, just above the export default, we have
our actor component, so we're going to use
the special property that's called prop types
on that one. So actor dot prop types, and
this one is lowercase p, not capital T, as
it is up here. Be very careful here is can
be quite confusing, actually. So prop types,
is going to equal and we have an object. And
then we can specify our different props that
we have here. So we have the name, Prop, and
the name prop. We know that this one is a
string. So from the prop types that we import
that capital P prop types with capital P prop
types, we have something that's called string,
so we're going to check against if it's a
string. All right, then we have the character.
And from prop types with capital P, we're
also going to check if that one is a string,
and we have the third one, image URL, Rob
types, dot string, all of these are going
to be strings. So we say this one, go back
to our application. And we can see here, we're
going to need to be on an individual movie
here. So we have this movie here, nothing
shows up here. But if we go inside, or I'm
just going to close this here. So if we go
inside our move it up JS component, we have
our actor here. And we know that this name,
for example, is a string. So if we change
this one to a number, for example, 10, save
it, go back to our application, you can see
that we instantly get a warning here fail
prop type, invalid prop name of type number
supplied to actor expected string. So this
is a very handy way when you develop your
application to know that you're sending the
correct props to your components. And this
is only available in development mode, it
will not be in production. So it's kind of
a tool when you develop this application to
actually validate your props that you're sending
to your components. So we're going to change
this back now, and hopefully get an idea on
how it works. Now, that was our actor. Then
we have our bread crumb. So just as before
we import prop types, capital P capital T
from prop dash types. And below the component
we have the component name, breadcrumb dot
prop types. With a lowercase p, it's going
to equal an object. And for this one, we have
a prop. That's called movie title. And from
the prop types with a capital P, we're going
to check if it's a string, right. So that's
the bread crumb. Then we have the button.
For that one, we have two props. So we import
prop types, capital P, from prop dash types.
And below the component. We have the bottom
dot prop types. lowercase p equals an object.
We have our text prop that one We're going
to check prop types, capital P here and a
little bit repetitive here that we check if
it's a string. And then we have a coma, and
we have a callback. And from the prop types,
capital P, this one is going to be a function.
So we have that one also on the prop types
object. funk, we can check if it's a function,
save it, go back to our application and check
Yeah, it seems to be right. Let's have baronne.
Then we have our grid, import prop types capital
P from prop dash types, below the component,
grid dot prop types lowercase p, then we have
two props for this one, header, prop types
dot string, we check if it's a string. And
we actually don't need to check the children
because that is a built in Prop, so we don't
need to verify that one. That's the grade
that we have the header and the header don't
have any props, we can skip that one, we have
the hero image. And this one has reom to import
prop types capital P from prop dash types.
Below the component, type in hero image, dot
prop types lowercase p, we have our object.
And we have the image we check against the
prop types with capital P dot string. All
of these are going to be strings. Also, we
have the title, prop types dot string. And
we have the text prop types. dot string, right?
image, title and text. Save the component
we move inside of movie info component. And
for that one, we have one prop import prop
types from prop data types. And below the
component movie, info dot prop types equals
an object. And we call it movie I think, yeah,
movie. And this one is an object. So prop
types dot object. And this is what I talked
about before in the last video. If we go back
here, you can see if you want we can save
this object with dot shape. But I think there's
too many properties in this object. Now to
actually do this. I don't think it's worth
it. So just check if it's an object. But if
you use dot shape, you can shape the complete
object here and check every property on the
object. All right, let's move on we have the
movie info bar. And for that one, we have
three of them. So import prop types from prop
dash types. The loader component, movie infobar
equals an object. And we have the time and
prop types. dot this is going to be a number
so we have the number property check against.
That's the time then we have the budget, prop
types. DOT number is also going to be a number.
We have the revenue, prop types DOT number
all three of them are numbers. movie in forbore
Yeah, of course, I also have to have dot prop
types like this. Right? Just check the application.
Everything seems to be working. Movie info
isn't the fun is it because I typed in Yeah,
this one is auto generated when I typed in
movie info below. Okay, just remove it, save
it. Then we have the search bar. Import prop
types from prop data types. Right below the
component. We have the search bar dot prop
types equal an object. So we have the callback
function. So prop types dot func, we check
if it's a function. Save it. The Spinner will
not have any props for that one. We have the
thumb and we have three of them there. So
import prop types from prop Types below the
component, we have thumb dot prop types, lowercase
p equals an object. And we have the image.
I think image movie ID and clickable image,
prop types capital P, dot string, that's the
URL for the image. So it's a string. Then
we have the movie ID, prop types, DOT number,
the ID is a number, and then clickable. Prop
types, dot, and this is a Boolean. So we have
something that's called bool. And this will
check against a Boolean. Right? Now, it's
actually our last component, I think we don't
have anything in home and movie and not found.
That's the last one. And I saved this for
last, actually, because we built the whole
application. Sure, you should do this from
start when you build a component, I didn't
want to confuse you too much before we have
learned more about react. So that's why I
said it last. But you should have as a habit
to always do this when you create a component
that receives some props. So that's why I
saved it for last. I think that sums it up
about prop types, I'm not going to go all
crazy about prop types. Hopefully you learn
something here to get you started with prop
types. And actually, I don't think in this
application, we don't need to do any deeper
checks here, actually. Okay, in the next section,
we're going to see how we can persist our
state in the session storage. We have almost
finished replication, there are some things
we can do to optimize it. Because now Yeah,
it works. But for example, here, those movies
here, we always reload those movies when we
visit each site here. And also, when we go
back to the start page, we always fetch from
the API. And that's what we're going to talk
about here. Because in your browser, you have
something that's called local storage and
session storage. And we're going to utilize
the session storage to store the data that
we already retrieved. If you open up the panel,
and you have something that called application,
and inside application, you have the storage.
And there you can see the local storage and
the session storage. And these here are all
the movies that are stored from the application.
So you can see it's the movie ID here, and
here we have the data for the movie that's
stored here. Then we also have the homestead.
This is from the other application that is
finished, not ours. I just wanted to keep
them here to show you how it's going to look
when we store this stuff in the session storage,
local storage and session storage are quite
similar. The big difference is that the local
storage persist until you decide to remove
it, the session storage only persist over
a session. So every time you create a new
session, the session storage will get wiped
out. And you may wonder, wouldn't it be better
to have the local storage for application?
Yeah, it would probably, but this page here
is based on all the popular movies. So it
changes a lot. So that means if we store it
in the local storage and never remove it,
we always get the same list of movies here.
And that's no good. So that's why it's better
to store it in the session storage. And also,
each individual movie here. Also sharing just
because we have a rating, that one has zero
rating. Okay. Let's select another one, that
one has 7.6. So the rating will change depending
on the voting. So there is stuff that can
change in each movie also. So that's why I
chose the session storage for both of them.
But if you want, you can use the local storage
instead, the code is going to be the same
except that you swap out session storage for
local storage when we write the code. In the
next video, we're going to learn how to persist
the state in the session storage for the homepage.
Okay, we're going to learn how to persist
the state in the session storage. And we're
going to start by creating a little function
that we can use to read from the session storage.
So go back inside of the code editor, and
in the file, let's call helpers dot j s that's
the one are provided for you in the store
defies we're going to add in a little function
at the bottom here in this file. So we export
the const is persisted, stayed like this equals,
then we have a parameter that's called state
name or name, you can name it whatever you
want, then I have an arrow function. And then
we create a cost that we call session state
equals and from the session storage, session
storage. We have a method that's called get
item. And this is what I talked about before
if you want to use the local storage instead,
you can just change this one to local storage
and it will work you just swap this one out
to local storage. Alright, so we invoke The
method is called get item, we give it the
state name. And this will return the state
from the session storage if there's a state,
otherwise it will return No. So it will get
the item from the session storage with the
name that we provide, there would need to
return something from this function that we
created. So return, and I'm going to do a
short circuit here, I checked, if session
state. If we have something in this one here,
now I have double ampersand and it will return
what's the right of the ampersands. Otherwise,
it will return this one. And this will be
now if it couldn't find this one in the session
storage. Let's say that we have something
in the session state, it will run what's to
the right of the double ampersand so we can
return that state. But we can just return
it as it is because you can only write to
the session storage and to the local storage
as a string. So we have to parse it back from
a string into JSON. So that's also what we're
going to do when we write to the session storage,
we're going to first convert it to string
but now we have to parse it back and forth,
we can do that with JSON capital letters,
parse, and then we give it the session stayed
like this. And this will parse it back to
JSON object and we return it save the file.
And this is it for this little function. So
let's move inside of the use home fetch hook
down below here. Our search an initial use
effect hook. In this one, we can check if
we have a session state before we retrieve
anything from the API. So there are a couple
of things we have to consider here. Because
we want to check the session storage on the
initial render, before we fetch anything from
the API. If we have something in the session
storage, we retrieve that one instead. And
later, we're going to create a hook that also
writes to the session storage. And we're not
going to write to the session storage if we're
in a search. And that means that we also don't
want to retrieve anything if we are in a search.
So that's why we're going to create an if
statement here. Just at the top in this use
effect if and we'll have an exclamation mark,
and search term. So this means if not search
term, then we're going to check the session
storage. So we create a new cost, call it
session stale equals, and then we also have
to import a function that we created in the
helpers file, it's up here at the top with
the market with helpers, and import is persisted
state from dot dot forward slash helpers.
So that's our function that we're going to
use here. To the right of the equal sign,
we call that function is persistent state.
And for our homepage, we're going to create
a state that is called the home state. So
we are hard coding in the string here for
this one, you can make it a little bit more
elegant if you want to do that. But I have
a string here that I call home state. So that's
the property that we're going to write to
the session storage. And this one should actually
be called stayed like this. Then I'm going
to nest in another if statement here. You
could do this in multiple ways. But I think
this one is more readable for this course.
So that's why I have a nested if statement
here also. So if session state, we check if
we have something here, then we're going to
set the state and give it the session state.
And it's also important that we return because
we don't want to do anything else here, because
otherwise it will fetch it from API also.
And this is all that we need to retrieve something
from the session state, we make sure that
we don't check the session storage if we're
in a search. But if we're not in a search,
we check if we have something here. And if
we have something in the session storage,
we set the state with the form that we retrieved
here. And then we return, we return early
from this use effect. Otherwise, it will work
as before here. We set the state first with
the initial state to wipe it out. And then
we fetch the movies from the API. All right,
save it, just make sure that everything works.
And it does. So that's great. I'm also going
to wipe out the old session storage here.
This one is from react dev tools. So when
you delete it, it will create a new one. Right.
But we don't actually have something to retrieve
yet, we also need to write something to the
session storage. So if we go down here below
our load more use effect, we're going to create
another use effect. And I mark it with right
to session storage. And then I have my use
effect like this. This one is going to have
a dependency rate. And it's going to write
to the session storage when the search term
seniors and also when the state changes and
yet Again, I checked if not search term. Because
if we're in a search, we don't want to write
that one to the session storage. And this
is of course, optional. Also, if you want
to, to save the search, you can do that also.
But I don't think that's a great way of doing
it to have your last active search on the
homepage. So that's why. So if not, in a search
term, we can set on the session storage. And
this is the same as before, if you want to
store it in local storage, you change this
one to local storage instead.we have a method
that's called set item, just as we had the
one that's called get item. In this case,
we're going to set it the first argument is
going to be the name that we wanted to have
in the sessions to session storage. And for
this one, I chose the name homestead, just
as the one as I grabbed up here, really important
to have the same name. It's a hard coded string
there, then the second argument is going to
be what we want to write to the state. And
if you remember, I mentioned that we can only
write a string to decision storage and to
the local storage. So we have to stringify
it. And we can do that with JSON, capital
letters, dot stringify. And we give it the
state like this. And even if we didn't specify
these ones first, you can see that it complains
that it wants to search term and the state
now so this is the linting rules for hooks
that is included in create react app. So it's
really great to have that one. All right.
So that's how we write to the session storage,
save the file, go back to the browser. And
you can already see when I say the file it
that it wrote the whole state here for us.
So we have the results here. And we can actually
go back to the code and do some console logging.
So up here in the search and initial inside
the if statement where we grabbed from the
session storage, we can console log, grabbing
from session storage, like this. And down
below here, we can console log grabbing from
API and save the file. And then if we go back
to the console, you can see grabbing from
session storage. And if we reload the page,
it works, it grabs from the session storage
all the time. And then go back to the application
here. And we delete the homestate in the session
storage, go back to the console, reload it.
And now you can see that we grabbed from the
API. So if we load some more movies here,
a few of them. And then we reload the page,
you can see that we have them here, instantly.
And that's because we save it to the session
storage. In the next video, we're going to
persist the state in the session storage for
each individual movie. Okay, one more thing
to do with the session storage. And that is
to store each individual movie in the session
storage. That's what we're going to do back
in the code editor. So we're going to be in
the use movie fetch. And we only have one
use effect in this one. So down at the bottom
of that one, we run that fetch movie function.
And before we do that, we're going to check
if we have something in the session storage
just above that one. Just as before, we create
a const that we call session state equals.
But of course, first we also have to import
that function up here. To mark market with
helpers, an import is persisted state from
dot dot forward slash help us. Yeah, I don't
know why I did like this. Okay, to the right
of the equal sign here, we got to run is persistent
state. And we're going to check for the movie
ID. Because each movie is going to be stored
in the session state with its own ID. So that
will give us null or the actual state. So
if session state, if we have a session state,
we're going to set the state and give you
the session state. And then we're also going
to set the loading to false. This one because
we setting it to true up here, when we start.
That's why we have to set it to false also
Otherwise, it will keep on showing the spinner.
Okay, and then we make an early return, just
as we did before. Otherwise, it will run this
function here that fetches the movies from
the API, right auto format it and save it.
But we're going to create the use effect also
for writing to the session storage. Right
this session storage then we create our use
effect. With an inline IRA function, it's
going to have a dependency array. And it's
going to change on the movie IDs change and
the state change. And these actually won't
change because we're just grabbing data one
time for each movie. But as I told you many
times before, you should specify all the dependencies
for each use effect. If there's something
that won't work, because you specify them
here, you should handle it inside of the use
effect. And that will make sure that you have
less errors in your application. For this
one, we don't need an if statements, we can
write to the session storage dot set item,
and we're going to give it the name of the
movie ID, each movie is going to be stored
in the session story with its own ID, that's
how we separate them out. Then we have a comma
and we give it the state. But just as before,
we have to run JSON stringify. State, because
we can only write the string to the session
storage. All right, save this one and go back
to the application. And here, you can see
that it already saved the movie here. So here's
the movie for that one. So if we check this
one out, I think it's down below here, you
can see that it will instantly grab that movie.
And if we choose not one, here it is zero
rights to decision storage. And next time,
it will instantly grab it because this one
here you can see where the loading spinner
on this once, but next time, we don't have
to reload it. That's how you utilize the session
storage to persist the state in your application.
In the next section, I'm going to show you
how to deploy this application, it's time
to deploy the application. And for this course,
I'm going to show you how to deploy it to
netlify. I think netlify is a great and very
easy way to deploy your react application.
So that's why I'm not sponsored in any way
by netlify. I just like it. And I know that
there's a lot of people that likes it also.
So I think netlify is a good choice for this.
So the first thing you have to do is to create
an account at netlify, it's free. So make
sure that you create an account. And that
will show you kind of a dashboard here, I
have a lot of sites here now. So yours will
be empty if you don't have an account already.
So make sure to create an account at netlify.
We will need it in the next video. So in this
video, I'm going to show you how to create
a production build of the application that
we're going to deploy to netlify. So back
into the terminal and create react app is
really simple to use. It has a built in command
that we can use to build our site. So make
sure that you're inside your application folder.
And then you run NPM, run build like this.
And this will build the application for us.
As it says here, it will create an optimized
production build for us. So that's great.
And it will place it in a folder that's called
build. If we move inside our code editor again,
we can see that we now have this folder that's
called build. And this is a complete site
in here. It's the it's the production build
of our site, we have to do one small thing
here when we're deploying to netlify if we
want our routing to work correctly, because
for example, I can show you here, this is
the site here. If I go to this site and choose
a movie, grab this URL, that's the direct
URL to the movie, and then paste it in here,
you can see that it works now. And that is
because I created that little file that we're
going to do now. Otherwise it won't work,
it will show an error here. And that's because
we using in with react router. So that's why
we have to have that little file. So back
inside of the code editor. And inside a build
folder at the root create a new file, the
name is going to be underscore redirects like
this, it's very important that you name it
exactly like this underscore redirects. And
then inside of that one, we're going to type
in forward slash asterisk, forward slash index
dot HTML, space and 200. And this will make
sure that the routing will work in our application.
So save the file. And now we ready to deploy
it on natla phi. So that's what we're going
to do in the next video. I'm going to show
you two ways in this video how to deploy your
site to nullify, and the first one is going
to be really easy actually. Because if you
log into your account at nullify, and you're
at this dashboard side, down below at the
bottom, you will have this little sewn here
where you can drop your site want to deploy
a new site without connecting to get drag
and drop your site folder here. And this is
really sweet with netlify actually. So if
we grab our folder, that's the folder here
where the complete application is your working
folder with application, you have the folder
inside of that one that's called build. So
make sure that To grab the build folder that
we build in the last video, and just drag
and drop it here, you can see that netlify
starts to build your site. And I actually
didn't have time to finish that sentence before
it's published my site. So you have the link
here, it will create a randomly generated
name, you can change that if you want to do
that, click this link. And you can see that
your application is up and running. So that's
how easy it is to deploy, who would nullify,
that's one way of doing it. Another way is
to use something that's called the netlify
COI. And that's what we're going to do next.
So make sure to be inside of your terminal.
So of course, you're going to be in the folder
where your application is, we've already built
our application, otherwise, you have to build
it. So NPM, run build, and also add in that
little file that I showed you in the last
video for the routing to work in nullify,
then we're going to install the natla phi
COI, I have already installed it, but I can
show you again, of course NPM, install netlify
dash c ally dash D. So that means that I install
it globally. Alright, that installed correctly,
I'm going to clear my console. And then we
can run nullify deployed like this. And then
you're faced with different questions here.
So in this case, we're we're going to create
and configure a new side. So make sure that
you navigate down to that one. And it's waban
Fox team, in this case, you will probably
also just have one team to choose from. So
select that one. And then you can create a
site name, if you want to do that. I won't
do that now. But you can also change it later.
So we'll use the default and just press enter
here. And then it asks for the public directory
down here. And if you remember, the Publish
directory is the build folder. So we type
in dot forward slash build and press Enter.
And there you have it, but the site isn't
actually live yet, because we now have the
opportunity to see if our site works. So you
have a website draft URL, we can click that
one. and here we can try our application to
see that it works before we actually go live
with it. Right, it seems to be working back
to the terminal. And if we read here, we can
add the dash dash prod flag if we want to
go live with it. So we run nullify deploy
dash dash prod and this will make it go live.
Yeah, of course, I shouldn't have space, it
should be dash dash prod like this. And the
public directory is just as before dot forward
slash build. And you are provided with a couple
of URLs here. So this is the unique deploy
URL for this deploy. This isn't actually the
live site. So this is the live site here on
this link, you can click that one and open
it up. But I want to go inside of natla phi
and check that is actually here, you can see
that is here. So you can click this one and
see if it works. And it works. And that's
sweet. So that that is actually also quite
simple to do it in the terminal like this.
So if you change something in your application,
you can deploy it very easily without logging
into netlify from the browser. So you just
type in netlify deploy. And if you know that
it works, you can flag it with prod like this.
And you can do this every time you change
something on your site. Alright, in the next
video, I'm going to show you how to deploy
with continuous deployment. That means when
you change something and push it to GitHub,
I'm going to use GitHub for that one is going
to deploy it automatically. Okay, we're going
to talk about continuous deployment on netlify.
Now, and that means that you can have, for
example, in this case, I have a repository
on GitHub that I'm going to use for this one,
I published my site here to get up and I'm
going to use this one for continuous deployment.
And that means that when I push something
to this repository here, netlify will automatically
build my site and publish it. So that's really,
really neat. Actually, just make sure that
you add to Git ignore file to not upload the
dot m file. And also just one other thing
you have to do, and that is the file that
we created in the build folder, you have to
move that one inside of the public folder
instead, you can see that I have the underscore
redirects in the public folder. And this will
make sure that this one is included when netlify
builds the side. So that's all you have to
do and push it to your repository. I'm using
GitHub, you could use Bitbucket or some other
service if you want to do that. So this is
the complete side. Then I'm going to move
inside of nullified and I'm at my dashboard.
You have something that's called new side
from get I'm choosing Get up because that's
what I'm using. So it's authorized me here.
So you have to log in, then I can search for
my name is RM DB version three. So I select
that repository. And we're going to build
from the master. That's correct. The command
is going to be MPM run build. And we the Publish
director is the build folder. So that is correct.
But we have one more thing to do, because
we have an environmental variable for our
site. So we have to set that one up also Show
Advanced. and here we can create a variable
new variable. So you can set the name here
and the name is going to be react underscore
app underscore API underscore key, just as
the one that we had in our application in
the dot env. file. Alright, there, we need
to give it some value. And here, we can give
it the API key to the Movie Database API.
So I'm obviously not going to show that for
you. So I'm going to paste that one in. And
then I'm going to click Deploy site. So make
sure that you also paste in your key here,
and then click Deploy site. And now we just
wait for it, it's going to build the site.
So it will take a little bit longer now. And
hopefully this will work. And if we want to
see the build log, we can also do that by
clicking here deploying your site, and it
will show us the log. And there you have it,
the site is live, it says here, so we're going
to try that out. Go back to our dashboard.
And here's the side. Click the link, we make
sure that it works. And it does. And that
is great. Just going to make sure also, that
these unique links work if we paste that one
in. Yeah, and it works. Sweet, sweet, sweet.
This is how you publish on netlify. And this
also concludes the main part of this course,
I hope you enjoyed it, there are some bonus
parts. In the next part, I'm going to show
you how to use class components instead of
hooks. And then I'm going to show you how
to convert this application into TypeScript.
And lastly, I'm going to show you how to use
the login and vote system for the Movie Database
API. We're going to reflect our application
into using class components instead of react
hooks. I actually don't use class components
anymore. And I think a lot of people don't
do it. But the chances are that if you get
a job as a react developer, you will work
with a code base that at least has some class
components. So there's a lot of applications
out there that still has class components
in it. And it's actually not even deprecated
from the React libraries. So it's a legit
way of creating components in react. So in
some sense, it's a matter of preference. I
don't think I ever will use them again, actually,
because I love hooks. And I always use functional
components with hooks. But I want to show
you how to do it with class components also.
And there's three components that we have
to refactor because we have three components
with stadium. And that's the search bar to
home and the movie. And we're going to start
with the search bar. So make sure that you're
inside index.js file in the search bar folder.
And there will be a lot of errors and warnings
here when we remove stuff here now, but we'll
fix that as we go along in this video. So
first of all, this one is a functional component,
we want it to be a class component. And then
up here, instead of importing use state use
the fact that you use ref, we can import something
that's called component like this. And instead
of the const here, we delete all of this here.
And we create a class that we call search
bar just as before the same name, and it extends
component. So if we did an important one up
here, we had to specify extend react dot component,
this is a little shortcut you can do here.
So we can remove these ones here. In a class
component, you have one class property, that's
called state. And that is the only state holder
you have. So that's one. So that's one downside
with classes. If you use you state and react
hooks, you can have as many states as you
want to separate them out. Here we only have
one. So we have the class property. That's
called state. And now you can see that I'm
not using the constructor like this. Because
we don't need to do that Babel and Webpack
will make sure that it will be transpiled
down correctly. So we have this class property
here. That's called state and it equals an
object. We're going to have a property that's
called value, and it's an empty string. So
that's the value for our input field in the
search bar. And then we also got to have a
class property that's called timeout. And
we set that one to know right, the use effect
we can use That one anymore. But we can reuse
this logic here for the timer. So I'll remove
these ones for now. And in a class component
in react, you have something that's called
lifecycle methods. And there's three of them
that you should know, that's probably the
most used once you have one that's called
component did mount. And that's the one that's
going to trigger initially in the component.
And then you have another one that's called
component did update, and that's the one that
we're going to use now. And then you have
the last one that's called component will
unmount. And that one is triggered just before
the component will unmount. And in that one,
you can do some cleanups and stuff like that.
But we're going to use to underscore component
did update. And you could do this in several
ways, you don't actually have to use this
lifecycle method to get this to work. But
I want to use it here to show you how this
lifecycle method works. So component did update
like this, this one is going to give us the
previous props and the previous state. So
I make an underscore prep props, we're not
going to use the props, because we don't need
to check against the previous props. So market
with an underscore just to tell that we won't
use that one. And then we have the prep state,
the prep state we will use. Alright, so that's
the component did update lifecycle method.
And this one will trigger on each update on
the component. So what do we want to do here,
now the state here with value is going to
be the text that the user typed in, in the
input field, because this is a control component
to keep it in the state. So we want to check
if this dot State DOT value, it's the value
here. And as this is a class, we have to use
this. So this dot State DOT value, if that
one isn't equal to the prep State DOT value,
we want to do something otherwise, we will
go into an infinity loop here, and that's
no good, we check here, if the value in the
state isn't the same as the previous one,
then we know that we should do something.
All right. And then we have one prop that
sent in to this component, and we can destructure
that one out. So const, it's called set search
term equals this dot props. So we destructure
this one out from the props. Because we send
in this function here, that's going to trigger
when we do a search, then we have a timeout.
It's the one here to copy this one, move it
inside of there. Instead of const timer, we're
going to set this one to this timeout that
we created up here. So this doc timeout, is
going to equal this one here. And the first
thing we also have to do is to clear this
timer, so clear timeout, this stop timeout,
and this is why I have this appears so that
we can access it here and clear it before
we do something else. Alright. And inside
of this timeout here, we're going to grab
our state value. And we can also destructure
that one out. So cost value equals this dot
state. So we grabbed that property from our
state. And instead of the state here, we give
it the value like this. So every time we type
something in, we're going to set the state
and that will update the component, and it
will trigger this one, we cleared the current
timeout and then we set a new one. And at
every 500 milliseconds, we will trigger this
search function just as we did before. Then,
in the class component, we have a render method.
And inside the render method, we can return
this logic here, we can grab this one, turn
it out and paste it inside a render method
like this. And this one, we have to change
this one, this dot state value. And also when
we set the stage this one is incorrect here,
we should specify this dot set state. And
our state will look like this we have an object
like this URL, we have appropriately this
called value. And the value here is going
to be the same. And now you can see we don't
have any errors in this component. And that's
great. If you want you can also destructure
this value out up here just before the return
statement, cost value equals this dot state
like this, and then we can use the value like
this instead. Save the component, go back
to our application, make sure that you're
running the application, then we can try if
it works, and it's working. So it works exactly
as before, we're just using a class instead
now. So this is how we refactor the search
bar to a class component instead. In the next
video, we're going to refactor the homepage.
We refactor the search bar into a class component.
And now we're going to refactor the home component.
So make sure that you're inside the home.js
file. And first, we can remove this hook here,
like this, and up here, we're going to import
the component and the home function, we create
a class called home that extends component
like this. And the use on fetch, we're not
going to use that one, we're going to copy
that logic and use it inside of this component
instead. So we have our state equals an object.
And I'm going to have a property for this
one, that's called movies, that's going to
hold the array with all the movies. And I'm
going to give it the initial state. And this
one, we have that one inside of our hooked,
that's called use home fetch. So copy this
one. And we can paste it in maybe here, he
need she stayed, he need to stayed. Yeah,
it shouldn't be a see my column, because this
is no big. So we have a comma. And then we're
going to have the search term, because now
we have everything in the same state. We can't
separate them out, then we have is loading
more is going to be set to false initially.
And we have loading is also going to be set
to false. And we'll have the error false.
So this is how the structure of a state is
going to be. Yeah, I said I did this one is
going to be an array, but it's going to be
an object. And then we'll have the results,
that's going to be an array that holds all
the movies. So you can structure it however
you want. This is the way I choose to structure
it the movies is the data that we get back
from the API, and the other ones are the ones
that we create ourselves. All right. Then
we're going to make some room here and go
back to the use home fetch hooked. We have
our fetch movies function here, to grab that
function. Everything, copy it, go back to
the home.js file and paste it in here. Below
the state, we have to remove const. That's
movies, it's the same here. Here, we have
to do something else, because we don't have
the state as separate states. Now, to remove
these ones. And this doc set stayed, we have
our object, we set the error to false. And
we set loading to true like this. And here
you can see we only changing the properties
that we want to change, React will merge the
other ones automatically. And this is actually
different from how the state works in a functional
component with use state. With the use state
hook it won't merge the old Stadium, they
also have to make sure that you also provided
one if you want to keep it. But in this case,
we changing the error and the loading here
and other ones will stay the same. So this
is how it works in class components. All right,
we have our movies, this one is going to be
the same. The set state is going to be quite
different now. First, I'm going to spread
out the previous state. And then I gotta have
my movies properties. Because inside of this
movies property that we created up here, we're
going to place everything that's returned
from the Movie Database API. And that's the
stuff that we have here, I'm actually going
to remove the sidebar also. So move this one
up inside of the movies object here. So we
spread out the previous movies and never have
the results. And then we check if the page
is greater than one just as before. But here
we have to change this one because from the
previous state, we also have to go inside
the movies property, like this. So prep dot
movies dot results. The movies dot results
is going to be the same here because this
is the new data that we grabbed from the API,
so we merge that one. This one is also going
to be the same. So this is our set state for
the movies and then below we have a coma and
then we set loading False. And then inside
of the catch, we don't have a set error. So
this set stayed. We set the error to true.
And we also set the loading to false. Like
this, we can remove this set loading here.
This is our fetch movies method. That's called
a method. Now because we're in a class, then
we don't have the use effect here to trigger.
So we're going to have a few functions here,
we're going to have one that's called handle
search. equals, we have the search term, or
create an arrow function for this one. And
when we search for something, we're going
to call this set state parenthesis and we
have our state object movies, we're going
to set the movies to the initial state just
to reset it just as before. And then we also
give the state the search term. And as this
is a sixth syntax, we don't have to specify
it like this, it's enough to just specify
search term when the name is the same. Okay,
so we set this state and when we have set
the search term, and also reset the movies
to the initial state, we want to do something
when that state has updated. And in a react
class on the set state, we have a callback
function that we can use that will trigger
when the new state is set. So we have a coma,
and I create an inline arrow function here
and go on another row here. So then we want
to fetch the movies, this dot, that's movies.
And we give it the one because we're fetching
from page one, this dot stayed. And we give
it a search term, like that. And we can actually
remove those curly brackets, I don't think
we need them. If we don't want to have them,
it's up to you to decide. All right, so that's
the search, then we have the handle handle
load more function. And it's only going to
be an arrow function like this. And I'm going
to type it in on another row, this dot fetch
movies. And from this dot State DOT movies,
we have the page. And we're going to add one
to the page, because now we're grabbing the
next page. And then we give it the start state
the search term. So we also provide a search
term if we're in a search, right? We can actually
auto format it yet, because there's some arrows
down below here. So we're going to create
a random method. And then we're going to move
this one this logic here, inside of the random
method, like this. And then we have a few
things to correct here. So first, I want to
destructure out some stuff from the state.
So up here, as the first line in the render
method, I have a const. I destructuring. out
the search term movies, loading and error
equals this dot state. All right, so that
will fix a few things. Here, we have to change
stayed, because it's going to be from the
movies dot results. And I do that on all three
of these movies. And instead of set search
term on the search bar here for that Prop,
we're going to give it this dot handle search.
And here instead of state, we're also going
to map through the movies dot results. Down
below here, we change state. The movies on
this callback here is going to be this dot
handle load more instead. And now we can auto
format it. And hopefully we won't have an
error. But there's one more thing that we
have to do. Because it won't fetch anything
yet. Yeah, of course, I have to have this
dot set state. And I haven't imported API
either. So go back to the US home fetch. Grab
this one up here, copy and go to the home.
We can paste it in here. And this will get
rid of all the errors, but we're not actually
fetching anything. Now, if we save this one,
go back to the application. You You can see
that it's, it's empty here, because we won't
we don't trigger on the thing, we need to
have a lifecycle method to trigger when this
component mount. And we have a lifecycle method
built in for that. It's called component did
mount. So we call that one and inside, we're
simply going to invoke this dot fetch movies.
And we give it a one, because we want to grab
the first page or format it and save it, go
back to the application. And now you can see
we have our data and our movies here. And
hopefully, everything works as it should.
Yeah, it works. So that's how you do it. And
yet again, the app will look exactly the same
here, we have the same functionality in the
application itself. But we have refactored
the homepage, to use the class component instead.
And as you can see, I think there's a lot
more code here. And I think it's actually
not that easy to separate out things. So that's
why I prefer to use functional component and
the use state hook can use effect instead.
I don't really like this way of doing it anymore,
especially with the state because you have
to nest a lot of stuff here. As you only have
one state, it's much easier when you can separate
them out into different states as you can
with the use state hook. Alright, just one
more thing to do in this section. And that
is to refactor the move a component to use
a class component instead. And that's exactly
what we're going to do in the next video.
We're almost finished with a refactoring into
class components, we only have the movie page
left to do. And we're going to do that right
now. So go back inside of the code editor
and the inside a movie.js file. And for this
one, we're actually going to do a little special
thing here. And that's because we are using
this hook here, use params. That's from react
router, version six. And there's actually
no good way of grabbing the params in a class
component with react router, they have completely
removed that functionality. And they do not
support that for class components. That's
why I'm going to do a little trick down below
here at the bottom, just above where we export
this one here, we're going to create the functional
component for this one const. movie with params,
like this, and then it's gonna take in some
props, we have an arrow function, actually
going to remove the sidebar again. And then
we have our movie component that we have up
here. So this one is going to spread all the
props that this component receives that way,
we can have more props, if we want to do that.
So we just pass them along to the movie component.
Then I'm going to create a prop that's called
params. And inside here, I invoke use params,
like this. And then instead of exporting the
movie itself, I'm going to export movie with
params. So what I'm doing here is creating
a wrapper component that will show the movie
class component and also provide it with the
params for us. So that's the best way I found
of doing this actually, there may be some
other solutions also. But I think this is
actually kind of neat, because you can do
it on one roll like this, before you have
something that's called with router that you
can wrap your component with. But that's actually
not provided in the React router Dom or in
the React router library anymore. So that's
why I have to do it like this. Alright. So
let's reflect to this one, we're going to
remove this hook here. And we can also grab
from the use movie fetch hooked, we can grab
the API import. And I'm going to paste that
in the movie up here somewhere, maybe there.
And we're not going to use that hook anymore.
And of course, we have to rename this one
also. And up here, we're going to import component
just as before, and we rename this one we
create a class class movie extends component.
This one, we can remove that one also. And
we can actually create a render method right
now and move this logic inside of
that one. Something like this. All right,
now we have some serious refactoring to do
here. So first, we're going to create our
state. Whoever class property state it's an
object movie. I'm going to set that one to
an empty object to start with. Then we'll
set Loading to true and error to false, like
this. All right, that is the modal formatting
there also, then from the use movie fetch
hook, I'm going to copy this fetch movie function
like this. For this one, I'm not going to
implement the session storage. So I'm just
copying this one here. And I didn't do that
in the home component either. Right pasted
in here in the mover component, we remove
the const from fetch movie. Let's just before
we have to refactor this one, this one becomes
this set stayed parenthesis and we have our
object error is going to be false. And loading
is going to be true like this. And then we
can also destructure out or or Prop, because
we're sending that in with that special little
component that are created down here. So now
we have access to a prop, that's called params.
So destructor that one out, because we're
going to need the movie Id like this equals
this dot props, dot params. And that will
grab that one for us. All right, these ones
are going to be the same. This one also set
state we have to change this one, this one
also this dot set state, and the state is
going to be movie, we have that property,
it's an object. So we move these ones up inside
of that object. And then we have a coma. And
we set the loading property to false like
that. That should be if we're not one, we're
going to remove the set loading. And here,
change the set error to this dot set state.
parenthesis and object error. True and loading
the false. All right. And I think that's it
for that function. And then we're going to
have a lifecycle method also, for this one,
the component did mount we're going to do
something when the component mount, and the
only thing we're going to do is to invoke
this dot fetch movie. And then down below
in the render function. We can destructure
out from our state const. We have our movie.
We have the loading, we have the error. And
that's it. Then we grab them from this stuff
stayed. And hopefully, it will work here now.
Yeah, I think that's fine. There's a more
formatting. And let's see if it works. We
save the file, go back to the application.
is grabbing from the session storage? No,
I think. Yeah, it works. So that's sweet.
We have successfully refactored this application
into something that what I think is a worse
application because we use in classes. Now,
I wouldn't do it like this, I would keep the
functional components and the state with hooks,
and the use effect and the use state stuff
that we use in the application. But it's up
to you to decide that. But hopefully this
gave you an idea on how class components works
in react, and to keep state in class components.
And the lifecycle methods. There's more lifecycle
methods, but I won't go into them here because
I'm not using them in this application. So
that's why all right, in the next bonus section,
I'm going to talk about TypeScript. And we're
going to refactor our application into TypeScript.
Welcome to this bonus section, where we're
going to reflect your application into using
TypeScript. And TypeScript itself is quite
a large topic. So we will only scratched the
surface actually. But hopefully, that's going
to be enough to give you a basic understanding
of how TypeScript work and especially with
react. So TypeScript is an extension of JavaScript.
And it adds types to JavaScript. So that's
great, because JavaScript is actually quite
a loose language where you can do whatever
you want, and it still works. So it can be
a little bit messy if you're in a large application.
So TypeScript will transpile down to JavaScript
in there. And so that's why, as they say here,
all valid JavaScript code is also TypeScript
code. So you can decide how much you want
to type stuff and how strict you want to be
with TypeScript. And TypeScript is gaining
a lot more ground. And it's almost a standard
today, when you create something from scratch.
A lot of applications, of course, don't use
TypeScript, as they are And there's a lot
of code base out there that hasn't been refactored.
And you probably shouldn't do it for all of
the applications either. But TypeScript is
great if you have quite a large application,
and you want to keep track on types. And it's
really great also, because it's kind of like
to have a second coder beside you, that tells
you what you do wrong. Meanwhile, your code.
So it's a great way to write a lot more error,
less code. I think that's one of the great
things with TypeScript because you have a
really powerful IntelliSense with TypeScript,
and it will tell you if you do something wrong.
All right, that was a really short introduction
to TypeScript. In the next video, we're going
to set up a project and start refactoring
our application into using TypeScript. Alright,
let's start refactoring our application into
using TypeScript. And I'm actually going to
create a complete new application with create
react app. And that's because you can also
create an application with TypeScript support,
and it gives you some defaults and setup that
we can use. So we don't have to do that ourselves.
If we look here, with create react app, we
can flag it with template and TypeScript.
And that will create our application with
TypeScript support. So that's what we're going
to do first. So make sure that you're inside
a folder where you can create a new project,
and then go inside a terminal. And that's
going to show you this also. And then we type
in MP x, create dash react dash app. And then
we name our application, React dash or IMDb
dash, Ts. And I think you also must have only
lowercase letters in the naming. Then we flag
it with template type scripts, like this.
And we press enter, and we wait for it. Alright,
that's the bootstrapping of the application
itself. So let's navigate inside of that folder,
CD, React dash or IMDb dash Ts. And you can
see that we have some different files here.
So that's great. Well, one more thing that
we need to do before we can start coding,
and that is to install our dependencies in
this TypeScript application, also, to have
the style components. And we also have the
React router. So let's start with the style
components, MPM, I style dash components.
And as this is a TypeScript project, we also
need the types for style components. And if
a library won't provide you with types, by
default, you can usually find the types in
AD types forward slash, and then you can type
in the name of the library that you're installing.
So in this case, it's going to be ad types,
forward slash styled dash components. And
we'll press enter. Alright, so that installed
correctly. And then we also need to install
the React router, the next version, the version
six and the types for that one. So MPM I,
if you remember, we also install a library
that's called history, that one is used for
react router, history, space, and then we
have the React dash router dash dome at next,
just as before we grab in your next version,
and that is the version six, then we have
a space. And we're going to grab the types
for this one also. So add types, or a slash,
React dash router, dash dome, and we press
enter. Alright, so that's the dependencies
we need for this product. But there's one
more thing we have to do, because now we have
bootstrap this new TypeScript application.
But we want our old files inside of that one.
So if we look here, here's the file for this
project. I'm also showing the hidden files
here. So we have the Git and Git ignore. So
now inside of this src folder, here, we have
all the TypeScript files. But we want our
files instead. And therefore, we can actually
remove some of those files here, we don't
need to set up tests, we don't need a service
worker, we don't need a logo index CSS app,
we can still keep the index actually, because
that one is already set up for us. The other
ones we can delete. So just keep the index
TSX and the React app and the.ts. And remove
the files. Like this. And then from our finished
application, I'm using the hooked version
now. So not the class based one, use the hook
based one. And we're going to grab from the
src folder, the API app components, config,
global style helpers, hooks, images, everything
except the index.js file, copy these ones,
and go inside the src folder of the newly
bootstrapped TypeScript project and paste
them in. And the application won't work now
because we have to do a lot of stuff here
to get it to work, but that's fine. There's
one more thing we have to do also analysis
to copy your dot m file
like this or if it says that you can't copy
it because it's hidden, you can create a new
dot m file and set up your environmental variable
for the Movie Database API there again, so
just copy. So just copy that code from your
other m file and create a new one and paste
it in. Because it's really important, because
we need that one to be able to fetch data
from the Movie Database API, we have copied
all the files that we need for our TypeScript
project. And that means that we can close
the other project and we're going to be in
the new project from here on. In the next
video, we're going to convert this base files
here, the API, app config, global style helpers,
and stuff like that into TypeScript. And then
we'll move on with the components and the
home and the movie page. Okay, before we do
anything, I have to correct the mistake I
did in the last video. And that is the dot
m file, it shouldn't be in the src folder,
it should be in the root folder. So move this
one out to the root folder of your project.
And make sure that it's outside the src folder,
otherwise it won't work, we can go inside
of our terminal and try to start a project
up, we will get an error or probably a lot
of them. As you can see, because we haven't
actually converted anything into TypeScript
yet. So that's why. So first in the index
dot TSX file, we have to do some cleanup,
we're going to remove the index dot CSS, we're
going to remove the ServiceWorker like this,
and save the file. And then we have something
that's called react dash app, dash m.ts. And
this is the references for the types for react
scripts. So we'll leave this alone. And also
we have something here that you can see that's
called Ts config dot JSON. And this is the
the config you can set up for TypeScript.
So this is why I wanted to bootstrap the application
with create react app, because they already
set this one up for us. So they have a lot
of great defaults here, that set up for us.
And if there's something special you want
to configure for TypeScript, you can do it
in this file. So you can add them here, it's
actually a lot you can do to set it up just
as you like it. But we're not going to do
that we're going to use the defaults that
create react app provides for us. So we cleaned
up the index dot TSX file. And we're going
to refactor all of the other files here in
this video. So we can start with the api.js
file, we have to rename it, we're actually
going to rename all of these files. Because
they they should be called.ts. So that it
indicates that it's a TypeScript file, so
we renamed them to.ts. Instead, all of these
files is going to be.ts. The app is actually
going to be dot TSX. And that's because we
using JSX, inside of that one, otherwise,
it won't work. So every time you use JSX,
make sure that you have the file extension
dot TSX. Otherwise, type TypeScript will fail.
Alright. So that's the renaming of the files.
And then we can start in the api.ts file.
And for this one, we're actually going to
create some types because we returning data
from the API, and we need to type that data.
But first, we can start to actually type the
functions themself. So here, you can see that
it complains, no parameter search term implicitly
has an any type. And that's because we haven't
set any type. This one, if we want to specify
a type on this parameter, we use a colon.
And then we specify it as a string. And you
can see that it stops complaining now. And
that's great. And the page, this one is actually
going to be a number. So we specify it as
a number. So that's how you specify parameters,
you have a lot of types you can specify for
them. And then if you want to specify the
return type on the function, you can see that
TypeScript actually won't complain out because
the default setup don't force us to specify
a return type. But I want to show you how
we can do that. And in this case, it's a promise
that we return because we're fetching from
the API and we get back a promise. So if we
want to type the return type to be a promise,
we have a colon here. And then we specify
it as a promise. But the promise needs something
else you can see here represents the completion
of another, blah, blah, blah, generic type
promise requires one type argument. And when
you send in a type argument type like this,
you do it inside of angle brackets, and we're
going to specify that this is going to be
the type of a new type that we're going to
create. That's called movies. We haven't created
this one yet. So of course, it complains.
So we're going to do that in a second. We're
only going to specify this const here also,
the endpoint that we create here. We have
a colon and then I type it as a string. So
that's how we typed this function. And now
we're going to create a type. That's called
movies. And the actual data that we get back
from the API is, it has a lot of properties.
So I'm only going to type the properties that
I'm actually using inside of the application.
So we can mark it with types here. And then
I got to export this type, because I'm going
to use it in another file. So that's great.
You can also export the types, you don't have
to specify them all over the place, you can
specify them in one file, and you can export
them and import them wherever you need them.
So export type movies like this. And from
the API, we get the page. And that one is
going to be a number, you could also create
something that's called an interface. And
then you do it like this. They are almost
the same today, in the new versions of TypeScript
before there was some major differences. Actually,
the recommendation is to use type in a react
application. So we're going to do that. So
export type movies and then equals and the
object, then we have the results. And the
results is actually going to be all the movies,
we're going to specify another type, that's
called a movie, that's a singular movie. And
this one is going to be an array. So it's
going to be an array of the movie type. So
this is how we specified our array. So if
you had an array, for example, with only numbers,
you can specify it like this. But we are going
to create another type object, that's called
movie. And we're going to do that in a second.
But first, we're also going to type the total
pages, it's going to be number. And then we
have the total results, that one is also going
to be a number. Do some more formatting. And
you can see in the type of bacteria that it
uses see my colon and not coma as in a regular
JavaScript object. I actually think it will
work with coma also. But the formatting is
set up, so that it uses see my column, but
you can see that it, it seems to be working.
But when I want to format it, yeah, it will
return to the semi colons. Okay. All right.
So we need to specify each specific movie
here. So we create another type that I export,
export type movie equals an object. And here
we have a few more of the different properties.
So we have the backdrop underscore path is
going to be a string, the ID is going to be
a number, the original underscore title is
going to be a string, the over view is going
to be a string, it's easy to have a typo here.
So be careful. popularity is going to be a
number, poster underscore path is going to
be a string, the title is going to be a string,
the vote underscore average is going to be
a number. And the vote underscore count is
going to be a number, the budget is also going
to be a number. And then we have the run time,
it's the number also and and the last one
is the revenue. And it's also going to be
a number. So that's the type of object for
a singular movie. And now you can see that
it won't complain here, because we using that
one and telling the results is an array of
the type movie. So each element in the array
is going to be an object of this type. So
that's how we specified it now. All right,
and you can see that it won't complain here
now, because we using this type here, the
movies, so that's fine. Then we move on to
the fetch movie, the singular fetch. For each
movie, we have this parameter here. So we
have to use parentheses. When we type this,
the movie ID is going to be a number. And
the return type is going to be a promise again.
And this time, it's the movie, we already
created this one because it's a single movie.
So we have this object here. So that's great.
And we can also specify the endpoint, you
can see that it won't complain because the
default setup won't force us to specify everything.
But it's always a great ID to specify what
type you return in the context. All right.
So that's the fetch movie. And you can see
also bonus material for login. We're not going
to type this one. So I'm going to stop here
for the basic fetch functions here. So fetch
credits We have the movie ID, that one is
going to be a number, like so. And it will
also return a promise that we create a type
that called credits. But before we do that,
we can also specify the credits endpoint as
a string. All right, then we go up here, again,
just below the type movies, we're going to
export the type that's called credits, it's
always a great idea to export the types because
you never know when you need them. That way,
you make sure that you can access them from
anywhere in your application, the ID is going
to be a number, the cast, we're actually going
to create a new cast object for that one.
So it's going to be an array with an object
that we specify as a cast. And we're going
to do that in a second, we have the crew,
and it's also going to be a new type object.
So an array of crew like this. So up here,
we export the type to cast equals, we have
the character is going to be a string, the
credit underscore ID is going to be a string,
the name is going to be a string. And a profile
underscore path is also going to be a string.
If you want to type these in one row, instead
of typing them out, when all of them going
to be a string, you can do it like this. You
have a square bracket, and then you have the
property, the property is going to be a string.
And then the type is going to be a string
like this. And this will also work. But I
think it's better to be more explicit and
type all of them like this, then we have the
crew. So export type, crew equals object job
is going to be a string name is also going
to be a string, and the credit underscore
ID is going to be a number or to format it
and save it. And hopefully this will work,
you can see that it will, it will give us
some arrows here now because I won't type
this one here. Or is it only Yeah, I can actually
just type this one. So we don't have an error,
the request token is going to be a string.
The username is also going to be a string.
And the password is also going to be a string
some more formatting, and then we have them
on the wrong row. So that will get rid of
the arrows. But we won't focus on these below
the bonus material, all of these ones here.
So that's what we're doing. Alright, save
the file. So that's the api.ts, then we'll
have our app dot TSX file. You can see here
now that it complains, because we don't have
the types for this one. And that's because
we're using the next version. So in this case,
I'm just gonna ignore it, because I know it
will work. So when you ignore something with
TypeScript, you can do that by command and
n at Ts dash ignore. And that will get rid
of that error. So we have to do this for now,
before it is officially released, then they
will provide the types for it. And then we
don't have to do it like this. And the only
thing we have to do more is to specify our
react component. So this is a functional component.
And if we do a colon, and react.fc, we have
that built into react. So we have that type
for a functional component. So this is everything
we have to do to specify this as a react functional
component. Alright, save the file. Then we
have the config.ts file. And the only thing
we have to do here, if we want is to specify
those strings, because all of them is strings.
This one can be undefined also. So yeah, well,
we can do it, API URL colon string, this one
colon string. And if it can have more than
one value, we can have this pipe. And we specify
it as undefined also, because you can see
if I remove this one here, it complains because
it tells us that type string, undefined is
not assignable to type string, because we
saying that it can only be a string, but it
can actually also be undefined. So TypeScript
tells us that Yeah, you're doing something
wrong here. So this one could also be undefined,
so you should do something about it. So that's
what we're doing here. Pipe undefined, like
this, and it will be happy and all of the
other ones will be strings here. So I'm just
going to do it quite fast. string, string
string Spring lists one here, a string and
this string and the last one a string. Right,
save the file. That's the config. And then
we have the global style, we don't need to
do anything inside of here, this is a start
component. So it's fine like it is now, the
helpers.ts here, we're going to start this
ones up also. So here we have this time puram.
So we create parenthesis. And this one is
going to be a number. But the return type
of the function itself is going to be a string.
So we type it like this, and ours is going
to be a number. And the means is also going
to be a number. So that's it for that function,
then we have to convert money, parenthesis,
it's going to be a number, and it's also going
to return a string. And this one is a special
one. So you can see that this format here.
The type is actually this one here into into
DOT number format, international number format.
So copy this one. And we can actually specify
this as a type also for it. Like so. Then
the last one inside of this file, is the state
name. This one is going to be a string. Jason,
of course, has an Annie type as a return type,
we can specify Annie, it shouldn't actually
complain here. Yeah, and that's because this
is named the wrong way. Here it should be
session state. So that's why. So JSON dot
parse, has an any type. So that's why we have
to specify it as Annie, you should avoid specify
anything as Annie, because you remove all
the type checking here when you specify it
as any, because you're saying that it can
be of any type. So always make it a habit
to not use any if you can do only use it in
specific case like this one, because this
one will return. And that's why we have to
specify it as an ID. And that's it for these
files. Here, we can start up our application
to see that it works NPM start. And it seems
to be working. So that's sweet. In the next
video, we're going to refactor the homepage
to use TypeScript and also the components
that we use on the home page itself. Alright,
let's continue to refactor the application
into TypeScript and move inside of the component
home dot j s, we're going to rename this file
to Ts. And also I can tell you that if we
look here in the terminal, I don't run my
dev environment, because when you change the
file names, it will break. So you'll have
to restore it again. So that's why I'm going
to start it up later. But if some stuff don't
work, because I've changed some file name,
or things like that, try to break it and start
up your dev environment again. rights are
renamed the home Ts like this. And then inside
of that file, the only thing we have to do
here is to specify this as a react dot functional
component react.fc. And you can see there
actually made a mistake here, this one shouldn't
be Ts, then it won't work because we have
gay sex here. So this one should be dot TSX.
So change that one to home dot TSX. And then
it will work hopefully, here we have some
stuff that it complains about. And that is
because we haven't typed anything yet in our
hooks that fetches that data. So if we move
inside of the hooks, and use home fetch, first
we rename this file to.ts. Here, we're not
using any Deus Ex, so we can name it to.ts.
Okay, the first thing we have to do here is
to import the type movie. And we do this inside
of curly brackets, because this is not the
default export. And then it complains here
on the page, this one is going to be a number
and a search term, it actually interprets
this one as a string, because we set it as
a default string here. So we don't have to
specify anything more here. But it complains
about the state. And that is because if we
hover over this use state, you can see that
results is set to never it doesn't know what
type this will be. That's why we can specify
it as movie and an array. So we're telling
it that we're setting this to an empty array,
but it should interpret it as a movie array.
So that's why we imported it up here. And
that's why we also get the types on the state
correctly here. So in the home, you can see
that the warnings has disappeared because
now it knows all these types because it interpreted
from this hook here as we telling it that
this state is Gonna be of this type. And then
it follows along inside of this file, that's
super great. Say the home also, then we're
going to refactor the components that we're
using for the home component. So we have the
bottom. So in the index.js file, that one
is going to be renamed to index dot TSX. And
the style file is going to be renamed to.ts.
Because we're not using any JSX inside of
that one. And for a style file, we don't need
to do anything there. But in the index dot
TSX file, we have to do some stuff, because
now we have some props here. And we're also
going to remove prop types. We don't need
that one when we're in TypeScript. So remove
everything that has to do with the prop types,
then here are going to specify types. And
I created a type that are called props. You
can call it whatever you want, it doesn't
need to be called props. So we have the text
prop here, text, that's going to be a string.
And then we have the callback, then I'm going
to type this very loosely, it's going to be
a function that returns nothing. So when we
specify to void because void means that it
won't return anything. So this is a click
callback. All right, but it still complains,
we have created a prop object. So we have
to specify the button as a react dot functional
component react.fc. And if we want to specify
our props, we can do that inside of angle
brackets. And then we use our props object.
And then you can see that it works. It knows
the types now of these props, you can see
if we hover over them, you can see the types.
Right, so that's it for the bottom. Now we
have the grid, the grid styles, we're going
to rename that one to grid styles.ts. And
the index is going to be renamed to dot TSX.
Yet again, for the stars, we don't have to
do anything here because we're not sending
in any props to the style components. In the
index dot TSX file, we have to do some stuff,
though. So we remove the prop types. And also
make sure to remove them at the bottom here,
like this. Then I specified types. And I create
a type props an object and we have the header.
We set up one as a string, the children, we
don't need to type that one because that's
built in to react. So we specify the grid
to react.fc. We have angle brackets, and we
give it the props object. This is it for a
grid. Move on to the header header dots header
styles is going to be.ts like this, and the
index is going to be dot TSX. Nothing to do
in the stars file. But in the index dot TSX.
We can do some stuff. We only have to specify
this as a react.fc. That's everything for
the header. All right, then we have the hero
image here we image dot Stiles is going to
be renamed to.ts. And this index.js is going
to be renamed to dot TSX. Instead, in this
star component, we actually have to do something
because we have this prop here and we haven't
thought that one up here. I mark it as types.
I create a type props equals, we have the
image and this is going to be the URL so it's
a string. And when you type a style component,
you do it here just after the components you
choose to create. We have the angle brackets
again, and we send in the props like this.
There you have it, that's the styles. Then
we have the index dot TSX remove the prop
types. Just as before we specify our types,
type props equals an object image is going
to be a string title is going to be a string
and the text is also going to be a string
we specify it as a react.fc. We have the angle
brackets and send in the props. And this should
be it for this component save it move on.
Moving for moving football These are for the
movie page we have the search for the index.js
is going to be renamed to index dot TSX. The
search for styles is going to be.ts we don't
have to do anything In this style file, but
in the index dot TSX, we remove the prop types.
everything that has to do with prop types.
Then we have the types. I create a type props
equals an object. And then we have the set
search term and this one is going to be a
callback. And how do we type this one? Well,
this has implicitly an Annie type. But if
we go back to the home, and see where we have
the search bar, you can see here, and here,
we actually get that type. So when you hover
over stuff, we get the type. And that's really
good, because we can actually just copy this
one, copy and move back to the index dot TSX
file in the search bar. And then we paste
it in here. So this is the React dot dispatch.
And inside here where the React dot set state
actions, so this is the type for the setter
for the use state. And it's a string in this
case, if it was a Boolean, it would have said
Boolean here instead of something. First,
we have a react dot dispatch. And we specify
the type that is, is that it is a state action.
And we specify that one that it's a string
that we're going to set this state with. So
the search bar is going to be a react.fc component,
we have the angle brackets, and we give it
the props. And that's it for the search bar,
move on to the spinner, spinner Stiles is
going to be renamed.ts. And the index is going
to be renamed to dot TSX. The Spinner we don't
have any props for that one. And this one
is actually nothing to do because it just
exports the star component. And the last one
is going to be the thumb. So we renamed the
index to dot TSX. And the thumb styles is
going to be.ts. So nothing to do with the
styles but in the index dot TSX remove the
prop types like this. And then we specify
types, type props, equals, the image is going
to be a string because it's the URL to the
image, then we have the movie ID, that one
is going to be a number and the clickable
is going to be a Boolean. And then specify
this as react.fc. And we give it the props.
And this should be it save the component.
And I think we should be able to start up
our application. So we run NPM start. Let's
see if we have any errors. It actually seems
to be working. Alright, that's great. I didn't
have any typos or stuff like that. That always
makes me happy when it works the first time.
Okay, so that's the home component. In the
next video, we're going to convert the movie
page and all the components for that page
into TypeScript. So we're going to refactor
to move a component and also actually the
not found component. So we're going to start
with a not found this one is a small component,
so we just specify this as a react of FC.
And that will be that one. And we also have
to rename it to dot TSX. And save the file.
And now if we look in the console, you can
see that it gives an error, that's because
we renamed that one. And that's what I meant
before break it, and you have to restore it,
otherwise, it won't work usually. Okay, so
let's move inside of the movie.js file, rename
it to move it off TSX. And then we're going
to refactor some stuff here. So we specify
it as react.fc. We don't have any props for
this one. And you can see that it complains
now because it can't interpret the types here.
So we're going to fix that in the hook. So
go inside the hooks and use movie fetch, we
renamed this one to.ts. And we also need to
import some stuff here, we need the movie
type object, we need a cast and crew. That's
the one that we created all errors, we import
a mural. So now I'm going to specify some
types. Export type, movie state, and the movie
state is going to be the movie. But as I'm
also creating these properties, myself, the
actors and the directors, I have to add these
ones, so we can actually merge them together
to one type. So we use the ampersand and then
we have the object The actors is going to
be an array of cast, this and the directors
is going to be an array of crew. And that
will create a type object with the movie.
And then we merge in the actress and type
domestic an array of cast. And then we have
the directors and we type them as an array
of crew. Right? The movie ID, it complains,
here, we have to specify the types. It was
specified as a number. And the use state here,
it doesn't know what state is this actually.
So we're going to specify the state, we have
the angle brackets, and then we can give it
the movie state. And then it will know that
this state will have this type. But it complains
now, and that is because we're setting it
to an empty object. And it doesn't like that,
because we say that it can only be a movie
state. So we could do it like this, if we
want to tell it that it can also be an empty
object. Or we can do as we did before, we
say as movie stayed, like so. And it won't
complain anymore. So that's everything we
have to do, I think the movie ID okay. Yeah,
we also have to make this a string because
this persistent state function is taking in
a string. And this is actually a number enough.
So you can see how great it is with TypeScript,
because it's telling us when we're doing something
wrong, so we convert this one to a string
with a built in function like this. And then
I bet it's the same here yeah.to string, like
so. And this will hopefully be it. Back inside
a movie dot TSX file. Yeah, and this is because
we get a string back from the API. And now
it wants a number. So we can convert this
to a number. And there are smoother ways of
doing this. So you don't have to convert it
like this. But I think it's a great practice
in TypeScript. So that's why I did it this
way. So we can convert it because TypeScript
will complain if we send in the wrong type.
But of course, we could be more consistent
and refactor some stuff in the use movie set
and also in the API file, to specify the correct
type from the beginning. With course in the
API here, you can see that the movie ID is
a number, we could specify this as a string,
instead, we can actually do that. So we make
this a string. Or we specify this as a number,
this one should be a string. And we save it
go back to the movie. And now it should work.
Yeah. So that's probably the way to do it
instead. So you don't have to do all this
converting. And now we have to refactor the
components that we use for the movie page
also. So let's begin with actors, right, the
dot styles is going to be active.stars.ts.
And index is going to be dot TSX. We don't
have any props in the styles. So we're only
going to be in the index dot TSX. Remove the
prop types just as before. And then we have
the types. types, I created type props equals
an object, we have the name is going to be
a string, the character is going to be a string,
the image URL is going to be a string also,
we specify this so react.fc. And I give it
to props. Just as before, save the file, then
we're going to be in the breadcrumbs. So rename
this one also.ts. And the index is going to
be dot TSX. Same goes with the stars. We don't
have to do anything but in the index dot TSX.
Remove the prop types. A lot of repetitive
stuff here, but that's great when you learn
things. As I told you before, I specified
a types type of props equals an object. We
have the movie, that's the URL, so it's a
string. And then this one is going to be a
rec.fc and where the angle brackets and give
it to props. Yeah, I actually named it movie
title. That's what it should say. Right, that's
the breadcrumb. Then we have the movie info
renamed the index.js to index dot TSX and
the movie info tiles is going to be renamed
to.ts. And the story in the stars because
this one was sending in some props to up here,
a market with types created type props, equals,
we have the backdrop, and is going to be a
string. Just as before, we have the angle
brackets here on the component that we crave,
and we send in the props. Don't know why it's
still red. Yeah, that's because this one should
be named animated movie info like this. So
yet again, you see TypeScript is great, because
it will warn us, if we don't do stuff the
right way, it will warn us save it. Because
I didn't see this actually, when I created
it before in the course, I forgot to name
this one. And I didn't see a warning. But
now TypeScript warns me about this, save the
file, and go inside the index dot TSX file
like this, we remove the prop types. And we're
going to have some types for this one. For
this one, I'm going to import the movie state
from dot dot forward slash dot dot forward
slash hooks, and use movie fetch. Like so.
And then I also going to specify a type props
equal an object, and we have the movie, and
the movie is going to be the movie state type.
So you can see here I import the types, I
don't have to specify them again. I mean,
if you really love structure, you can create
specific files for your types and have them
inside of those files. All right, movie info,
it's going to be a react.fc are going to give
it to props, like so. Alright, then it complains
here, this one shouldn't be here. And compliance.
Again, I did a mistake here. And you see TypeScript
is great. It tells me that this mistake Yeah.
And that's because I'm not providing a movie
ID for this one, because we shouldn't be able
to click it. So go back inside of the thumb.
And this one, movie ID should be set to optional,
you can set an optional prop with a question
mark like this, save the file, go back. And
you can see that the warning disappeared from
the movie info. Alright, save that file. And
we'll have one more component to go. That's
the movie info bar, rename this to dot TSX.
And the styles.ts, we don't have to do anything
with the styles. And inside the index, we
remove the prop types like this. And then
we specify the types. So I have a type props.
An obit time is going to be a number, the
budget is also going to be a number and the
revenue is going to be a number. And then
we specify this as the rec FC, we have the
angle brackets and give it to props, we auto
format it. And it should hopefully work, save
the file. And this my friend should be it
actually we have successfully, hopefully,
refactor this one into TypeScript. So let's
make sure that it works. Go inside the terminal
and run NPM start. And it works. super great.
There you have it, you have a TypeScript application
now. And everything works as it should. No
arrows anywhere. Sweet. There is the TypeScript
part. And in the next part, I'm going to show
you some extra stuff that the Movie Database
can do. And that is a neat little login system.
And then you can vote on the movies. We've
reached the last section of this course. So
first, congrats to you because we've come
a long way in this course. And I hope you've
learned something about react. In this part
of the course, I'm going to show you how to
create a login for the Movie Database API
from our application, and you will be able
to vote on the different movies. So first,
I just want to show you on developers dot
the movie db.org what we're going to use to
make the login work. So down here where it
says movies, I clicked on this one, you can
see the complete API for the movies. And they
have one here, that's a post that's called
rate movies. So this is the one that I clicked
on here. And by posting to this URL here,
we can rate the movies and we have to provide
our API key and we Also to provide a session
ID. So that's where we do the login. And the
login is, I think, somewhere. People search,
where do they have a authentication, they
have a lot of stuff here. And first you have
to create a request token. And then we create
a session. So we get a session IDs. So there's
two steps you have to do to be able to log
in. And they also recommend you to actually
reroute to the Movie Database for making the
login. But it also provided with a solution
here that we don't actually recommend where
you can log in from your own site without
leaving that application or the site. So that's
the one I'm going to use here. And the reason
for this bonus chapter in the course is actually
that I want to show you how to create a global
context and store the user the logged in user
in that global context. That's the main part
that I want to show you. And also, I got a
lot of requests to show how to make a login
form and be able to vote on the movies. There
is one thing though, that's not going to work
with this solution. Because it's not a fully
solution. Really, in this case, you have to
use your login from the movie database to
be able to log in. So we won't be able to
create a new users and stuff like that. And
the best thing would probably be to build
your own API, your own back end somehow to
have your users log in there and save data
so that you can save all the stuff about the
user. So there's a lot of different approaches.
And this is absolutely not a fully login system
and voting system. I just want to show you
some small tips and tricks here to get you
started if you want to create your own fully
functional logging system, and stuff like
that, Okay, so let's get to it. I'm just going
to show you the code shortly here, before
we move on in the api.js file. I have created
these functions for us here down below this
comment to your bonus material below for login,
I have a function that called GET request
token so that that will obviously get the
request token from the API. And then I have
this one that's called authenticate. And I
did some comments here also. So first, we
have to authenticate the request token that
we get from this one. And then we have to
get the session ID with a request token. So
there's actually three steps and not to order
them because we have to get the request token
first. And then we authenticate that request
token. And then we get the session ID and
then we are logged in. And then I have this
function down below here. That's called rate
movie. And this one will send a rating score
to the Movie Database API, and hopefully return
an object that says that we were successful.
So that's what we're going to be using in
this part of the tutorial. So let's get started.
In the next video, we're going to create a
global context and a global state that we
can use to store the user in. Alright, let's
start by creating a context for our application.
And we are touching on China have advanced
stuff now in react. So don't feel bad if you
don't understand all of this stuff the first
time. All right inside the src folder, we're
going to create a new file that we call context,
dot j s. all lowercase letters seem to be
in the root of the SRC, not in the components
or anything like that, in the root of this
are See, I can close this one here. So we
have the context.js file, and inside of that
one, we're going to import react, comma and
the use state that we imported from react,
then I'm going to create something that's
called a context in react. And when we create
a context, we are creating something that
will make it possible for us to provide our
application with something in this context
that we want to use down in the component
tree in the application. In this case, it's
going to be estate value and a setter that
we're going to use. So the context can be
any value that you want to provide down to
your application. But it's really, really
handy if we want to have a state and a setter
that we want to be able to access from anywhere
in the application. So I'm going to export
this one because we have to import the context
in the component where we want to use it.
So export const, I call it context. With capital
C, you can call it whatever you want. It doesn't
need to be named context. And from react.we
have something that's called create context.
And I call this one. You could also of course,
imported up here, like this. We can do that
instead. If you feel that that is better.
I don't know really. All right. Then I'm going
to create something that's called a provider.
The provider is going to wrap our application
and make sure that we provide this value to
our application so we can decide where we
want to wrap this provider in our application.
In our case, we're going to wrap it in the
app component later so that we can The value
to our complete application. So we wrap it
high up in the hierarchy, so that the complete
application and all the components will have
access to this value. So I created a const,
I call this component use a provider, I destructure
out the children's, because we're going to
use this component to wrap our application.
So that means that the children is going to
be the app. In this case, I have a fat arrow.
And then I'm going to create a state const.
State Set state just as we did before, I call
the use state hook. And I can give it the
value of undefined as initial value. Right,
that's our state's we creating this one in
the use of provider, then we want to provide
this one to our application. So I'm going
to return from the context we created up here.
context, that's a component, we have something
that's called a provider. So context dot provider,
capital C, capital P, and then we have a prop
is called value and inside the value prop,
we can provide this value that we want our
application to have access to. So a curly
brackets, and I want to provide an array with
the state and the set state, that will make
sure that we get the exact same structure
as we do here with the state, we have the
state itself, and then we have the setter
in an array. So that's what I'm doing here,
I'm giving it the exact same structured array.
Alright, so inside this one, we're going to
return the children. And this makes sure that
we can use this provider to wrap any component
in our react application, and it will provide
it with these values. Now we have to export
default use of provider like this, save this
file, we finished here. This is how you set
up a global context and a state that you want
your application to be able to access globally.
Now, we're going to move inside of the app.js
file, and inside this file up here somewhere,
we can mark it with context. And we import,
use the provider. That's the one we created
from dot forward slash context. All right,
so that's our provider component. And we want
to place it high up in the hierarchy. So we
can just place it here inside of the router.
Use a provider like this. And we're gonna
take this one here and move it down and do
some auto formatting. So we're wrapping or
complete application inside of the use of
provider. And this makes sure that our complete
application will have access to the state
that we created. So we're going to use this
one later. But first, we're going to create
a login page. So that's what we're going to
start doing in the next video. We're going
to start creating our login component. And
I didn't say that I'm using the version of
the application without TypeScript. So you
shouldn't use the one with TypeScript use
the original one that we finished before we
did anything with TypeScript. And also before
we refactor it to classes, because I'm using
the functional component version, just to
be super clear, so that you know what product
you're using for this one. Alright, let's
move on inside of the components folder, we're
going to create a new component component
that called login dot j, s, capital L. And
we import react. And we're also going to need
you stayed and use context, that's the new
hook that we're going to use to grab our context.
I'm going to show you that in a second. And
we import this one's from react. Then we're
going to import something that's called use
navigate from react dash, router dash DOM.
And this one is used if you want to navigate
programmatically in your application, then
we're going to need a functions that I showed
you in the API file, so import API from dot
dot forward slash API. For this one, we're
going to reduce the button component. So I
marked it with components import button from
dot forward slash bottom. Right. And then
we're also going to create some styles for
this one. So we can actually do that now and
scaffold them out first. So we create a new
file in the components folder that's called
login dot styles dot j s. We're going to create
the actual styles in the next video. But for
now, we import styled from styled components.
And we export const wrapper and it equals
A styled dot div and double backticks save
the file Go back to the long end note as we
marked it with styles and import refer from
dot forward slash login styles, login login
dot stars like this, and then we need our
context. So I marked it with context. And
we import context from dot dot forward slash
context. And that's, of course, the one that
we created before. All right, then we can
create our component cost login equals, we
don't have any props for this one, to make
an explicit return, and we have a return statement.
And we can create the JSX. First, I'm just
going to export default first also. So don't
forget that one export default login. In the
return statement, we're first going to return
a wrapper. And inside a rapper, I'm going
to create the label. I'm going to type in
username colon, number load at one, I created
an input field input, the type is going to
be text, the value we're going to grab the
value later from the state. So I'm gonna just
mark it with state value for now. And the
name is going to be username. The onchange
is going to be handled input. And that's the
function that we're going to create, we can
scaffold this one out here, first const handle
input equals on our function, we're going
to take in the event, I can skip the parentheses
as it's the only one parameter. And we just
create an empty function from now like this.
Then we're also going to have a function that's
called handle Submit. And we'll leave it empty
for now also. Right, so let's continue here
with the input. So we can close this one here,
then we create another input field. type for
this one is going to be password. We don't
want to show the characters that the user
type in this one, because it's the password
input box value is also going to be a state
value that we're going to add. The name for
this one is password. And onchange is also
going to be handled input. So we have the
same function to both of these input fields,
and we close it here, then we're going to
have a submit button and we use a component,
the bottom component, the text is going to
be login. And also we don't have to provide
us with a prop that's called text and we send
in the text, we could also wrap the text with
this component if we want to do that instead.
And then we grab the text with the children
prop. We have a callback. And that's going
to be the handle Smith for this one. Do some
auto formatting, save it. So that's the basic
structure of our component, we want to be
able to use this component so we have to create
a new route for it. And we can do that in
the app.js file. First up here with where
we have the components, we're going to import
login from dot forward slash components forward
slash login, they will have the component
and then we can create it somewhere here we
create a new route with a path. This one is
going to be shown when we go to the path login,
the forward slash login and the element is
going to be our component. Login. And then
we close the route component and some more
formatting, save it, go back to our application,
make sure that it's running. I'm actually
not running mine. So I'm going to type in
NPM start. Whoa, I heard it really sumed in
here. And I'm going to bring up the console
for later. So if we go up here in the route,
and type in forward slash login, you can see
that we show our component here. So that is
working. Great. Go back to the application
and the login component. We're going to create
a few states for this one. So at the top of
the login component, we create a state that
we call user name and set the username, equals
use state are going to create an empty string
as initial state for this one, we create another
state, that's called password. And the setter
is called Set password equals use state with
an empty string as initial value also for
this one, something like that. And then I
also want to notice state, that's called error
and set error. And we have a use state call.
And we set it to false initially. So these
are the three states that we have, you could
also have won combined states for input fields,
if you want to have that is used to create
them separately like this, then we're going
to grab our context, we're importing it up
here. And we can grab the context with a hook
that's called use context. And our context
is going to be the state that we created.
So we create a new cost. And we can just structure
it out just as before, we have the state,
the state is actually going to be the user.
So we can be more specific, we call it the
user and the set user. And it equals, we call
the use context hook. And this works as simple
as we just give it the context. And this one
is going to bring in the context for us. And
the user, we're not going to use this one,
we're only going to use the set user, we can
mark it with an underscore. If we want to
do that. This is also very subjective on how
you like to do stuff like this, then we have
a hook that we will see imported for our navigation.
So we create a course that we call navigate.
And we call that hook use navigate. And this
will make it possible for us to use this navigate
const to navigate programmatically in our
application. Alright, so first, we're going
to make these input fields controlled by this
component. So we have to hook them up with
state just as we did with the search bar.
And we have this handle input here, where
we get the event from the input field, so
the input fields, the value for this one,
we can change this one now. It's going to
be the state that's called username. No, not
a capital N, all lowercase letters, and this
one is going to have the value from the password
state. All right. So this will make sure that
it is connected to the state. So now when
these input fields change, we can make that
change in the handle input because we have
an on change handler on them. And we can set
the different states in the handle input.
And you can see here that I give them a name.
So first, we want to grab the name. So I create
a const name equals e dot current target dot
name, and this one is going to grab the name
that are set here on the name prop. Then we
have another cost with the value. And we get
that one from e dot current target dot value.
So we need the name and the value. And actually,
you could do this in a one liner. If we use
just one state for our input fields, we could
set the name of the properties in an object
dynamically with the name that we get from
the input field. And then we set the value
so that will create new values in the object.
Depending on how many input fields we add
to our application. But in this case, I have
a separate state for each input field. So
I do it like this instead, in a small application
like this, I think this is more readable,
actually. But this means that we have to check
now what input box that we type in. So we
have an if statement. If named equals username,
then we're going to set the username stayed
with the set username, stay setter, and we
have the value. So we set the name of the
input box, and then we get the value. If the
name is username, we know that we should set
the state for the username. So that's what
we do in here. And if the name equals password,
we're going to set the password state. And
we give this one the value also. This one
maybe should have a lowercase m instead not
an uppercase, so we change this one just to
be consistent. Or format it save it and we
can see if it works, go back to the application.
And we can type something in here. And yeah,
it works. So we know that we have our control
components. So that's great. So our input
fields are working, then we'll have to submit
something and actually grab something from
the API to make the login. And we do that
in the handle submit function. The first thing
we're going to do is to set the error to false
just when we did when we finished our movies,
and then I have a try block and then a catch
block and we have the error. For this catch.
We can set that or True. That's the only thing
we're going to do inside of the catch block.
So we're going to be in the try block now.
And first, we need to get the request token.
So I create a new const. I actually noticed
now also that I forgot to bump up the font
size. So I'm going to do that now, from now
on is going to be bigger. Okay, so I have
a cost with a request token. We're going to
wait from the API, I have this function GET
request token. And of course, this one has
to be an async function, because we are waiting
here. So Mark this one with a sync. So that
will hopefully get us the request token, if
something goes wrong here, the catch block
will set the error to true and we're going
to handle that just in a second down in the
JSX. The cost, we're going to grab the session
ID We await again, from the API, I have a
function that's called authenticate. And for
this one, we're going to give it the request
token first. And then we give it the username,
and then the password. All right, that will
hopefully get us our session ID. And then
we can set the user. And this one, the set
user is actually the context that we created,
because we're grabbing the context here and
the setter for the user. So we're setting
this one in the context, I'm going to set
it with an object First, I want to set the
session ID. So I gave it from the session
ID that's the one that we'll get back from
the API. We have a property that's called
session underscore ID, all lowercase letters,
and then I'm going to set the username. And
as this is also e6 syntax, I don't have to
type out this twice, because it will interpret
this automatically. Alright, and then we just
have one more thing to do. And that is we
have to navigate somewhere when we successfully
logged in. So we can navigate programmatically
with react router, we use the navigate that
we got here from that hook us navigate, we
placed that one, we placed what we get back
here in the navigate cost. So navigate parenthesis
and we just specify the URL. And in this case,
we want to go to the homepage. So we specify
it like this. And I want to do some console,
log in here, console log, the session ID just
to see that we get something here, save the
file, go back to our application. And now
we haven't styled this one. We're going to
do that in the next video. But we can use
the input fields here anyways. So my login
is vevo and then I have my password that I'm
not going to tell you something like this,
and I tried to log in. And you can see that
we get this object back from API, we get the
session ID and the success is telling us true.
So that's really, really neat. We know that
our login system is working, and it redirected
us to the homepage. To go back to the login
page. I want to do one more thing here before
we finished with the logic for this component.
Down below here just above the first label,
I have a curly bracket and I'm going to create
a short circuit, I'm going to check if the
error is true. Double ampersand If the error
is true, we're going to have a div with a
class name of error. And then I'm just going
to say there was an error, something like
this. And then I want to format it. And then
I'm going to say this file. So you can of
course type in whatever you want to save the
file, go back to the application. So just
try to type something in here and click Login.
And you can see that we show this one here.
Instead, there was an error. And we also get
an error in our console. So we know that the
try and catch block is working. So this is
our login component and the logic and in the
next video, we're going to create the styles
for this component. We have our login component
and the functionality for that one. And now
we're going to create the stars for it. So
go back inside of the code editor and the
login dot styles dot j s file. We have our
wrapper that's the only style component that
we use him for this one. First, we're going
to display it as a flex. we align dash items
to center and we justify the content Center
also just the center stuff. Then we set the
flex direction on this one is going to be
column and we can save it to see what we've
got so far. You can see that we're centering
it here in the middle of the screen. So that's
great. Go back to the code, I'm going to set
a max width to 320 pixels, the padding is
going to be 20 pixels. And the color is going
to be from the variables, we have a color
that's named dark gray. So double dash dark
grey. Save it go back just to see what we've
got, right? When I set the max width to 320
pixels, it's showing it to the left. But if
we set the margin to zero and auto, and save
it, that will place it in the center again,
so that's great. All right. So that's everything
for the wrapper. Now we have the input, we
nest, this one inside of the wrapper component,
we set the width to 100%. On the input fields,
the height is going to be 30 pixels. border
is going to be one pixel solid. We have a
variable for color. And we also use dark gray
for that one. Then we set the border dash
radius to 20 pixels, the margin is going to
be 10 pixels and zero. And the padding is
going to be 10 pixels, save the file, go back
to the application. And you can see that we
created this nice little input fields here
sweet with rounded corners, and it matched
the overall the overall look of the application.
Then we just want to style our error class
also dot error. And for that one, I'm just
going to set the color to red. You can style
this a little bit better if you want to do
that. So if we type something in here and
click login, you can see that this is the
error. All right. And that's actually it for
this login component, I'm not going to do
any heavy styling, as this is the bonus section
of this course. So if you want to do it nicer,
you can do that yourself. In the next video,
we're going to be in the header and showed
a logged in user and also have a log in bottom.
Okay, let's create the login system from the
header, we're going to show a bottom to log
in. And I'm just going to place it in the
middle actually here. It may be should be
to the right. But yeah, as I told you, I'm
not doing any heavy styling for this section.
So you can style it to your own liking later.
So let's go back inside of the application
and inside the header component, so the header
folder and the index.js file. The one thing
we need to add to the imports here is to actually
import the context. So we import context.
From dot dot forward slash and dot dot forward
slash, again, we have the context file like
this. And this one is making an implicit return.
Now we need to have some functionality inside
of it, we have to change this one into an
explicit return. Like this, we add the return
statement here or reformat it just to make
it a little bit nicer. Some people also have
the formatting to activate when you save the
file, I'll actually I actually don't like
that, because sometimes when I save it, and
I'm not finished, it starts to format stuff.
And I don't like that. That's why I do it
manually, instead. Alright, const user, we're
going to grab the user from the context, we
don't need to set anything here, we just need
the user. And recall the use context hooked,
we actually need to import that one also appear.
So import react comma, curly brackets use
context. So we give this use context, hook
the context. And this will bring us the user.
So we don't need to destructure out the setter
for the state, we just need to use so so that's
why we're not destructuring out that one.
And we can do a console log user like this.
Save the file, go back to our application,
I'm going to try to login again. I click Login.
And you can see that we get this console log
here. So we have the session ID and the username
of vaman. And that's of course for vaman fault.
All right, so we know that our context is
working great. And that's sweet. So go back
to the index.js file in the header folder.
And now we can use this one here. So just
between the two logos here. I'm going to create
curly brackets. And the first thing I'm going
to do is to check if we have a user and then
I create a ternary operator. So I have a question
mark, parenthesis and the first thing I'm
going to do if we have User are going to show
a span with a class name of logged in, like
this. And I'm going to type out logged in
as colon. And then I have new quarter brackets,
and I grabbed the use of dot username. And
that's from the object that we get back from
the context, of course. So when we are logged
in, we're going to show the text logged in
as and we also show in the username. Otherwise,
if we're not logged in, we have a colon, here,
we have a new pair of parenthesis, are going
to use the link component. And it's going
to link to if you remember this one, the link
component is the one that we use from react
router to navigate inside of our application.
This one is going to link to the login page
like this. And inside the link, I'm going
to have a spam that has a class name of login.
And it says login and then do some nice auto
formatting. I'm going to move this one off
and save the file and see if it works. Go
back to the application, we can't hardly see
it here. We're going to style this in a second.
But we have a login button. So it takes us
to the login page. So here again, I'm going
to log in. And this is something that you
also can do if you want you can store the
user information in the session storage or
in the local stories, there's a lot of discussion
going on, on what is the best practices to
use. In this case, we have a session ID, so
we have to request a new session ID on each
session from the Movie Database API. So I'm
just storing it in the application itself.
So that means that it will get wiped out every
time you reload application, I had to log
in. Again, if this was in the real world,
we probably would have a login system that
will also save this token somewhere. So you
don't have to log in every time. And I actually
have a YouTube video, where I show how to
create a back end and set up JSON Web tokens
and how to create a login system in a react
application. So this is a very simple use
case on how you can create a login system
here. All right, that was a side note, I'm
going to click the Login button. And hopefully
up here Yeah, you can see that we showing
logged in as beiben. So it's working, we have
to give it some styling also. And this is
just going to be a couple of rows. So I'll
do it in this video. So inside the header.styles.js
inside here, we actually don't need the class
names that are set, we can just set the color
to a variable of white, like this, and then
we have the a tag, I set the color to the
same variable there, double dash white. And
the text dashed declaration is going to be
set to none. Auto format. Let's save it. And
also if we want, we can remove these classes,
we don't need them, we can just have a span
on this one's awesome thing like this, save
the file, go back to the application, you
can see that now we see it. And yeah, this
is probably not the most beautiful way, it
doesn't look that good, because I'm just placing
it in the middle. Now, we would have some
dedicated space for a login button and stuff
like that. But this is just to show the functionality.
So I'm not going to style it any better than
this. So I clicked the login. And I log in
again. click the Login button, whoops, something,
I guess I typed the password wrong here. I
log in again. And that works. And now we can
see that we have this white text instead.
And it tells us that I'm logged in. So that's
great. In the next video, we're going to create
the rate component that we're going to show
somewhere here, I think we're almost finished
with the voting system. But we need a rating
component that we can place here in the movie
info component. So we're going to create that
will now move back inside of the code editor
and inside of components create a new folder
that we call Wraith, capital R. And inside
of that folder, we create a new file that's
called index dot j s and I actually not going
to have any styling for this one. I'm going
to use the components as they are. So first
I'm going to import react. And I'm also going
to need the use state for this one. Because
it is going to be a control component I imported
from react. Then I create my component rate
equals, and I'm going to destructure out the
callback for this one. Because when we vote,
we need to have a callback function that will
do something. And in this case, it's going
to send a request to the API. That's a component
I'm also going to export default rate like
this. And the first thing we do in this component
is to create a state with a value and set
value equals use state And we're going to
start with the value five, the rating is going
to be between one and 10. And then we have
the return statement and we return our JSX.
So I'm going to make it simple here, I create
a wrapping div, and then I create an input.
And the type is going to be range. So we create
a range slider, the min value is going to
be one, the max is going to be turn, and the
value is going to be our state value. And
then on change, we have to change this state
value. So I want to show you also that you
can create an inline function instead of creating
a function up here to where the event E, I
create an inline arrow function. And then
we set the value e dot turn target dot value,
and this is enough. And we will close this
component. Alright, so that's a range slider
after the range slider, we want to show of
our value like this. And then I create a p
tag just to get it on a new row. And I create
a button. I have an onClick handler on this
button. And in this case, we have an inline
arrow function because we are going to call
our callback with a value. And we give it
the value if we don't have this inline arrow
function here, and we just type it out like
this, then it's going to instantly run this
and it won't work. So we have to have an inline
function here as we providing an argument
to this callback function. Right, close it
and inside of the button with type out rate,
do some more formatting, save it, we're gonna
move inside of movie info component in the
index.js file. And up here where we import
the thumb, we also got to import our rate
component, dot dot forward slash rate. And
then we're going to show the rate component
somewhere below. theme, we're going to place
it Yeah, maybe here, just above the M tag
for the text. So I create a new div and inside
that div, I have a p tag rate movie. And below
that one, we use a rate component. And for
now, we don't have a function that we're going
to send into this one the callback function.
So just showing the component just to see
that it works and shows up, save the file.
Go back to the application. And you can see
that we have the rate slider here. And we
have a rate bottom, it doesn't work. Now,
as you can see, because we're not sending
in the callback function to it. But this one
will work in the next video, because we're
going to tie all this together and make it
work so that when we press this red button,
we will send along this rating number to the
API, and we will rate this movie. Alright,
we're almost finished. And this is actually
the last video in this course. So hope you
enjoy the course, we're going to tie this
together. So let's move inside of the code
and inside the movie info component in the
index.js file, the first thing we have to
do is to grab the context, the context or
import context, from dot dot forward slash
and dot dot forward slash again, and context.
So we're going to use the context. And that
means that we also need to import from up
here, the use context hooked. Right. And now
you hopefully can see how handy it is to have
this global state because we can access it
from any component in the application. And
in this case, we're going to grab the user
and the session ID. So you can send along
the session ID to the API when the user rate
the movie. And now we're making this implicit
return, we're going to change this one to
an explicit return, so return and I created
curly bracket, and then we need to have one
below also. There is some auto formatting,
and go back up if it's in space. And first,
we're going to grab the user from our context,
just as we did before the cost user use context.
And we've given you the context. So this will
give us the user here. And then we are going
to send in a callback function to our rate
component here. So we're creating this function
here in this component and send it along to
the rate component. We're going to call this
function calls handle rating. This is going
to be an async function because we're making
a an API call. We have the value And then
we can do some stuff inside of here. So this
value is going to be the value from the range
slider. So create a new cost rate equals,
then I wait. And from the api.id and I imported
up here. No, I also need to import the API.
We do that up here, import API from dot dot
forward slash dot dot forward slash API, like
this, then I go back down here and change
this one. API dot, I'm going to grab the function
that's called rate movie. And if you want
to know more about these functions, you can
always check them out in the api.js file.
Because I told you probably too many times
now that I pre made these functions for you.
So you don't have to do that in this course.
Alright, move back to the movie and for an
index.js file. So the rate movie function
is going to take in three arguments. So we
have the user dot session ID. And we have
the movie ID, because we need to know the
movie ID of the movie that we want to rate.
And we also want to give it the value, that's
the rating value. Right. And that's actually
everything we need to do. In this case, I
just want to console log out to rate to see
that we get something back and that the rating
was working. So we can use this handle rating.
Now down below here, we can give it to the
rate component, we have a prop. That's called
callback. And we give it to hand reading and
save the file. And hopefully this should be
it. Go back to the application. Yeah, we have
one more thing to do, because I don't want
to show this rate slider when we're not logged
in. So we can do that also. So just here,
when we have the rating, outside of the wrapping
dem are going to create a ternary operator,
I'm going to check if you sir. Then I'll double
ampersand, and I move my M curly bracket down
here or to format it. And it will also auto
generate this parenthesis. So if the user
exists, if we're logged in, we're going to
show the rating. Otherwise, we don't show
anything. Save the file go back to our application,
you can see that we're not showing the rate
slider now we have to log in. So we click
the Login button, and I log in. And now we're
logged in, we're going to go to movie here.
Now you can see that we see the rating slider.
So I don't actually know if this movie is
any good, but I'm going to give it a rating
or eight. And I click the red button. And
here you can see in the console that we got
a success of true and status code one, a status
message success. And if we click rate again,
you can see that we get another message because
it says that the item record was updated successfully.
So you can update your rating score. If you
want to do that. There's also a resource in
the endpoint if you want to remove the score
also. So there are some neat stuff that you
can do with the Movie Database API. And I
hope this inspired you to actually build more
stuff into this application, because now you
have a good foundation. And for example, the
next step you can do is to create a logout
button for the user. And the way I would do
it in this case is that I can just wipe out
the global context the state here and remove
the user from the global state. And that will
log out the user we don't have to do anything
else with the Movie Database API or something
like that. Alright, that's it for this course.
I hope you enjoy this. I sure enjoy this.
This is the third iteration of the course.
So this is the third time that I actually
update it and re recorded from scratch. And
if you want free tutorials, you can always
visit my YouTube channel, search for vaman
Fox, or you can go to vevo in fact.com if
you want more courses from me